SUNSET REVIEW. OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS OF THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS IN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TODAY WE
WILL BE CONDUCTING OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS TO REVIEW THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
THE BOARD OF THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR THE BEER OF
ELECTRONICS AND APPLIANCE REPAIR
HOME FURNISHINGS AND THERMAL
INSULATION.
THE THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
BUREAU AND THE CALIFORNIA TAX
EDUCATION COUNCIL AS WAS THE
CASE LAST WEEK. TO ASSIST THE
MEMBERS AND THE THE PUBLIC IN
THEIR REVIEW AND EVALUATION OF
EACH AGENCY COMMITTEE STAFF.
PREPARED BACKGROUND PAPERS WHICH
IDENTIFY ISSUES AND PROVIDE
STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH
PROGRAM. THESE PAPERS HAVE BEEN
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITES AND MADE AVAILABLE TO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES.
WE WILL ASK EACH PROGRAM TO
BEGIN HEIR TESTIMONY WITH BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THEIR FUNCTIONS AND
TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
RAISED BY STAFF.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES WILL
COMMITTEES WILL ALSO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS WHICH THEY
MAY HAVE WE WILL ALSO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS. PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC FOR EACH PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. OF LIKE TO
INVITE THE CO CHAIR OF TODAY'S
HEARINGS AS A SIMPLE MEMBER
SEVEN LOW WHO'S THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. OF TO
MAKE HIS COMMENTS IN THE TO BE
INHERENT RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET THIS GUY GET STARTED
THEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR. OF SO FIRST UP WE ON THE
AGENDA IS THE CALIFORNIA TAX.
EDUCATION COUNCIL ALONG WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM C. TAKE IF
YOU COULD KINDLY. MAKE YOUR WAY
UP TO THAT TO THE DYESS WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD AS WELL AS OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO. PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE COUNCIL AND SO
RIBS AND IS PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
COME UP TO THE. MICROPHONE. AND
WELCOME WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
GOOD MORNING. MY NAME IS LESTER
CRAWFORD AND I AM THE CURRENT
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX
EDUCATION COUNCIL. ALSO KNOWN AS
THE TRUCK. ALSO WITH ME FROM US
HERE TO JUST THREE THIRTY
MINISTRY.
THEY ARE AND STAFF FROM THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD.
DID YOU COMPRO AND GIGI JONES
PUBLIC RELATIONS. ALISON SPIEGEL
OUR LEGAL COUNSEL.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO DISCUSS OUR PROGRAM
WITH YOU.
THIS IS THE THIRD TIME'S THE
TECH HAS APPEARED BEFORE THE
SUNSET REVIEW COMMITTEE.
AS STATED IN YOUR REPORT IN
NINETEEN NINETY SIX A LAW PASSED
BY THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE.
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR CREED OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION
COUNCIL A PUBLIC BENEFIT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT ENTITY CHARGED WITH
ENSURING QUALIFIED TAX
PREPARERS.
SERVE CALIFORNIA TAX PAYERS.
THE FLOOR TRANSFERRED FROM THE
TRIP OUR TAX PREPARER PROGRAM.
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS TO THE CALIFORNIA TAX
EDUCATION COUNCIL. THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR APPROVING
TECH SCHOOLS. AND CERTIFYING TAX
PREPARERS.
RED ROCKS PERSON. FOR IT.
OBSESSED WITH A PROPELLER
SPINNER OR SPINNEY TAX RETURNS
FOR OTHERS.
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS
LICENSED BY THE CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF ACCOUNTANCY. IN ROAD AGENTS
AND RODE WITH THE INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE. ATTORNEYS WERE
ACTIVE MEMBERS OF THE STATE BAR
OF CALIFORNIA. AND EMPLOYEES OF
THESE INCIDENTS ARE ARE EXEMPT.
FROM THE LAW.
THE TIME OF THE TRANSFER THE
RIVER TO RESPONSIBILITY TO.
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND REGISTER PROPELLERS
WERE IN THE STREET.
TODAY YOU SEE TALK REGISTERS
ALMOST FORTY HOURS IN COMPUTERS
ANNUALLY.
SENATOR REGISTERED TAX PREPARERS
ALSO KNOWN AS C. R. T. PLEASE.
ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE AN INITIAL
SIXTY HOURS OF QUALIFYING
EDUCATION. AND TWENTY HOURS OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION ANNUALLY
FROM CITY TECH APPROVED
PROVIDERS.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS TAKING THE
SIXTY HOUR QUALIFYING EDUCATION
COURSE MUST PASS A PRIMER EXAM.
PROVIDED BY THE PROVIDER.
THERE ARE TWO PEAS ARE ALSO
REQUIRED TO HAVE A PARTY FOR
HOURS AND DOLLARS SURELY BOND.
PROVIDERS OF THE SIXTY HOUR
CURRICULUM DEVELOPED THEIR OWN
COURSE MATERIAL. AND FINALEXAM
THAT MUST INCLUDE SPECIFIC
SUBJECT MATTER. OUTLINED IN THE
TECH POLICY.
CAN A DESERTED RESTAURANT
PROPELLERS CENTER APPROVES TAX
EDUCATION SCHOOLS.
THIS CRUISE CORPORATE AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW PROCESS.
OUR ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF AS WELL
AS. WRITTEN REVIEW BY SEA TURTLE
CONTRACTOR PROFESSIONALS AND
OTHER AFTER THE MONEY SHE EARNS.
EVERY THREE YEARS.
THEY'RE APPROVED PROVIDER IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE THE MATERIALS
WE REVIEWED.
CURRENTLY SEE TURKEY HAS
APPROXIMATELY ONE HUNDRED
APPROVE SCHOOLS. ARE PUT IN BOTH
CLASSROOM AND ONLINE COURSES.
AND YOU'RE READY TO TACKLE THE
CURRICULUM PROVISION.
CURRICULUM PROVIDER TASK FORCE
MEETING IN SACRAMENTO. TO REVIEW
PROVIDER POLICIES ANSWER
PROVIDER QUESTIONS AND RECEIVE
INPUT FROM PROVIDERS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THEIR RESOLVE ISSUES
THEY MAY HAVE. CONCERNING THE
TECH.
ESSENTIAL TO THE SUCCESS OF THE
FEEDER PROGRAM HAS BEEN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF IT THE STATE OF
THE ART COMPUTER SYSTEM. ONLINE
REGISTRATION.
WITH THE ONLINE REGISTRATION
SYSTEM APPROVED PROVIDERS ARE
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT STUDENT
COURSE INFORMATION
ELECTRONICALLY.
PROVIDERS ARE GIVEN A CERTAIN
TIMEFRAME BY WHICH THIS
INFORMATION MUST BE SUBMITTED TO
THE TECH.
DURING YOUR REGISTRATION CYCLES
FEAR TEA PLEASE ARE ABLE TO GO
ONLINE WITH VIEW THEIR EDUCATION
AND RENEW REGISTRATION.
THE EDUCATION HAS NOT BEEN
SUBMITTED BY A PROVIDER. IS THE
RTP REMARK ABLE TO RENEW.
UNLIKE THE MADAM RANDOM. PART OF
BEING A SELECTED CERTIFIED
PUBLIC ACCOUNTANTS AND IN ROAD
AGENTS.
SENATOR BAER BARS THE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS ARE IT REPAIR.
PRIOR TO THEIR INITIAL
REGISTRATION AND SUBSEQUENT
ANNUAL REGISTRATION.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITIES UNDERTAKEN BY
SEA TAC. IS TO EDUCATE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS ARE FOR
ELECTING A LEGAL TAX PREPARER.
AND YOUR BUDGET OF APPROXIMATELY
APPROXIMATELY A QUARTER MILLION
DOLLARS IS ALLOCATED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. ADVERTISING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SENATOR CONTRACTS RIPLEY PUBLIC
RELATIONS FIRM. TO DEVELOP A
CLEAR CONCISE MESSAGE REGARDING
TAX PROFESSIONALS. ARRANGE MEDIA
INTERVIEWS DURING TAX SEASON
PROVIDED DIFFERENT MARKETING
CAMPAIGN BRAZEN INFOGRAPHICS.
AND DEVELOPING SOCIAL MEDIA.
CENTER TO USERS TWITTER.
SPORT AND YOU TROOPS TO HELP
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE
TECH AND C. R. T. PLEASE.
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN FREE
ADVERTISING SEARCHES PARK
SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENTS SOCIAL
MEDIA AND MEDIA INTERVIEWS.
ARE ALSO UTILIZED TO
DISCRIMINATE. OUR MESSAGE.
BROCHURES POSTERS IN A TENDER
FOR TAX PROTESTERS SEMINARS.
ANTIBODIES TO THE PERMIT.
WHAT TURNS OF SELECTING A LEGAL
TAX PREPARER?
THE KEY. TO. OUR.
IT IS ENFORCEMENT.
FOR THIS REASON FIFTY PARTNERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD TO PROVIDE THE NEEDED
ENFORCEMENT ARM. OF THE PROGRAM.
C. TECH PROJECTS BETWEEN THREE
HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY. FOR
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO
PROVIDE THIS SERVICE.
IN RETURN THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD FRAUD. UNIT INVESTIGATORS
ARE ARAB VERIFYING REGISTRATION.
AND STRIDING ILLEGAL PROPELLERS.
ALL PENALTIES COLLECTED BY THE
PLANTS ARE TAX BOARD. GOING TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
GENERAL FIRM.
SERVER CONCEPTION IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN. NO GOVERNMENT
FUNDS HAVE BEEN SPENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION. OF THE THREE
TECH PROGRAM.
IT IS ENTIRELY FUNDED FROM THE
ANNUAL REGISTRATION FOR THE.
THIRTY THREE DOLLARS. AND A LATE
REGISTRATION FEE OF FIFTY FIVE
DOLLARS.
IN CLOSING ESCHEATOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION
COUNCIL.
ARMOR LIKE TO PERSONALLY FRANK
RELIGIOUSLY TOWARDS FOR CREATING
THIS ENTITY. THE LEGISLATIVE
STAFF FOR KEEPING HER FROM TRACK
IN OUR INTERFACING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
REPRESENTATIVES TO OUR BOARD FOR
THEIR PARTNERING WITH US IN
GIVING THE ILLEGAL PREPARERS.
OFF THE STREETS.
AS THE TURKS ADMINISTRATIVE
STAFF OUR FRONT CONTRACTORS.
HER MOM IN THE SUCCESS OF FREE
TECH.
AND FINALLY TO THE DEDICATED
VOLUNTEER MEMBERS OF THE BOARD
WHO HAVE SHOWN THEIR DESIRE TO
CARRY OUT THE GOALS AND MISSION.
ARBOR CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION
COUNCIL.
A BIT OF CALIFORNIA.
TAXPAYERS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE CO CHAIRS
SENATOR HILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW.
MEMBERS AND STAFF. MY NAME IS
ALISON SPIEGEL AND I AM C. TEX
COUNCIL. SEE TECH IS HAPPY TO
DISCUSS WITH THE COMMITTEE'S
ISSUE NUMBER THREE IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER.
C. TAC WAS INTENTIONALLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY CREATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE. OVER TWENTY YEARS
AGO TO SOLVE A PROBLEM. OTHER
THAN EXISTING PROBLEM OF THE DCA
TAX REPAIR PROGRAM THAT WAS
FAILING.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE CREATED
SEATAC IT CAREFULLY CONSIDERED
MANY DIFFERENT MODELS. WEIGHED
THE PROS AND CONS OF EACH. AND
SETTLED ON THE CURRENT NON
PROFIT MODEL. BY ALL MEASURES C.
TECH HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
SUCCESSFUL.
WHEN DCA AROUND THE TAX REPAIRS
PROGRAM IT WAS COMMON TO SEE
BOXES OVERFLOWING WITH
APPLICATIONS THAT HAD BEEN
SITTING ON PROCESS. FOR A YEAR
OR LONGER. AND HEAPS OF UNCASHED
CHECKS.
THE DC PROGRAM WAS RUN BY SEVEN
PEOPLE. IN THE ANNUAL FEES
VARIED WILDLY FROM YEAR TO YEAR.
IN SOME YEARS THERE WAS NO FEE
AND IN OTHERS IT WASN'T AS MUCH
AS FIFTY DOLLARS.
IN CONTRAST SEATAC IS A MODEL OF
PROCESSING EFFICIENCY.
WITH A STAFF OF THREE. AND AN
ANNUAL INDIVIDUAL REGISTRATION
AMOUNT OF ONLY THIRTY THREE
DOLLARS.
IT IMMEDIATELY PROCESSES
REGISTRATION OF TAX PREPARERS.
AFTER TAX APPEARS COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION. WHICH IS REPORTED
DIRECTLY FROM THE EDUCATION
PROVIDERS TO SEATAC.
REGISTRARTE TO GO ONLINE PAY
THEIR ANNUAL FEE. AND AT THE END
OF THE PROCESS THEY ARE NOTIFIED
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN REGISTERED.
AND ARE ABLE TO BEGIN PREPARING
RETURNS IMMEDIATELY.
C. TECH IS A PROGRAM THAT HAS
WORKED SUCCESSFULLY FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE DECIDED TO
CHOOSE THE STRUCTURE.
IT CAREFULLY BALANCE THE PROS
AND CONS.
AS A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
CORPORATION SEATAC HAS
INCREDIBLE FLEXIBILITY. AND IS
ABLE TO PROCESS APPLICATIONS
IMMEDIATELY FOR VERY LOW COST.
ITS POWER IS IN ITS STRUCTURE.
BUT IS A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
CORPORATION SEE TECH DOES NOT
HAVE SITE AND FIND A FORTY. NOR
DOES IT HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
GOVERNANCE GOVERNMENT IMMUNITY
AS A STATE AGENCY WOULD.
IT ALSO IS NOT SUBJECT TO MANY
OF THE LAWS APPLICABLE TO STATE
AGENCIES. SUCH AS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT OR THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT.
WHILE IT IS NOT SUBJECT TO THESE
PROVISIONS.
IT ALSO HAS NOT RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS FROM REGISTRANTS OR
THE PUBLIC THAT IT IS NOT
COMPLYING WITH THESE LAWS.
THE LEGISLATURE BALLAD OFF
BALANCE ALL OF THESE FACTORS
WHEN IT CREATED SEA TAC KNOWING
WHICH BODIES OF LAW WOULD AND
WOULD NOT APPLY. AND WISELY
DECIDED ON A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
MODEL.
ON THE WHOLE C. TECH BELIEVES
THAT THE SCALE TIPS
SIGNIFICANTLY IN FAVOR OF
REGISTRATION OF TAX PREPARERS BY
SEA TAC AS A PRIVATE NONPROFIT
ENTITY.
THE FACT THAT SEE TECH IS NOT
SUBJECT TO SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
LAWS IDENTIFIED IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THERE ISN'T PUBLIC ACCESS
OR ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE
ORGANIZATION.
ON THE CONTRARY SEATAC IS A VERY
TRANSPARENT ORGANIZATION WITH A
HIGH LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
FOR EXAMPLE AS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT CORPORATION WHY IS NOT
SUBJECT TO BUDGET BUDGET AUDITS
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IT
IS SUBJECT TO ANNUAL AUDITS BY
INDEPENDENT AUDITORS WHO
PUBLICLY REPORT THEIR FINDINGS
TO THE BOARD DURING OPEN
SESSION.
AND HIS REPORTS ARE AVAILABLE ON
LINE TO THE PUBLIC.
WHILE IT IS NOT SPECIFICALLY
SUBJECT TOO BADLY KEEN.
MOST OF THE GENDERS FOR BOARD
MEETINGS AT LEAST A WEEK IN
ADVANCE.
IT'S MEETING SCHEDULE IS
DETERMINED YEARS IN ADVANCE AND
FOR EXAMPLE. ITS MANE OF AMBER
DATES AND LOCATIONS FOR ITS
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BOARD MEETINGS
ARE ALREADY LISTED ON ITS
WEBSITE.
WHILE IT'S NOT SUBJECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT.
ITS PROCEDURES FOR DENIAL AND
DISCIPLINE ARE CLEARLY
ARTICULATED IN ITS STATUTE.
SEE TEX STRENGTH AND PROCESSING
EFFICIENCY EFFICIENCIES COME
FROM ITS STRUCTURE. AS A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT CORPORATION.
WHERE THE COMMITTEES TO DECIDE
TO IMPOSE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
REQUIREMENTS OF STATE GOVERNMENT
ON THIS PRIVATE NONPROFIT
CORPORATION? IT WILL LOSE MANY
OF THE BENEFITS IT HAS GAINED BY
THIS MODEL OF OPERATION.
C. TECH HAS A PROGRAM THAT WORKS
VERY WELL AND SEE TECH BELIEVES
THAT IT SHOULD CONTINUE IN ITS
CURRENT STATE.
C. TECH IS HAPPY TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEES ON ANY
LEGISLATIVE CHANGES THAT IT
BELIEVES ARE NECESSARY. THOSE C.
TECH DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT ANY
ARE NEEDED AT THIS TIME.
IN RELATION TO ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
IDENTIFIED IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER.
IT WAS NEVER THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT SEATAC BE AN
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
ITS LAWS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
STRUCTURED SO THAT OTHER
AGENCIES SUCH AS F. TB AND THE
IRS. BE IN CHARGE OF ENFORCEMENT
NOT SEATAC.
THIS INTENT CAN CLEARLY BE SEEN
BY THE FACT THAT SEE TECH DID
NOT HAVE ANY ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY BEFORE TWENTY
FOURTEEN.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN SEE TAKING
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DENY
APPLICATIONS AND DISCIPLINE
REGISTRANTS. IN AN ATTEMPT TO
ADDRESS A LIMITED ISSUE.
AROUND THIS TIME SEE TEXT SAW
THE LOOPHOLE WAS BEING USED BY
FORMER ACCOUNTANTS. WHO LOST
THEIR STATE LICENSES LICENSES
DUE TO DISCIPLINARY ACTION BEING
TAKEN BY THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY?
IN THESE CASES REVOKED
ACCOUNTANTS WERE REGISTERING
WITH C. TECH AS TAX PREPARERS.
AND SEE TECH HAD NO AUTHORITY TO
DENY THE REGISTRATION OR REVOKE
THEIR C. TECH REGISTRATION.
THIS LOOPHOLE HAS BEEN CLOSED
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
WELL SEE TECH HAS ONLY TAKEN
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST A
HANDFUL OF INDIVIDUALS.
THOSE CASES HAVE ALL STEM FROM
SITUATIONS WHERE THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY TOOK DISCIPLINARY
ACTION AGAINST THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
C. TAC IS NOT AT ITS HEART AN
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
AND IT BUT IT DOES BELIEVE THAT
ADEQUATELY PROTECT THE PUBLIC BY
REQUIRING ANNUAL EDUCATION FOR
TAX PREPARERS. AND PAYMENT OF A
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR BOND.
C. TECH DOES NOT CURRENTLY
REQUIRE REGISTRANTS TO SUBMIT TO
LIVE SCANNED AND DOES NOT GET
CRIMINAL HISTORY PORTING FROM
THE DOJ OR FBI.
INSTEAD SEE TECH RECEIVED
INFORMATION FROM THE IRS THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY. AND HAS
RECEIVED INFORMATION FROM TAKE
DATA TREASURY INSPECTOR GENERAL
FOR TAX ADMINISTRATION IN THE
PAST.
C. TAC DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
THERE WOULD BE A SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT BENEFIT. IF
APPLICANTS AND REGISTRANTS
REQUIRED TO SUBMIT TO A CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND CHECK FOR C. TECH
REGISTRATION. AND ANY SUCH
REQUIREMENT WOULD BE QUICK WOULD
CREATE OVERWHELMING
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS. THAT
WOULD RESULT IN INCREASED CROP
COSTS AND A LOSS OF PROCESSING
EFFICIENCIES.
IF SEATAC WERE TO SUDDENLY
REQUIRE AND RECEIVE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND PORTS REPORTS. IT
WOULD HAVE TO HIRE ATTORNEYS TO
REVIEW THESE REPORTS. AND
INTERPRET THEM FOR ALL
APPROXIMATELY FORTY THOUSAND
REGISTRANTS.
THIS WOULD TAKE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF TIME AND RESULT IN A
GREATLY INCREASED EXPENSE.
THEN THERE WOULD BE AN ONGOING
NEED FOR ATTORNEYS TO INTERPRET
SUBSEQUENT ARREST NOTIFICATIONS.
AS THEY ARE RECEIVED AND TO
REVIEW DOJ AND FBI REPORTS FOR
NEW REGISTRANTS.
APPLICANTS AND REGISTRADA BE
REQUIRED TO PAY FEES FOR LIFE
SCANS WHICH RANGE FROM FIFTY TO
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS A PERSON.
C. TAC WOULD HAVE TO IMPLEMENT A
NEW PROCESS AND PROCEDURE FOR
SENDING NO LONGER INTERESTED
NOTIFICATIONS TO THE DOJ. IN
SITUATIONS WHERE PEOPLE WERE NO
LONGER REGISTERED.
IT WOULD HAVE TO CHANGE ITS
CURRENT COMPUTER SYSTEM AND
APPLICATION PROCESSING SYSTEM.
SO THAT THESE CRIMINAL HISTORY
REPORTS COULD BE REVIEWED AND
APPROVED BEFORE REGISTRATION
WOULD BE ISSUED. INSTEAD OF THE
CURRENT PROCESS OF IMMEDIATELY
ISSUING REGISTRATIONS.
THE COST IN BOTH TIME AND MONEY.
TO IMPLEMENT ALL OF THESE
CHANGES WOULD BE STAGGERING.
SEE TAX CURRENT SYSTEM WORKS
WELL. WITH OTHERS AND GENERALLY
IN CHARGE OF ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITY NOT SEATAC.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF COMPLAINTS
DETECTS RECEIVES ARE FOR
UNREGISTERED ACTIVITY.
THESE COMPLAINTS ARE REFERRED TO
FTP WHO DETERMINES AT ITS OWN
DISCRETION WHICH INDIVIDUAL
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO ENFORCEMENT
ACTION.
C. TAXIS SEES NO NEED TO CHANGE
ITS HISTORIC ROLE IN ORDER TO
MAKE IT INTO SOMETHING IT WAS
NEVER INTENDED TO BE. AT GREAT
COST TO THE REGISTRANTS.
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WORKS WELL.
AND SEATAC DOES NOT BELIEVE THAT
ANY LEGISLATIVE CHANGES NEED TO
BE MADE IN THIS REGARD. BUT IS
HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEES TO EXPLORE THIS
ISSUE.
WITH RESPECT TO ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE. SUE THE REGISTRATION OF
TAX PROFESSIONALS WHO CONTINUE
TO. BE REGULATED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION
COUNCIL.
HE TOOK OUT THE REMARK TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE. SIMPLY
STERLING WE BELIEVE WE SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CONTINUE IN ITS
CURRENT FORMAT.
WE HAVE DONE AN INCREDIBLE JOB
WITH PROCESSING REGISTRATION
TIMELY AND EFFICIENCY.
THERE HAVE BEEN NO COMPLAINTS
AGAINST THE THEATER
ORGANIZATION.
I'M NO CONTROVERSIAL PROGRAMS.
WE BELIEVE THAT IF WE ARE
ALLOWED TO PERFORM IN ITS
CURRENT FORMAT. CONTINUED THE
PROPER PROCESSES THAT WE HAVE
NOW. AND IT WILL CONTINUE TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. FROM YOUR
LEGAL TAX PROFESSIONALS.
WE ARE OPEN FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND HE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR SURE APPRECIATE THE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TODAY ARE YOU MISTER
CRAWFORD I GUESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS.
IS THE OR THE COMES TO MIND IS
THAT THE THE SEA TAC HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE FOR MANY YEARS YOU
SEEM TO HAVE A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH. WITH OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THE
SUCCESS OF THE OF THE THE
COUNCIL TO?
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU KNOW YOU
REGISTER IN A NUMBER THE RIGHT
NUMBER PEOPLE YOU'RE GOING AFTER
THOSE WHO HAVE HAD.
WHO HAVE BEEN TRYING TO BREAK
THE LAW OFFICE IN NOT
REGISTERING? A WHAT DO YOU
ATTRIBUTE THE SUCCESS TO.
I'VE BEEN ON THE COUNCIL OF
FOREIGN.
ACTUALLY THE LONGEST SERVING
MEMBER. ARE I BELIEVE.
GOING BACK IN THE EARLY DAYS.
ARM THERE ARE LOT OF COUNTLESS
HOURS THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
TRYING TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM A
SUCCESS. BUT THE PARTNERING WITH
THE INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE AND
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WITH
THEM AT OUR MEETINGS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
OUR WE'RE ABLE TO BRAINSTORM.
MEAN THESE TWO REGULATORY
AGENCIES. AS TO WHERE THIS
HAPPENED AFTER WHIMSY TOOK TOOK
OER. THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OF
THE ORGANIZATION THAT TOLD US
ABOUT FOOD ARMATURE PLAYERS. IN
EXCESS OF TEN THOUSAND.
WE IMMEDIATELY UNDERTOOK
PROGRAMS TO TRY TO SEE IFWE CAN
TO THE PROS INDIVIDUALS TO
REGISTER AND THAT'S WHERE WE
CAME UP WITH THE SITE AND FIND.
THEM ARE PARTNERED WITH THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO GO OUT
INTO THE FIELD TO TRY TO GET THE
IMAGE APPEARS TO REGISTER.
WE HAVE BEEN EXTREMELY
SUCCESSFUL.
IN THAT TOWN HAD IT NOT BEEN FOR
US COMING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. GIVING THEM OUR
PARENTS WE CAN HAVE THE OUR.
TEETH. WE CAN FIND INDIVIDUALS
FOR NOT BEING REGISTERED. WE
WOULD NOT BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS WE
ARE TODAY.
WE THANK YOU AND ONE MORE LIKE A
THANK YOU. FROM THE SEQUEL V.
YOU RAISE THE ISSUE OF
TRANSPARENCY AND AND.
OPEN MEETINGS AND AND THE THE
DUE PROCESS ISSUES THAT.
COME TO MIND IN. THE
TRANSPARENCY ISSUES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF A OF A PUBLIC.
BODY THAT WE WE'VE ALL NOTICED
AND YOU EXPLAIN SOME OF THOSE.
THOSE CONDITIONS AND THAT THE
THE WAY YOU DO BUSINESS TO. TO
CREATE THE THE OPENNESS OF THE
OF THE ORGANIZATION AND THE
COUNCIL.
DO YOU FIND OR HAVE YOU.
EXPERIENCED ANY PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE DEVELOPED BECAUSE OF THE.
FACT THAT YOUR COUNSEL OTHER
THAN A GOVERNMENT BOARD OR
EFFECTIVE AGENCY I MEAN YOU
YOU'RE IN THE BUSINESS OF. OF
REGISTERING PEOPLE NOT IN THE
BUSINESS OR NEED YOUR YOUR ROLE
IS NOT TO. REGULATE IN THE SENSE
OF YOU'RE NOT CREATING
REGULATIONS YOU'RE JUST
REGISTERING AS A AS A BODY DO
YOU SEE. A BETTER THIS IS BEEN A
PROBLEM OR CHALLENGE IN TERMS OF
YOUR ABILITY TO TO BE AS
TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE AND HAS
THERE BEEN A PROBLEM DEVELOP
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I CERTAINLY HAVEN'T SEEN AN
ISSUE WITH THAT.
I WOULD I WOULD ASK THAT LESTER
AND MAYBE CELESTA DRESS THAT IS
THEY ARE THE.
THEY'RE INVOLVED IN EVERY
MEETING BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY ISSUES
RAISED WITHOUT.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ESCORT US WE
ARE HEADED MAPPING FOR THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD PARTNERED
WITH THE TECH.
AREN'T WE WILL NOT HAVE THE
TEETH.
AND SERVICE NEVER BEEN A PROBLEM
WITH THE PUBLIC UNDERSTAND. WHO
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD? THE
ENFORCEMENT ARM.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL MEMORIES ARE FIGHTING
THESE A LITTLE BIT PLAYERS. BUT
ALSO CORRECT IN THE PINES THEIR
ISSUE.
OKAY. IN I GUESS WHEN I LOOK AT.
YOU KNOW THE. THE COUNCIL WAS
CREATED OF TWENTY YEARS AGO.
BASED ON CERTAIN CONDITIONS
CERTAIN ASSUMPTIONS AND NEEDS
BASICALLY OF TRYING TO REGULATE
AND A SENSE OF.
ADMINISTERING THE THE THE
LICENSING AND REGISTRATION OF OF
THESE THE PARTICIPANTS. HAVE YOU
SEEN ANYTHING OVER THE TWENTY
YEARS THAT HAS CHANGED.
IN.
THE INDUSTRY THAT WOULD REQUIRE
YOU TO CHANGE IN HOW YOU DO
BUSINESS OR HOW YOUR STRUCTURED.
AND THE. TWENTY.
OH EIGHT OF THE IRS DECIDED THAT
THEY. LIKED OUR PROGRAM SO MUCH
THAT THEY WANTED TO DO SOMETHING
NATIONALLY. AND THEY PROCEEDED
TO.
OFF WANT REQUIRE PETER NUMBERS
THEY WANTED TO REQUIRE AND THESE
WERE FOR THE NON EXEMPT
PREPARERS. AND THEY ALSO WANTED
A STANDARDIZED TEST FOR THESE
NON EXEMPT PREPARERS AS WELL AS
EDUCATION REQUIRED EDUCATION.
AND I THINK AT THAT POINT
SEATAC.
BECAUSE THE IRS DECIDED THAT
SINCE WE WERE REVIEWING THE
PROVIDERS AND APPROVING THEM.
THAT.
THEY WERE THEN GOING TO IF THEY
GOT A LETTER FROM US SAYING THAT
THIS PERSON THIS PARTICULAR
SCHOOL IS APPROVED. THEY WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY APPROVE IT AS WELL
SO.
AT THAT POINT SEE TECH DECIDED
THAT.
WE REALLY. NEEDED TO LOOK
CLOSER AT THE SCHOOLS WE WERE
APPROVING AND TO REALLY. MAKE A
CONCERTED EFFORT THAT ALL THE
COURSES WE WERE LOOKING AT WERE.
YOU.
REALLY A VERY GOOD COURSES AND
WE DEVELOPED A WHOLE NEW POLICY
FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT WE WERE
PROVING.
ARE THE CURRICULA OF THE TESTS
THAT WERE BEING GIVEN BY OUR
PROVIDERS AND I THINK THAT WAS A
VERY MAJOR CHANGE WITH SEA TAC.
AND THAT WAS WITH THE.
THE INVOLVEMENT OF THE IRS THAT
THAT'S CORRECT VERY GOOD. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AND THANK YOU
FOR ALSO FOR.
I THINK YOU'VE BEEN VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN THE MANNER IN
WHICH YOU'VE DONE BUSINESS AND
HOW YOU'VE DONE IT AND AND THE.
AND BY THE. I GUESS THE
EFFICIENCIES THAT YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO CREATE BECAUSE OF.
THE FACT THAT YOUR COUNSEL AND
IT'S MUCH APPRECIATED THANK YOU
THINK AFTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AS SOME OF
OUR GIFTED.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
I THINK THIS WAS THE
EXTRAPOLATION OF. BOSS OF MINE
STATE SENATOR BILL GREEN.
I WASN'T WORKING FOR ME AT THAT
TIME BUT I MY SIS NAME AS PART
OF THE CHAPTER AND THE AUTHOR OF
TEN SEVENTY SEVEN. HOWEVER WITH
THAT BEING SAID ARE THERE THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT STAFFERS
ARE RECOMMENDING DO YOU THINK
ANY OF THAT IS UNREASONABLE.
THE THE ISSUES THAT.
THE RECOMMENDATION FIBER.
YES I WE. WOULD DO THAT REALLY
DRESS THAT SAYS YEAH. IT WOULD
BE VERY DIFFICULT FOR US TO
ARMED TO THE ENFORCEMENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT.
ARE.
OUTLINED IN THOSE ISSUES ARM IT
WOULD IT WOULD BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR US AN AS ALISON
POINTED OUT THE COSTS WOULD BE
EXCEEDING TOOK MANY OF THE
PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE FOR FOURTEEN YEARS OUR FEES
WERE TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS. ARMED
AND THEN THEY WERE RAISED TO
THIRTY THREE DOLLARS WE TRY TO
KEEP IT LOW AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE SUCCESSES OF
THE PROGRAM TO BE QUITE HONEST
WITH YOU OUR FEES ARE LOW. WE
GET THE JOB DONE VERY QUICKLY AS
FAR AS THE REGISTRATION AND
IMMEDIATELY PEOPLE CAN PROCESS.
STIR PREPARING OUR RETURNS SO I
I THINK SOME OF THOSE WOULD PUT
SUCH A BURDEN ON C. TECH THAT IT
WOULD BE IT WOULD BE DIFFICULT
FOR PEOPLE.
SOME OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TALKS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY YOU
THINK TRANSPARENCY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S.
THE THE THE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL BE BURDENSOME.
NO I AS FAR AS THAT I WAS
TALKING MORE ABOUT THE THE.
YOU KNOW THE INVESTIGATIVE
PORTION OF IT I THINK AS HE TOOK
ALREADY IS EXTREMELY TRANSPARENT
ALL OF OUR YOU KNOW OUR MEETINGS
THAT WE HAVE ARE VERY OPEN.
WE HAVE A NOTICE PUBLISHED
SEVEN SEVEN TWO HOURS IN
ADVANCE.
ARE YOU SUBJECT TO THE.
THE BROWN ACT BUT BACK LOOKING
AT.
WE TRY TO FOLLOW THE BAGLEY
KEENE IS NOT REQUIRED BUT NOT
REQUIRED ALLISON HAS POINTED OUT
WE DO SEND.
WE DO.
TEN DAYS BEFORE ALREADY OUR
MEETINGS FOR THIS YEAR ARE
POSTED AT THE BEGINNING ACTUALLY
AFTER THE NOVEMBER MEETING WE
POST.
OUR MEETINGS FOR THE FOLLOWING
YEAR.
WE. GET WE HAVE MINUTES THAT
ARE ONLINE PEOPLE COULD GO AND
REVIEW OUR WEBSITE IS VERY OPEN
I MEAN AND WE ALWAYS TELL PEOPLE
THAT CALL IN ON. THAT THEY COULD
CERTAINLY LOOK AT OUR WEBSITE
FOR ANY INFORMATION WE HAVE MANY
OF OUR POLICIES ONLINE. WOULD
PUT OUT NEWSLETTERS ARE TO OUR
PREPARERS WHICH THEN THEY PASS
ON. TO THEIR OF THE PEOPLE THE
TAX PAYERS SO I I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE VERY TRANSPARENT. OKAY THE
MASS QUESTIONS I'M NOT FAMILIAR
WITH THE STRUCTURE OF YOUR
BOARD.
IS THERE A TIME THAT YOUR BOARD
VOTES.
ON ITEMS YES WE MEET TWICE A
YEAR. YOUR BOARD VOTES YES.
SO WHAT IS THE TAKING ORDER
MICHAEL HORAN.
USUALLY WE HAVE ALL BOARD
MEMBERS HAVE. HAD OUR MEETING
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A TIME WHERE
BOARD WAS YOUR BOARD MEETINGS
LACKED THE CORNER TO GET
STARTED.
EVER IN TWENTY YEARS NEVER. AND
HOW MANY BOARD MEMBERS ARE THERE
CURRENTLY HAVE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN
MEMBERS.
OKAY.
BECAUSE THE OTHER BOARDS COURSE
FOLLOWED THE BACK AND CLICK THE
BACK A CLEAN KING ACT AS WELL AS
THE BROWN ACT. AND EVEN WE'RE
FOURTEEN MEMBERS.
CERTAINLY THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO YOU KNOW TALK
ABOUT HOW EACH OTHER VOTE AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY WE
HAVE. BAGGY KING AS WELL AS THE
BROWN ACT. AND SO YOU DO TAKE A
PUBLIC VOTE ON ISSUES THAT COME
BEFORE YOUR BOARD SO WE TALK
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND SO. ON
THIS ISSUERS CALIFORNIANS THAT
THERE IN FACT IS IN FACT
TRANSPARENCY.
AND I'M JUST CONCERNED THAT
YOUR BOARD DOESN'T FOLLOW. WHAT
WE REQUIRE FOR?
MOST BOARDS EVEN INCLUDING.
CITY COUNCILS AND BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO THAT'S ALL THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A SUMMER
GETS ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMES.
JUST A COMMENT.
SIMPLY NEVER RIGHT.
I MEAN IT IS A IT IS AMAZING
THAT.
YOU GET THE WORK DONE THAT YOU
HAVE AND IT IT'S KIND OF.
WE'RE SITTING HERE IN MANY
RESPECTS WHAT I'M HEARING IS ALL
THE GOOD THINGS HERE BUT YOU'RE
DOING.
AND HERE'S SOMEBODY WHO DOESN'T
HAVE TO.
RESPOND.
YOU KNOW TO THOSE BETTER JUST
DOING IT ANYWAY I THINK IT
SOUNDS TO ME LIKE YOU'RE BEING
TRANSPARENT. IN IN YOUR
PROCESSES BUT IT'S JUST.
.
I DON'T KNOW.
I'VE ALWAYS THE I'VE CERTAINLY
ALWAYS BEEN FOR.
YOUR TRANSPARENCY IN THE IN IN
THE RULES BEHIND IT BUT IT'S
ALWAYS NICE TO SEE. AN
ORGANIZATION IS A REQUIRED TO DO
IT BUT DOES.
MOST OF THAT ANYWAY AND FROM
WHAT I'VE HEARD. FROM THE THE
THE SENATE CHAIRMAN IN HIS
COMMENTS SEEMS LIKE YOU GUYS ARE
DOING A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE MENTION
THAT I DID. HAVE A CHANCE TO. GO
ONLINE TO YOUR WEBSITE FOR
EXAMPLE WITH RESPECT TO
TRANSPARENCY AND APPRECIATE THE
COMES THAT BEEN MADE AS WELL
THOSE LOOKING TO SEE. AND
ADDRESSING UPDATE IN MINUTES OF
OF THE AGENDAS AND SAW THAT THE
LAST MINUTES PERHAPS WAS. AS OF
MAY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
AND SO MY DEBATE OPPORTUNITY TO
IS TO ADDRESS. ONE MORE UPDATED
APPROACH TO.
THE ACTIVITIES THAT IS OCCURRED.
YES THE NOVEMBER ON ME MINUTES
WILL BE ONLINE WE USUALLY. HAVE
SOME WE PREPARE THE MINUTES SAID
ABOUT TO THE CHAIRS AND TO THE
COMMITTEES AND THEN THEY SENT IT
BACK TO US SO IT USUALLY TAKES A
COUPLE OF MONTHS FOR US TO GET
THOSE ONLINE. BUT THEY WILL BE
OKAY WONDERFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AT THIS TIME. SCENE THEN
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK.
AND SHARES SOME INSIGHTS ON THIS
AS WELL.
MANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OKAY
CNN.
YEAH IT'S IT WAS THERE WAS A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IT IS. YES.
IF YOU COULD KINDLY
EXPEDITIOUSLY MAKE YOUR WAY UP
TO THE MICROPHONE AT THERE AT
THE CORNER THERE. AND YOU'LL
HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES AND
PLEASE YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
THERE.
WHAT IS? THE.
YES.
MY NAME IS READY MISTER RICH.
AND FOR THE PAST THIRTEEN YEARS.
I'VE BEEN EMPLOYED BY HR BLOCK.
I WORK WITH FIELD TRAINING AND
TRAINING DEVELOPMENT. I'M KIND
OF THE LIES AND BETWEEN MY
COMPANY IN THE. CALIFORNIA TAX
EDUCATION COUNCIL.
IT MATTERS OF TRAINING IN THE
REGISTRATION.
VERTEX FOR FIRST.
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS MEETINGS
HAVE BEEN ADVERTISED.
TO BE OPEN TO THE PUBLIC AND
ALLOWED ME TO ATTEND ALMOST ALL
OF THEM IN THE PAST THIRTEEN
YEARS.
ALONG WITH COVER WITH OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES.
DETECTIVE LED THE WAY FOR THE
CREATION OF SORT OF CURRICULUM
STANDARDS THAT PROMOTES A SOLID
BASIC KNOWLEDGE. TO BUILD
CONFIDENCE NEW PREPARES FOR NOW.
IT FOR THE FUTURE. ALONG WITH
CONTINUED EDUCATION WITH GROWTH
AND ABILITY TO KEEP PACE. WITH
THE FAST CHANGING WORLD TAX FOR.
PROBABLY MANY HIGH LEVEL OF
RESPONSIBILITY FROM EACH.
APPROVED PROVIDER TO PRODUCE
HIGH QUALITY COURSES THROUGH THE
COURSE REVIEW PROCESSES THAT ARE
IN FORCE.
WE HAVE ABOUT NINE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BETWEEN CORPORATE AND
FRANCHISED AND PROBABLY
THOUSANDS MORE. I DON'T EVEN
KNOW HOW MANY THERE ARE IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
MUCH OF THE EDUCATION CONTENT
STANDARDS THAT WE HAVE TO.
ADHERE TO FOR CALIFORNIA ARE
ALSO FELL FOR GUIDANCE IN THE
COURSE PRODUCTION OF MANY OF THE
OTHER STATES.
LASTLY I FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THE FACT THAT ALL OF OUR
DIRECTORS. FOR ALMOST ALL OF THE
MANY WAYS SITTING ON THE BOARD.
ARE ALL BEING INVOLVED PRESENTLY
OR OR PREVIOUSLY AND PREPARING
TAX RETURNS.
THEY. ARE IN THERE IS EXHIBITING
EXPERIENCE AND ROLLED AGENTS
CPA'S. SECURITY PLEASE OR OTHER
HIGH LEVEL MANAGEMENT POSITIONS
IN THE COMPANIES THAT PRODUCE
THE TAX RETURNS.
WHEN YOU SIT ACROSS FROM CLIENT
THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD BEEN
PREPARED A BAD EXPERIENCE IS HE
IS HE WAS NEEDED.
THAT'S THE CALIFORNIA TAX
EDUCATION COUNCIL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS DEBORAH BUT DAMN I
REPRESENT JACKSON HEWITT.
I'M.
I AM BEN ACEITAR COLDER FOR THE
LAST EIGHT YEARS.
PERSONALLY I STARTED FROM. BEING
A TAX PREPARER.
GOING TO AN INSTRUCTOR GOING TO.
MANAGEMENT AMBIEN AND TERM DAMN.
WHICH MEANS DISTRICT MANAGER.
I SEE IT FROM ALL SIDES.
AND I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT THAT PROGRAM FOR SEA TAC
FULLY BENEFITS.
THE CONSUMER. BECAUSE I HAVE
SEEN PEOPLE THAT HAVE. NOT
CONCEIVED TACT AND IT'S.
I WOULDN'T WANT MY TAXES DONE
FROM THEM.
BY A SIMPLE SO I FULLY SUPPORT
C. TAPPAN SEA TAC IN ITS CURRENT
FORM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
WANTED TO THANK YOU MISTER
CRAWFORD FOR THE SAKE OF BUT
YOU'VE BEEN SERVING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. THAT RIGHT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
PUBLIC SERVICE. THIS NOW
CONCLUDES THE REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX EDUCATION COUNCIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR NOW THEN
TRANSITION TO THE REVIEW. OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR FOR CAN KINDLY ASK THE
WITNESSES TO PLEASE COME UP TO
THE DICE IS A PREPARE AND THE
NEED TO REPRESENT IS THAT WE
HAVE AT THE BUREAU CHIEF.
PATRICK DOOR RATE AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR DEAN FOR FEEL.
AND CAN REPRESENT AS WILL COME
UP AND GIVE A BRIEF INTRODUCTION
REMARKS AND ALLOW QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE OPENING UP TO. MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC.
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
.
IF YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PATRICK
TERRAIN I AM THE CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR I'M
PLEASED TO HAVE THE DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS DEAN TO PHILLY.
DANGERFIELD JOINING ME THIS
MORNING. WRITING.
MR.
I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK GOD
CHEERS HILL AND LOW AND THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO REPRESENT THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR AND
THE SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS TODAY.
HOW FUNNY HAS THE DISTINCTION OF
BEING THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO IMPLEMENT A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM FOR THE
REGULATION OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR INDUSTRY?
OF AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR WAS
ESTABLISHED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO WITH AN
ACCIDENT OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR ACT. IN FOR CLOSE TO
FIFTY YEARS HAS BEEN COMMITTED
TO SERVING AND PROTECTING
CONSUMERS. IN THIS STATE.
WHILE SUPPORTING THE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR INDUSTRY TO CREATE A FAIR
AND COMPETITIVE MARKETPLACE. AT
ITS CORE THE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
ACT ESTABLISHES DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS TO BETTER INFORM
AND PROTECT CONSUMERS. IN THEIR
TRANSACTIONS WITH AUTUMN WITH
REGISTERED AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR
DEALER'S.
THE BUREAU MEDIATES CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS.
INVESTIGATES POSSIBLE POSSIBLE
VIOLATIONS OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR ACT AND ITS REGULATIONS
AND TAKES DISCIPLINARY ACTION TO
ENFORCE VIOLATIONS OF THESE
LAWS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR. THE
SMOG CHECK PROGRAM WAS ADDED TO
THE PAYROLLS RESPONSIBILITIES
WITH THE GOAL OF REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION CAUSED BY MOTOR
VEHICLES.
IN ADDITION TO LICENSING SMOG
CHECK STATIONS INSPECTORS AND
REPAIR TECHNICIANS THE BUREAU
CERTIFIES INSPECTION EQUIPMENT.
AND THE SCHOOLS AND INSTRUCTORS
PROVIDING THE TRAINING FOR
LICENSURE.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUREAU
ADMINISTERS. A CONSUMER
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
WHICH PROVIDES REPAIR ASSISTANCE
IN VEHICLE RETIREMENT OPTIONS TO
CONSUMERS WHOSE VEHICLES CANNOT
PASS THEIR SMOG CHECK.
WOULD BE A SURPRISE.
TO EMPOWER CONSUMERS THROUGH
EDUCATION AND AWARENESS OF OUR
PROGRAMS.
WE ALSO WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR AND SMOG CHECK
INDUSTRY TO IMPLEMENT CHANGES
AND UPDATES TO OUR PROGRAMS. AND
TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR ACT.
WE FACILITATE AN ADVISORY GROUP
THAT MEETS QUARTERLY.
WE ALSO HAVE AN AN EDUCATIONAL
ADVISORY GROUP COMPRISED OF
EDUCATORS SHOP OWNERS AND
TECHNICIANS TO IDENTIFY AND
RESPOND TO TRAINING ISSUES. THAT
AFFECT OUR LICENSEES.
THE BILL IS HEADQUARTERED IN
RANCHO CORDOVA.
WE HAVE TWELVE FIELD OFFICES AND
SIX FORENSIC DOCUMENTATION
LABORATORIES LOCATED THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
OUR LICENSE BASE INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY SIX
THOUSAND REGISTERED AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALER'S.
TWO THOUSAND LICENSE BREAKING
LAMPS STATIONS.
THREE THOUSAND LICENSE BREAK AND
LAMP ADJUSTERS THOSE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS PERFORMING THE AND
MAP AND BRAKE INSPECTIONS AND
CERTIFYING THE VEHICLES ARE
COMPLIANT WITH.
RELEVANT LAWS. SEVEN THOUSAND
SMALL CHECK STATIONS ARE ALSO
LICENSED BY THE BUREAU. AND
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND SMOG CHECK
INSPECTORS AND REPAIR
TECHNICIANS.
WE ALSO CURRENTLY CERTIFIED
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
STAR STATIONS. MEETING SPECIFIED
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS TO PERFORM
SMOG CHECKS ON THE STATE'S
HIGHEST POLLUTING VEHICLES.
THOSE OPERATIONS ARE PRIMARILY
FUNDED BY A SMOG CERTIFICATE FEE
CURRENTLY SET AT EIGHT DOLLARS
AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS. AS WELL
AS REGISTRATION AND LICENSING
FEES
AN ANNUAL SMOG ABATEMENT FEE.
WE HAVE HAD MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
SINCE THE LAST SUNSET REVIEW.
CONDUCTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN.
INCLUDING SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE SMOG CHECK
PROGRAM THAT WERE MADE POSSIBLE
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE ON
BOARD DIAGNOSTIC INSPECTION
SYSTEM OR O. S.. HAS STREAMLINED
THE INSPECTION PROCESS FOR NEWER
MODEL YEAR VEHICLES AND IS
IMPROVED. THE ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY THOSE VEHICLES NEEDING
REPAIRS.
THE BUREAU ALSO HAS IMPLEMENTED
REAL TIME BLOCKING OF A SMALL
CHICKS SMOG CHECK CERTIFICATE.
WHEN FRAUDULENT INSPECTION
ACTIVITY IS RECOGNIZED BY THE ON
BOARD DIAGNOSTIC INSPECTION
INSPECTION SYSTEM.
IN CONCERT WITH THIS EFFORT. WE
HAVE ALSO ESTABLISHED A
SPECIALIZED ENFORCEMENT TEAM. TO
PURSUE ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION
AGAINST DEFENDING STATIONS AND
LICENSEES. ENGAGED IN FRAUDULENT
SMOG CHECK INSPECTION ACTIVITY.
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A MOMENT THIS
TIME TO RECOGNIZE THE WORK OF
PARTNER AGENCIES AT THE LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVELS IN
PARTICULAR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND THE
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES.
WHO ASSIST US IN OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS? I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THESE ENTITIES AS
WE EXPLORE WAYS TO ENHANCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
ONE IDEA WE HAVE INFORMALLY
DISCUSS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
MOTOR VEHICLES IS A CHANGE TO
THE VEHICLE CODE THAT WOULD
ENHANCE THE BEARERS ENFORCEMENT
OF THE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR ACT.
I APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE. THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND OUR
STAKEHOLDERS TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR PROGRAMS.
AND THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES WE
PROVIDE.
I WOULD NOW LIKE TO RESPOND TO.
SEVERAL ISSUES IDENTIFIED BY THE
COMMITTEE'S.
THE FIRST ISSUE I WILL ADDRESS.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE. IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER SUBMITTED.
MIGHT COMMITTEES IS REGARDING
THE ENFORCEMENT WORKLOAD OF THE
BUREAU.
THE BILL HAS NO NEW PROGRAMS OR
PROGRAM CHANGES PLANNED THAT
WOULD INCREASE ENFORCEMENT CASE
WORKLOAD.
AS HAS BEEN THE CASE THE LAST
FEW YEARS FOLLOWING
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BAR ON OBD
INSPECTION SYSTEM TESTING THAT
BEGAN IN. TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN.
HOWEVER AS VEHICLES CONTINUED TO
ADVANCE TECHNOLOGICALLY. AND IF
THE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR INDUSTRY
IS UNABLE TO KEEP UP WITH THESE
ADVANCEMENTS.
ADVANCEMENTS AN ADDITIONAL
UNEXPECTED WORKLOAD COULD BE
GENERATED.
THE BEER REMAINS PREPARED TO
SHIFT RESOURCES AS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS CHANGES IN THIS
WORKLOAD.
IN ADDITION THE BUREAU WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TO
MANAGE AND EXPEDITE THE
RESOLUTION. OF ITS CASES.
SECONDLY I WILL DISCUSS ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE RELATED TO
ADVERTISING.
SPECIFICALLY WITH RESPECT TO OUR
RECENTLY ADOPTED REGULATIONS
THAT REQUIRE MOBILE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALERS TO INCLUDE THEIR
LICENSE NUMBERS OR THEIR
REGISTRATION NUMBERS IN THEIR
ADVERTISEMENTS.
THE COMMITTEE ASKED WHETHER IT
WOULD BE NECESSARY TO APPLY THAT
STANDARD TO ALL REGISTRANTS.
AS A NEW REGULATIONS WERE
ADOPTED. ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
NOVEMBER SIXTEENTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SUFFICIENT DATA IS
STILL NOT AVAILABLE TO DETERMINE
THEIR IMPACT ON THE UNLICENSED.
MOBILE AUTO REPAIRS.
HOWEVER THE BUREAU CONTINUES TO
EDUCATE REGISTERED AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALERS AS WELL AS
CONSUMERS ON THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS.
BUT ALSO HAVE BEEN EDUCATING TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITIES ON
REGISTERED.
YEAH ENTITIES OUT THERE.
THROUGH VARIOUS.
AT.
YEAH. VENUES WE ALSO WILL
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS TO INFORM
PERSONS OR ENTITIES PERFORMING
THESE. AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR IS
ABOUT THE NEED FOR REGISTRATION
AS WELL AS THE NEW ADVERTISING
REQUIREMENTS.
PART OF THE IMPLEMENTATION.
ALREADY IS REVIEWING ONLINE
ADVERTISING. AND MONITORING
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS.
TOOK TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE
WITH THESE REGULATIONS.
BRICK AND MORTAR REPAIR
FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO POST
THEIR AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR DEALER
REGISTRATIONS ALREADY IN THEIR
SHOP.
pEQUIVALENT TO A MOBILE A OR D.
HOSTING OF THE REGISTRATION. ON
THEIR VEHICLE.
WHICH IS ALSO REQUIRED BY THESE
REGULATIONS THE ONLINE
ADVERTISING IS TYPICALLY THE
VENUE BY WHICH MOBILE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR DEALERS ADVERTISE THEIR
SERVICES. WHICH IS WHY IT WAS
THE FOCAL POINT OF THE NEW
REGULATIONS.
AS WE COLLECT DATA ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE ADVERTISING
REGULATION. THE BUREAU WILL
DETERMINE IF FURTHER REGULATION
CHANGES ARE NECESSARY.
LASTLY WITH REGARD TO ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHT THE COMMITTEE HAS
REQUESTED AN UPDATE REGARDING
THE MINOR SERVICE REGULATION. IS
BEING PURSE SUED AND DEVELOPED
BY THE BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR.
HAS THE COMMITTEE REPORT NOTES.
THE BUREAU HELD A PUBLIC
WORKSHOP ON JULY TWENTIETH OF
LAST YEAR TO DISCUSS REGULATORY
PROPOSAL THAT WOULD HAVE
EXPANDED THE EXEMPTION LISTED
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN STATUTE TO
INCLUDE OTHER SERVICES.
DUE TO A LACK OF INDUSTRY
CONSENSUS AT THIS WORKSHOP.
SCALE BACK THE EXEMPTED SERVICES
PORTION OF THE REGULATORY
PROPOSAL. HELD ANOTHER PUBLIC
WORKSHOP. JUST LAST MONTH ON
FEBRUARY TWELFTH.
THE BILL IS CURRENTLY IN THE
PROCESS OF REVIEWING COMMENTS
THAT WERE RECEIVED AT THE SECOND
WORKSHOP.
THIS TIME IT'S I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
BUREAU DOES NOT HAVE AUTHORITY
TO REMOVE. OR MODIFY THE CURRENT
STATUTORY LIST OF EXEMPTED
SERVICES.
COULD BECOME NECESSARY HOWEVER
TO PROTECT CONSUMERS WERE MORE
EXPERTISE MAY BE REQUIRED TO
WORK ON THE VEHICLE.
DO YOU DO ADVANCES IN AUTOMOTIVE
TECHNOLOGY.
MAKING A ONE SIMPLE PROCEDURE.
MORE COMPLEX ESPECIALLY FOR
CERTAIN MAKES AND MODELS OF
VEHICLES.
THE BUREAU ONLY HAS A STORY TO
EXPAND.
OR ADD TO THE STATUTORY LIST OF
EXTENDED SERVICES AND
REGULATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. AM AVAILABLE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AT THIS AT
THIS TIME SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM ANY COMPANY
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR.
MISSIONARY THANK YOU FOR THE.
THE. THE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS ONE OF THE CONCERNS
IS.
COULD EVER RISEN IN MY DISTRICT
IN SOME CONCERN FROM
CONSTITUENTS IS THE CLASSIC CAR.
PROCESS FOR SMOG CHECK IN HOW
THAT PROCESS IS COULD YOU
BRIEFLY JUST OUTLINED HOW THAT
WORKS TODAY.
YEAH AS PROVIDED BY STATUTE.
AN EXEMPTION OR I SHOULDN'T SAY
AN EXEMPTION.
MODIFICATION TO THE SMOG CHECK
REQUIREMENTS FOR THOSE
QUALIFYING IS COLLECTOR CARS I
THINK IS THE TERMINOLOGY IN
STATUTE. IS AVAILABLE.
I BELIEVE THE VEHICLE HAS TO BE
INSURED AS A COLLECTOR CAR.
REQUIRES THAT THE VEHICLE BE
THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
MULDER OLDER.
AND.
IT REQUIRES OR ALLOWS FOR A
MODIFIED INSPECTION.
TO A ELIMINATE SOME OF THE.
PORTIONS OF THE SMOG CHECK
REQUIREMENTS.
THE ONLY THING THAT THE VEHICLE
IS REQUIRED TO PASS ISM A
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS INSPECTION.
THAT INSPECTION IS PERFORMED AT
ONE OF THE STATE'S CONTRACTED
REFEREE ENTITIES.
THOSE ARE. FACILITIES.
.
ROUGHLY HALF A LITTLE OVER
THIRTY THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT
ARE. SET UP TO PROVIDE
SPECIALIZED INSPECTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE.
WHERE A VEHICLE MIGHT NOT BE
ABLE TO GET A NORMAL INSPECTION
AT A?
AT A REGULAR SIMPSON LICENSE
SMOG CHECK INTO THOSE CARDS TO
THIS CLASSIC CARS HAVE TO BE ARE
THEY REQUIRED TO MEET THE
STANDARDS NOT OF TODAY BUT OF
THE DAY THAT THE CAR THE THE
VEHICLE WAS. WAS MANUFACTURED
RIGHT OUT OF THE STANDARDS WERE
AT THAT TIME THAT THOSE ARE THE
STANDARDS AT THE END OF TIME THE
TIME OF THEIR REGULAR SMOG CHECK
STATION WOULD NOT BE EQUIPPED TO
DO THAT ARE REQUIRED TO DO IT.
IN. YES AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
SOFTWARE IT'S BUILT INTO THE
SMOG CHECK MACHINES.
ALLOWS FOR MODIFICATION OF
THOSE TESTS AT THE REFEREES. IN
AND THE OTHER PART IS. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A
LIMITATION OF THE NUMBER OF
MILES THAT VEHICLE CAN BE DRIVEN
A YEAR.
NOT IN STATUTE. IT MIGHT BE A
REQUIREMENT OF THE INSURER TO.
ALLOW THAT VEHICLE TO BE INSURED
AS A COLLECTOR CAR ISIS SAID
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT IN
STATUTE FROM OUT NOT TO MY
KNOWLEDGE. IF. GOOD.
.
ALL OF THIS QUESTION WHICH.
I'M JUST INTERESTED IN KNOWING
IF YOU'VE GOT A CLASSIC CAR OR
DO YOU COLLECT CARS ODD I KNOW
THERE'S A A LOT OF NONPROFITS
THAT HAVE THESE YOU KNOW.
A. BIG CAR COLLECTIONS THAT.
.
YEAH RAISE MONEY FOR THE
COMMUNITIES IF THEY'RE NOT
DRIVEN AT ALL THERE STILL
REQUIRED TO GET SMALLER JACK'S.
THIS SECTION TO SET UP THAT
REQUIRES A SMOG CHECK TO PROVE
THEIR ABILITY TO PASS THE
INSPECTION FOR THE VEHICLE
RIGHT.
THAT'S THE WAY YEAH THAT'S THE
WAY IT'S SET UP CURRENTLY IN
LAW.
THEY BEAT BILL IDEAS ON TIME.
WE STILL HAVE TIME. MAYBE.
NO CAPACITY ONE MORE COOL.
FATAL ONE MORE QUICK QUESTION
OF.
THE ISSUE THE REFEREES PROGRAM
AND THE REFEREE STATIONS THAT
YOU HAVE YOUR THIRTY AROUND THE
STATE IS THAT CONVENIENT IF YOU
FOUND THAT TO BE.
A PROBLEM FOR SOME I KNOW THE
CONSTITUENT THAT RAISE THE ISSUE
WITH ME TODAY TO DRIVE THIRTY
MILES TO FIND TO GO TO A REFEREE
STATION WITH THIS CLASSIC CAR.
THAT WAS THIRTY MILES THERE
THREE MILES BACK AT SIXTY MILES
HE WAS ONLY A LOT I GUESS BUYS
INSURANCE COMPANIES SHOULD
MENTION. OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILES PER YEAR. SO THAT PUT A
LIMITATION ANY USED HALF OF IT
TO TO GET TO A SMOG. CHECK
STATION HAVE YOU HAD ANY
COMPLAINTS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
ACCESS OR ANY CONDITIONS. IN NO
WE HAVE NOT HAD ANY COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THE ACCESS TO THE.
THE FACILITIES THEY ARE SET UP
THAT THEY'RE PRETTY EASY TO FIND
THEIR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. THROUGHOUT THE STATE
IT IS A CONTRACT WE HAVE WITH
THE FOUNDATION FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THERE'S A
NATURAL TIE INTO THE. THE
TRAINING.
OF.
FUTURE TECHNICIANS AND
INSPECTORS FOR THE INDUSTRY SO
IT'S REALLY A NICE A.
PATHWAY FOR PEOPLE IN THE. CITY
SCHOOLS TO GET INTO BUT AS FAR
AS.
.
COMMENTS OR COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ACCESS TO THE FACILITIES WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY BUT.
BE CERTAINLY OPEN TO LOOKING AT
OPTIONS CERTAINLY IN THE CASE OF
SOMEONE WHO HAS LIMITATIONS. ON
THAT IS BEING PLACED ON THEM
FOR.
MILEAGE. TO REGISTER THE VEHICLE
AS A COLLECTOR CAR THAT LOOKING
AT MAYBE WE CAN.
.
I HAVE SOME IDEA IT WAYS TO GET
OUT TO THE CONSUMER SUPPOSED TO
THE CONSUMER COMING TO THE
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AT THIS TIME FOR MANY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE WILL NOW OPEN UP THE
PORTION OF THIS MEETING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK. DURING THIS PORTION
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
AND YOU'LL HAVE UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION FOR THE
RECORD IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
PLEASE.
YES SIR I'M.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MY NAME ARE
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CHARLIE
PETERS.
CCLEANER PERFORMANCE
PROFESSIONALS.
WE REPRESENT PEOPLE WHO DRIVE
CARS.
AND THE THE LAST COMMENT
PROVIDED I FOUND QUITE
INTERESTING AND FAT.
.
WHAT DO WE HAVE A ANY KIND OF
DATA AS TO WHETHER ANY OF THESE
CARS WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THESE
CARS FAIL THE TASK?
AND.
WHAT KINDS OF REPAIRS ARE
NECESSARY AND WHO'S DOING THAT
AND WHAT KIND OF SUCCESS THAT
HAVE WITH REPAIRS?
IF ANY.
IF WE DON'T FAIL ANY CARS AND
IT'S KIND OF SILLY THAT.
.
WE HAVE THIS DISCUSSION AS TO
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE MAYBE THIS
NEEDS TO BE ELIMINATED.
SOMEBODY'S COLLECTING A LOT OF
MONEY AND GOING TO A LOT OF
EXERCISE IF WE DON'T FEEL ANY
CARS AND WE PROVIDE NO BENEFITS.
WHAT WE'RE DOING AND WHY A
SECOND PART OF THAT QUESTION
MIGHT BE?
IT'S BEEN AN INDICATION OVER
TIME THAT.
.
REMOTE SENSING AS ANOTHER MEANS
OF TESTING THESE VEHICLES AS
THEY TRAVEL ON THE ROAD. AND
THAT THESE CARS ARE NOT.
EXEMPT FROM REMOTE SENSING.
THE LEDGE COUNCIL PROVIDED THE
INFORMATION TO THE ORIGINAL SMOG
CHECK REVIEW COMMITTEE. THAT
THESE CARS ARE SUBJECT TO THAT.
I HAVE PROVIDED TO YOU A.
pTHIS COMMITTEE OF THE SUNSET
REVIEW COMMITTEE.
THE LAST TIME IT WAS CONSIDERED.
AND GAVE SOME SPECIFIC KINDS OF
PERFORMANCE RESULTS THAT TOOK
PLACE.
THAT WE SEE NO PROGRESS ON THAT
WHATSOEVER. ON THOSE SUGGESTIONS
SO WE HAVE PROVIDED TO YOU
TODAY.
A SUGGESTION THAT WE IMMEDIATELY
CEASE AND DESIST COLLECTION OF
FINES. FOR THE SPOT CHECK
PROGRAM. AND STOP THIS PROCESS.
DOES NOT SEEM TO PROVIDE ANY
BENEFITS WHATSOEVER. AND SO WE
THINK THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA DESERVE MORE
CONSIDERATION THAT THEY'RE
GETTING AT THIS POINT. I WILL
POINT OUT THAT THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS I REQUESTED. TO HIM IN
PERSON AND REMOTELY REQUESTING
TO MEET WITH THEM HE OBVIOUSLY
IS NOT HAS DOES NOT SEEM TO HAVE
ANY INTEREST WHATSOEVER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CONSUMER ISSUES
THANK THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT BECAUSE PLEASE.
MORNING GERMAN HELEN GERMAN LOW
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS PETER PARALIA CINEMA
EMPLOYEE WITH OIL STOP DRIVE
THRU OIL CHANGE.
AND OUR FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT
WORRIED ALL APOLOGIZES HE WOULD
HAVE LOVED TO BEEN HERE PERSONAL
HIMSELF. HE'S RECOVERING FROM
SURGERY.
THIS YEAR WE ARE CELEBRATING
THIRTY YEARS OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE. TWENTY FOUR
LOCATIONS COVERING CALIFORNIA
ARIZONA NEW MEXICO AND OREGON.
AND WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
EMPLOYEES.
AND SERVICE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
VEHICLES LESTER.
OUR COMPANY CULTURES ARE UNIQUE.
SERVICE PROCESS MINDED WE
OPERATE UNDER THE MISSION
STATEMENT.
WE WILL SERVE PEOPLE WITH
EXCELLENCE. HOW BILLY WITH A
SERVANT'S HEART?
WE ARE AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT A
STATUTORY EXAM FACTIONAL.
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE
PROVIDER LOOKS LIKE.
WE FULFILL THE CALIFORNIA
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR ACTS. ORIGINAL
DESIGN TO PROMOTE CONSUMER
ACCESS. TO THE COST EFFECTIVE
AND CONVENIENT PREVENTATIVE
MAINTENANCE SERVICES THEY NEED
MOST.
ARE SIMPLE STREAMLINED BUSINESS
MODEL. IS WHAT MAKES IT POSSIBLE
FOR THESE CRUCIAL SERVICES. TO
REMAIN COST EFFECTIVE.
WE DO NOT DIAGNOSE MALFUNCTIONS.
WE MAKE NO REPAIRS. ARE SERVICE
MODEL WOULD BREAK IF REQUIRED TO
USE A TIME CONSUMING PAPERWORK
OF A REPAIR DEALER.
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR
CUSTOMERS LIKE US THE WAY WE
ARE.
WE'RE SUBMITTING TO THE
COMMITTEE. FOR YOUR REVIEW. TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
FOUR CUSTOMER PETITIONS IN FAVOR
OF OUR EXAM BUSINESS MODEL.
WE ASK FOR CUSTOMERS FEEDBACK IN
RESPONSE TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN LEGISLATION.
AND CERTAIN BAR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS THAT PUT AT RISK THE
FUTURE VIABILITY OF OUR
BUSINESS.
BY WAY OF ELIMINATING THE
STATUTORY EXEMPTION FOR
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE.
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
WE URGE YOU TO PRESERVE.
THE EXEMPTION THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PICK A PLACE.
GOOD MORNING GERMAN LOW GERMAN
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID WERE
ALONG WITH THE AUTOMOTIVE WORLD
TRADE ASSOCIATION. WHERE THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING THE FAST INDUSTRY?
CA REPRESENTS STATUTORILY EXEMPT
PROFESSIONAL PREVENTIVE
MAINTENANCE ONLY OPERATORS AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO HAVE ADDED
REPAIRS WE BELIEVE THAT BOTH
SERVICE
MODELS PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS. THE MONITORING PUBLIC
IN OUR MOCK MEMBERS ARE
CUSTOMERS AGREE. WE ARE
SUBMITTING FOR YOUR REVIEW TODAY
OVER THIRTY THOUSAND CUSTOMER
PETITIONS. IN FAVOR PRESERVING
THE STATUTORILY EXEMPT
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE
BUSINESS SMALL. IT IS ONE THAT
DEPENDS ON SPEED AND VOLUME TO
PROVIDE COST EFFECTIVE TOP
SERVICE. AND HIGH QUALITY
PRODUCTS REQUIRED BY CUSTOMERS
AUTOMOBILE WARRANTIES. IF YOU
REMOVE THE SPEED WITH REPAIR
ESTIMATE PROCEDURES. VOLUME DROP
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE COST TO
CUSTOMERS WOULD GO UP POSSIBLY
EVEN DOUBLE.
WE'RE ALSO SUBMITTING FOR YOUR
REVIEW A DETAILED ANALYSIS OF
THE BUSINESS MODEL THE EXAM
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE
SERVICES. DEVELOPED AROUND. THAT
SHOULD BE NOTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN MCA MEMBERS THAT ARE
STATUTORILY EXEMPT PRIMITIVE
AUTOMOTIVE MAINTENANCE PROVIDERS
ARE A MPS ARE ANTS. ACTUALLY
OFFERED TO BE REGULATED
REGULATED BY BAR WITH THE ONLY
STIPULATION BEING THAT THEY NOT
BE FORCED INTO REPAIR ESTIMATE
PROCEDURES THAT DESTROY THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL.
THE RESULT WAS SB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT WHICH IS REFERRED TO IN
THE BACKGROUND REPORT WE WILL
ALSO BE SUBMITTING. IT WAS NEVER
ABOUT ABSOLUTE VERSUS BAR. IT'S
ABOUT CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
HAVING ACCESS TO COST EFFECTIVE
PREVENTATIVE MAINTENANCE VERSES
DEFERRING UNNECESSARY
MAINTENANCE AND ADDING UP WITH
EXPENSIVE REPAIRS.
AS IT STANDS TODAY THE AGING OF
THE AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR ACTS
STATUTORY EXEMPTION. PERMITTED A
MAINTENANCE CONTINUES TO
ACCOMPLISH EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS
INTENDED TO DO. AND MAKES
NECESSARY SERVICES READILY
AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS FOR A
PRICE THEY CAN AFFORD.
AND THE PROFESSIONAL OPERATORS
AT REFINE THEIR DELIVERY INTO A
SUCCESSFUL STREAMLINE BUSINESS
MODEL EMPLOY THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD PAYING JOBS PEOPLE WHO LOVE
OF. THANK YOU YOU EXPECTED
PLEASE.
AM I GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BUT
RICE I AM PRESIDENT OF CALLIE BC
I'M ALSO ON THE BAR EDUCATIONAL
COMMITTEE. AND I DID WANT TO SAY
THAT THE BAR ADVISORY GROUP IS
CRITICAL TO OUR BAR OPERATES
WITH WITH INDUSTRY.
I WANTED TO SAY THAT BAR WE WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT IT TOO MUCH
BUT WHAT THE THE ROLE THAT THEY
PLAY IS IN BETWEEN CONSUMERS AND
SHOPS. AND AND IN MANY CASES THE
SHOPS ARE TRYING TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY DO GOOD WORK SOMETIMES
WE. SOMETIMES WE DON'T. OF MANY
TIMES CUSTOMERS ARE WRONG AND
THE BAR HELPS KIND OF FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S WHAT NEAR ME AND IT HELPS
TO GET IT DONE SO I'M I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY DO.
I WANTED TO JUMP ON THIS MINOR
REPAIRS THING I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE LEGISLATOR GIVE THE BAR THE
CAPABILITY OF FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO DO MODIFICATIONS OR
CHANGES IN STATUTE. SO RIGHT
DOWN THERE TO THEIR HANDS ARE
KIND OF TIED AS TO WHAT THEY CAN
DO THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
CHIEF WAS TALKING ABOUT. ADDING
SERVICES REMOVING SERVICES AND
THAT GETS TO BE KIND OF A PAIN
BUT THEY'RE THE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS. LET'S WORK TOGETHER TO
SEE IF WE CAN GET SOMETHING THAT
WORKS FOR THE GENTLEMAN THAT
WERE JUST SPEAKING HERE A MINUTE
AGO AND ARE FEEL THAT ANYBODY
THAT FIXES CARS FOR MONEY. NEED
TO HAVE NEED TO BE REGULATED YOU
KNOW SO THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S OUR
POINT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU. EXPECT A PLEASE.
THANK YOU ARE JACQUELYN DONNA
FROM THE HALF OF THE AUTOMOTIVE
SERVICE COUNCILS OF CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA AUTOMOTIVE
BUSINESS COALITION IN THE
CALIFORNIA AUTO BODY
ASSOCIATION.
I'M ALSO ON THE MEMBER OF THE
BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE. REPAIR
ADVISORY THEY'RE SO.
IN TERMS OF THE PERFORMANCE ARE
DOING A GOOD JOB OF I WANT TO
MAKE THREE QUICK POINTS HERE.
NUMBER ONE IT WAS TOUCHED ON
EARLY BY SPEAKER THE BEER
ADVISER COMMITTEE THAT I MENTION
I SIT ON THE THAT THAT COMMITTEE
IS COMPRISED OF INDUSTRY FOLKS.
CONSUMER FOLKS AND IT MEETS ON A
QUARTERLY BASIS TO DISCUSS
INDUSTRY ISSUES THEY'RE DOING A
GOOD JOB.
AND WE NEED TO CONTINUE.
IT'S IT'S A IT'S AN IMPORTANT
COMMITTEE IN NEED TO CONTINUE.
NUMBER TWO AND I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO BE DISCUSSED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
IN TERMS OF AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT TO BE ART.
TAKES QUITE A LONG TIME TO HAVE
REGULATIONS APPROVE SOMETIME
TAKE TAKE FOR FIVE YEARS.
THAT'S JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE.
SO THAT THAT'S IT THAT'S THE
SECOND COM AND THE THIRD COMMENT
IS A MINOR SERVICES ISSUE THIS
IS BEEN A VERY CONTROVERSIAL
ISSUE I TESTIFIED ON THIS FOUR
YEARS AGO. THE MINOR SERVICES
EXEMPTION WAS PUT IN PLACE IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE DURING THE
MUSCLE CAR ERA.
AND THEY WERE EXEMPTIONS FOR
GAS STATIONS BASICALLY IF YOU
DID MINOR SERVICES SPARK PLUGS
TIRES OF BATTERIES THAT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE TO FALL UNDER THE
B. A. R. OVERSIGHT. THINGS HAVE
CONSIDERABLY CHANGED OVER THAT'S
ALMOST FIFTY YEARS AGO.
THE CARS INTO IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGY HAS CHANGED.
NOW EVEN CHANGING OIL OR AN OIL
FILTER REQUIRES.
EXPERTISE OF REMOVING
COMPONENTS OF CONSUMERS RIGHT
NOW ARE NOT BEING PROTECTED.
IT'S NOT A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD
FOR THE OTHER SHOPS THAT DO OIL
CHANGES THE SAME SERVICE.
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE EXAMINE
THIS AND DETERMINE
WHICH SERVICES ARE CONTINUE TO
DO IT BE MINOR AND WHICH
SERVICES NEED TO BE MAJOR AND AN
OVERSIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE CLIFF
CUSTOM MAY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
NEW CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION. AS
THE SORT OF FOLKS IN THE
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR INDUSTRY THAT
DOES EVERYTHING FROM OIL CHANGES
A SMALL CHECKS TO COMPLETE
ENGINE REBUILT AND ACCEPT OUR WE
ARE THE MOST REGULATED. AMONGST
FOR.
INDUSTRY IN THE AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR INDUSTRY SO FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE. WE WANNA THANK
DIRECTOR TO DIRECT A WE WANT TO
THANK. MISTER GRAFFITO WE
BELIEVE THE AGENCY IS WORKING
WONDERFULLY THE INPUT THAT WE
RECEIVE BACK THE. BACK AND FORTH
FEEDBACK LOOK NO ONE IS EVER
GOING TO AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THE REGULATOR SAYS BUT THAT'S
THE PROCESS THAT'S WHAT WE NEED
WE NEED OPENNESS WHEN YOU
TRANSPLANTNESS AND WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WHEN
THERE ARE ISSUES. YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT THIS MINOR REPAIR
ISSUE TODAY I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MISTER AMALA DONNA
WHO SPOKE BEFORE ME. THERE ARE
SERIOUS ISSUES HERE CONSUMERS
ARE NOT BEING PROTECTED. WE GOT
VERY INVOLVED WITH TWO BILLS
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN
UNFORTUNATELY GOVERNOR SIGNED
ONE AND VETOED THE OTHER.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THESE ISSUES YET AGAIN.
AND SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE AND AT
THE RECOMMENDATION FROM THE DAY
OF THE COMMITTEES AND ALSO WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN TO TRY TO
DERAIL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP. HIS
PROFESSIONALISM THAT HE DIDN'T
STILL THROUGHOUT THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK I WANT TO ALSO REMIND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT THERE
WOULD BE ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK DURING THE NORM BILL
HEARING. UP WITH THIS SAYS WITH
RESPECT TO THE SUNSET DATE SO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TO OUR WITNESSES SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT AND THAT WILL NOW
CONCLUDE THIS REVIEW OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU OF AUTOMOTIVE
REPAIR. I WILL NOW THEN
TRANSITION TO. THE NEXT ITEM
THAT WE HAVE LISTED ON OUR
AGENDA. WHICH IS THE REVIEW OF
THE BUREAU OF A LIKE TRONIC AN
APPLIANCE REPAIR HOME
FURNISHINGS AND THE THERMAL
INSULATION AND SO IF.
THE INDIVIDUALS FROM THE BUREAU
WOULD PLEASE JOIN US HERE ON THE
DICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
COULD FEEL FOR SITTING TIGHT IN
KEEPING THAT SEAT WARM OR THE
DURATION OF. THE TESTIMONY OF
THE DAY. AND MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE WELL EQUIPPED AND GETTING
SOME. SUGAR IN YOU SO THAT
YOU'LL BE HERE FOR QUITE SOME
TIME NOW WITH THAT SAID OUR
BUREAU CHIEF OF POLICE DRESSES
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS NICHOLAS ALL OVER THE
CHIEF OF THE BUREAU OF
ELECTRONIC COMPLIANCE REPAIR.
HOME FURNISHINGS AND THERMAL
INSULATION.
WITH ME TODAY IS BEING HER
FELLOW DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
REPRESENT THE BUREAU AND RESPOND
TO SEVERAL ISSUES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE BUREAU'S
HISTORY.
FUNCTIONS AND ACTIVITIES.
THE GIRL INSURERS.
CONSUMER PROTECTION THROUGH
ENFORCEMENT OF THREE BODIES OF
LAW.
THE HOME FURNISHINGS AND THERMAL
INSULATION ACT. ELECTRONIC AN
APPLIANCE REPAIR LAW. IN THE
SONG VERBALLY CONSUMER WARRANTY
ACT.
AT PRESENT THERE ARE THREE CORE
AREAS ON WHICH THE BUREAU
FOCUSES ITS WORK.
FIRST THE HOME FURNISHINGS AND
THERMAL INSULATION PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN ELEVEN.
AND INCLUDES THE REGULATION OF
MANUFACTURERS.
RETAILERS WHOLESALERS AND
FLAMMABILITY STANDARDS OF HOME
FURNISHINGS MATTRESSES AND
INSTALLATION.
SECOND. THE ELECTRONIC APPLIANCE
REPAIR PROGRAM WAS ESTABLISHED
IN NINETEEN SIXTY THREE.
IN RESPONSE TO FRAUD IN THE
TELEVISION REPAIRED HISTORY.
OVER THE YEARS AS TECHNOLOGY HAS
EVOLVED.
THE PROGRAM'S REGULATORY
AUTHORITY EXPANDED TO COVER THE
REPAIR OF MAJOR HOME APPLIANCES.
AND MOBILE PHONE REPAIR.
AND LASTLY THE BUREAU REGULATES%
THE SERVICE CONTRACT INDUSTRY BY
ENSURING CONTRACTS COMPLY WITH
THE SONG BEVERLY. CONSUMER
WARRANTY ACT.
AND THAT PROPER FINANCIAL
RESOURCES ARE IN PLACE TO BACK
THE CONTRACTS.
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE LESS
FAMILIAR WITH THE SERVICE
CONTRACTS. TYPICAL TYPICALLY
REPAIR OR REPLACEMENT SERVICES
SENATE BILL NINETEEN PASSED
LAST YEAR WILL EXPAND THE
BUREAU'S LICENSING POPULATION.
TO INCLUDE HOUSEHOLD MOVERS.
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
WE'LL DISCUSS HOW THE BUREAU'S
IMPLEMENTING THIS NEW
RESPONSIBILITY LATER IN MY
TESTIMONY.
THE BUREAU COMMUNICATES WITH
INDUSTRY BY PARTICIPATING IN
PUBLIC AND COMMUNITY EVENTS.
HOLDING WORKSHOPS ON REGULATORY
CHANGES.
UPDATING OUR REACH MATERIALS TO
EDUCATE STAKE HOLDERS ON THE
GIRLS MOST RECENT CHANGES.
AND THROUGH HOLDING REGULAR
ADVISORY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
TO CARRY OUT OUR ENFORCEMENT
MANDATE THE BUREAU INVESTIGATES
CONSUMER COMPLAINTS.
POSSIBLE VIOLATIONS OF THE ACT
AND REGULATIONS.
AND TAKES ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION
AGAINST THOSE WHO FAIL TO COMPLY
WITH THESE LAWS.
SOME RECENT ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF
THE BUREAU COULD IMPLEMENTING A
NEW WEBSITE THAT REMOVED
DUPLICATIVE AND OUTDATED
INFORMATION.
USING SOCIAL MEDIA TO
DISSEMINATE INFORMATION
REGARDING CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
AND RIGHTS.
AND HOLDING MORE THAN TWENTY
COMMUNITY OUTREACH EVENTS.
FOR CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES.
DURING TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
I'VE ALSO BEEN WORKING TO FIND
PROACTIVE WAYS TO MODERNIZE AND
STANDARDIZE. MANDATES AND
PRACTICES.
FOR EXAMPLE.
THE BUREAU'S INTERESTED ALLOWING
BUSINESSES TO USE ELECTRONIC
MEANS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
CONSUMERS REGARDING ESTIMATES.
INVOICING AND ORDERS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AS WE FURTHER
EXPLORE THIS POSSIBILITY.
I WOULD NOW LIKE TO RESPOND TO
SEVERAL ISSUES IDENTIFIED BY THE
COMMITTEE'S.
FIRST.
I WILL DRESS ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
FROM THE BACKGROUND PAPER
RELATED TO THE BUREAU'S OUT
REACH.
WE WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S COMMUNICATIONS
DIVISION TO DEVELOP AN UPDATED
OUT REACH PLAN UTILIZING SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS.
AND TARGETED INTERNET
ADVERTISING. AND BETTER
PLACEMENT ON WEB SEARCHES.
THE BUREAU CURRENTLY ADMINISTERS
PAGES ON FACEBOOK. TWITTER AND
LINKEDIN TO FACILITATE.
STAKEHOLDER INFORMATION AND
SHARING AND THE SHARING OF
IDEAS.
EXAMPLES OF CURRENT OUT REACH
EFFORTS INCLUDE LEVERAGING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH DC BOARDS AND
GIRLS TO HOST. THEIR HALF OF THE
LICENSING WORKSHOPS AND TO
DISTRIBUTE EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS.
PARTNERING WITH THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSING BOARD. TO.
PRESENT AT SENIOR SCAM STOPPER
VENTS.
AND COLLABORATING WITH THE BOARD
OF EQUALIZATION TO HOST EVENTS
FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY OUTREACH AT
COLLEGES CITY HALLS AND SENIOR
CENTERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SINCE MY APPOINTMENT IN
SEPTEMBER TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN.
WE HAVE ALSO PRIORITIZE OUR
REACH TO THE INDUSTRY.
ZERO STUFF HAS MET WITH
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS.
TO IMPROVE PUBLIC KNOWLEDGE OF
WHERE HAVE THESE PROGRAMS.
THESE RECENT INDUSTRY OUT REACH
EFFORTS HAVE FOCUSED ON
IDENTIFYING OPPORTUNITIES TO
IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE INDUSTRIES.
THE GIRL ALSO REGULARLY CONVENES
BETTER VISOR COUNCIL ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
TO BOTH INFORM THE WORK OF HALF
THE AND TO SOLICIT PUBLIC INPUT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
COMMITTEE HELD TWO MEETINGS.
AND IT'S WORK FOCUSED ON THE
TRANSITION OF HOUSEHOLD GOODS
MOVERS TO THE GIRL.
OUR REACH AND STAFFING.
GIVEN THE UPCOMING ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY OF LICENSING OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVERS THE
BUREAU HAS EXPANDED THE BODY TO
ADD TO INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES.
AS WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
PORTENTS OF PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THESE TYPES OF FORMS. WILL BEGIN
WEBCASTING ITS COMMITTEE
MEETINGS BEGINNING WITH ITS
MARCH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
MEETING.
WE HAVE MADE GREAT PROGRESS TO
LEVERAGE THE LIMITED RESOURCES
WE HAVE AND UTILIZE TECHNOLOGY
IN OUR OUR REACH EFFORTS.
THE GIRL LOOKS FORWARD TO MAKING
MORE PROGRESS IN THE COMING
YEAR.
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS ARE
WHERE.
OF THE ROLE OF THE BUREAU. AND
THEIR RIGHTS.
NOW I WILL DISCUSS ITEM NUMBER
SIX FROM THE BACKGROUND PAPER.
RELATED TO THE TRANSFER OF THE
HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVERS PROGRAM.
IMMEDIATELY FOLLOWING THE
SIGNING OF SP NINETEEN.
AGAIN WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
TO FACILITATE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION OF DUTIES.
IN PREPARATION FOR INTEGRATING
THE DIVISION OF HOUSE HOLD GOOD
MOVERS TO THE GIRLS
JURISDICTION.
WE HAVE CREATED A PLAN THAT
OUTLINES KEY ADMINISTRATIVE
DETAILS WILL WORK ON CLOSELY
WITH THE CIA AND THE PC.
SOME OF THE FIRST STEPS WE'VE
TAKEN FOCUS ON LEARNING THE
CURRENT REGULATORY SYSTEM.
OBTAINING RESOURCES IDENTIFYING
HOW WE NEED TO MANAGE DATA. AND
HOW WE NEED TO COMMUNICATE WITH
THE INDUSTRY AND PUBLIC AT LARGE
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT CHANGE.
WE HAVE EXECUTED AN AGREEMENT TO
ALLOW THE BUREAU TO UTILIZE PC
HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVERS PROGRAM
REVENUE. TO SUPPORT THE BUREAU
AN ONBOARDING NEW STAFF.
TO FACILITATE THE TRANSFER OF
RESPONSIBILITY.
STAFF WILL WORK WITH PC FOR
TRAINING ON THE VARIOUS ELEMENTS
OF THE HOUSEHOLD MOVERS PROGRAM
AS CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED.
GIVEN THE VAST DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN THE WAY P. YOU SEE AND
DCA PROGRAMS ARE GOVERNED.
WE WILL NEED TO INVEST
SIGNIFICANT TIME AND EFFORT INTO
DRAFTING A NEW SET OF
REGULATIONS.
WE SEE THIS AS ONE OF THE MAJOR
CHALLENGES WE ARE LIKELY TO
ENCOUNTER. BUT FEEL CONFIDENT.
BUT AN OPEN AND COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS WILL LEAD TO THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE OF
PROTECTING CONSUMERS. AND
ENSURING ENFORCEMENT TOOLS ARE
IN PLACE TO LEGALLY OPERATING
BUSINESSES HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD.
AS THE BUREAU WAS FORMALLY PART
OF THE RELEASE THREE PROGRAMS.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE CA TO
ADJUST THE TIMING OF OUR
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PROCESS.
WE ARE FORTUNATE THAT THE TIMING
OF THIS MAJOR TRANSITION OF
AUTHORITY FALLS NICELY WITHIN
THIS PROCESS.
OUR PLAN IS TO FOCUS ON THE
REGULATORY STRUCTURE WE NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY CARRY OUT THE
HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVERS PROGRAM.
THE SCHOOL SYSTEMS IN OUR
BUSINESS MAPPING PROCESS AND
ULTIMATELY GUIDE S TO SELECTING
THE BEST IT SOLUTION FOR OUR
EXPANDED PROGRAM.
IN THE MEANTIME MEANTIME. WE
WILL ACHIEVE COST SAVINGS BY
USING THE. EXISTING CPC IT
SYSTEM.
THE SYSTEM IN STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR ELECTRONIC CASE
TRACKING.
AND WE DO NOT ANTICIPATE ANY
MAJOR CHALLENGES.
LASTLY I WILL SHARE HOW WE ARE
WORKING TO ENSURE THE INDUSTRY
AND PUBLIC IS AWARE. OF THIS
CHANGE IN LAW.
THE BUREAU'S FOCUSED ON
NOTIFYING INDUSTRY MEMBERS OF
THE TRANSFER OF AUTHORITY FROM
PC TO THE BUREAU AND PROVIDING
CONTACT INFORMATION. FOR THE
BUREAU.
WE ARE FINALIZING DIRECT
OUTREACH TO EXISTING LICENSEES
AND CREATING EASY TO USE TOOLS
LIKE A FREQUENTLY ASKED
QUESTIONS FIRE FOR DISTRIBUTION.
DIRECTOR PHIL AND I WILL SPEAK
AT THE CALIFORNIA MOVING AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATIONS ONE HUNDRED
YEAR CONVENTION ON APRIL
TWENTIETH TO INTRODUCE DC GAMES
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
PRESENT INFORMATION ABOUT
LICENSING AND THE BUREAU'S
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
AND RESPOND TO QUESTIONS.
LEADING UP TO JULY ONE.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING ON USER
FRIENDLY UPDATES TO THE WEBSITE
THAT WILL ALLOW THE INDUSTRY TO
GET KEY INFORMATION LIKE FORMS.
LICENSING A COMPLAINT
PROCEDURES.
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS.
THE WEBSITE WILL ALSO ALLOW. THE
PUBLIC TO UTILIZE A LICENSE
LOOKUP. AND THE ABILITY TO FILE
ON MY COMPLAINTS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION AND
SISTER AGENCIES TO SCHEDULE
ADDITIONAL HOURS AND EDUCATION
EFFORTS. SUCH AS THE LICENSING
WORKSHOP AND PARTICIPATING IN
PUBLIC EVENTS.
NEXT I WILL DISCUSS ISSUE NUMBER
SEVEN.
RELATED TO LICENSE
CONSOLIDATION.
FOLLOWING ENACTMENT OF AB TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY. THE BUREAU
COMMISSIONED A MARKET ASSESSMENT
STUDY.
WHICH WAS COMPLETED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
THE ASSESSMENT FOUND THAT THE
BUREAU'S LICENSE TYPE SHOULD BE
DETERMINED BY THE BUSINESSES
ROLE IN THE SUPPLY CHAIN NOT THE
BUSINESSES COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
HOWEVER CALIFORNIA'S MANY
FURNITURE MANUFACTURER.
WHOLESALER AND IMPORTER LICENSES
ARE DETERMINED BY WHETHER THE
APPLICANT IS LOCATED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
RATHER THAN THE ACTIVITIES THE
BUSINESSES PERFORM. WHICH IS THE
STANDARD USED BY MANY OTHER
STATES.
AMENDING THE LICENSE TYPES TO
FOLLOW THE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
ASSESSMENT. ME SIMPLIFY THE
LICENSING PROCESS. AND WOULD
ALLOW THE BUREAU TO IMPLEMENT.
A CONSISTENT REGULATORY SCHEME
REGARDLESS OF THE LICENSEES
LOCATION.
THE ASSESSMENT ALSO RECOMMENDED
THE BUREAU CONSIDER
CONSOLIDATING ITS SEPARATE
FURNITURE RETAILER. BEDDING
RETAILER AND COMBINATION
FURNITURE AND BEDDING RETAILER
LICENSES.
WALL CONSOLIDATING THE THREE
LICENSES INTO ONE COMBINED
LESSONS WOULD PROVIDE THE POOR
WITH LICENSING EFFICIENCIES.
THE FEES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
COMBINED LESSONS WOULD HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
ONLY OFFER FURNITURE OR BEDDING
FOR CELL.
THERE ARE POTENTIAL CHALLENGES
TO IMPLEMENTING EITHER OF THESE
CONSOLIDATION. RECOMMENDATIONS
INCLUDING INTENSIVE OUTREACH IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ABROAD.
A TRANSITION PERIOD FOR
LICENSEES.
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CHANGES
AND MANY OTHER NECESSARY
COMPONENTS TO SUCCESSFUL SHIFT
AND LICENSING SCHEMES.
WELL THIS IS SOMETHING THE
BUREAU MAY CONSIDER IN THE
FUTURE. WE ARE FOCUSING OUR
CURRENT EFFORTS ON SUCCESSIVELY
ON BOARDING THE HOUSEHOLD GOOD
MOVERS REGULATORY PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION WHILE THE BUREAU
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN MOVING TO
AN ANNUAL RENEWAL FOR THE
EXISTING LICENSE TYPES TO ENSURE
A MORE PREDICTABLE REVENUE
STREAM ANCHOR TELL FOR SOME
COSTS.
THIS WOULD ALSO REQUIRE AN
INTENSIVE OUTREACH EFFORT.
AND HAVE IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES.
WITH REGARD TO THE HOUSEHOLD
GOODS MOVERS. THE BUREAU HAS
IT'S BEEN MANDATED TO CONDUCT A
FEE STUDY TO ASSESS THE BEST FEE
STRUCTURE.
BUT IT IS PREMATURE TO PREDICT
WHAT THE STRUCTURE WILL LOOK
LIKE OR WHAT WOULD BE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE LICENSE RENEWAL
CYCLE.
FINALLY I WILL DRESS ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE.
RELATED TO THE SERVICE CONTRACT
WORKING GROUP.
WHICH WAS FORMED BY THE BUREAU
TO PREPARE A REPORT THAT DETAILS
WHAT ASPECTS OF SERVICE CONTRACT
STATUTES AND REGULATIONS REQUIRE
MODIFICATION.
THE WORK GROUP MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE REPORT
THEY PRODUCE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN.
MANY OF WHICH WOULD STRENGTHEN
THE GIRLS OVERSIGHT OF SERVICE
CONTRACT ADMINISTRATORS.
GRANTED BUREAU ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS. AND ENHANCE
THE BUREAU'S ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
THE BUREAU AGREES IN CONCEPT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION TO
STANDARDIZE THE FREE LOOK. FOR
SERVICE CONTRACTS.
A FREE LOOK PERIOD IS A LENGTH
OF TIME WHEN A NEW SERVICE
CONTRACT HOLDER MAY TERMINATE.
THE CONTRACT WITHOUT PENALTIES.
CURRENT LAWS INCONSISTENT WITH
SOME PRODUCTS RECEIVING A THIRTY
DAY PERIOD AND OTHERS A SIXTY
DAY PERIOD.
THE WORKING GROUP RECOMMENDED
STANDARDIZING THE FREE LOOK
PERIOD TO THIRTY DAYS.
WHILE THE BOROUGH AGREES THAT
STANDARDIZATION IS NECESSARY IN
THE INTEREST OF CONSUMER
PROTECTION.
THE BUREAU BELIEVES THAT A
STANDARD SIXTY DAY FREE LOOK.
IS THE MOST APPROPRIATE
SOLUTION.%
THE WORKING GROUP ALSO
RECOMMENDED AMENDING THE
DEFINITION OF SERVICE CONTRACT
TO INCLUDE CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
IN FAVOR OF THE CURRENT LIST OF
PRODUCTS THE BUREAU REGULATES.
THE BEER WOULD BE HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL INPUT
REGARDING A POSSIBLE CHANGE.
TO THE STATUTE AS IT WOULD MEAN
THAT ALL SERVICE CONTRACTS WOULD
HAVE BUREAU OVERSIGHT.
AND THEREFORE PROVIDE A PLACE
FOR CONSUMERS TO BRING CONCERNS.
THE BUREAU SUPPORTS THE WORKING%
GROUP'S RECOMMENDATION THAT
WOULD REQUIRE A UNIQUE NUMBER
AND EVISION DATE ON ALL SERVICE
CONTRACTS.
THIS CHANGE WOULD BENEFIT
INDUSTRY.
CREATE TRANSPARENCY FOR
CONSUMERS.
AND HELP THE BUREAU RECOVER
SIGNIFICANT STAFF HOURS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY DEDICATED. TO DOING
LINE BY LINE COMPARISONS OF
DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF CONTRACTS.
ANOTHER ISSUE THE WORKING GROUP
CONSIDERED WAS TO ADDRESS WHEN
SERVICE CONTRACTORS.
ARE UNABLE TO FULFILL A REPAIR
ON AN ITEM.
DUE TO THE LACK OF AVAILABLE
PARTS FROM THE MANUFACTURER.
IN INSTANCES WHERE THE
MANUFACTURER GOES OUT OF
BUSINESS OR OTHERWISE FAILS TO
SUPPLY THE PARTS FOR LITERATURE.
THE SERVICE CONTRACTOR MAY BE
LIABLE FOR REPLACEMENT OF THE
PRODUCT IN LIEU OF REPAIR.
THE BUREAU IS AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
UNAVAILABILITY OF PARTS.
HOWEVER THIS FALLS OUTSIDE OF
THE JURISDICTION.
I WOULD APPRECIATE.
SEE THE OPPORTUNITY TO UPDATE.
THE COMMITTEE'S LONGER
OPPORTUNITIES AND WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE SOME GOOD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OTHER QUESTIONS OF ANYONE.
SENATOR DROP IT JUST LIKE TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT LAST POINT YOU
HAD ABOUT SERVICE CONTRACTS IN
THAT YOU KNOW YOU SAID THAT
SERVICE.
YEAH.
THE COMPANY TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICE CONTRACTS IF THERE'S NO
PARTS FROM THE MANUFACTURER. MAY
BE REQUIRED TO AND YOU HAVE NO.
AUTHORITY TO CHANGE THAT WHAT
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT I I DID I
DIDN'T MEAN I'VE GOT THAT
STRAIGHT.
SO WE WE DON'T CURRENTLY.
.
US MANUFACTURERS ARE COVERED
UNDER THE SERVICE CONTRACTS
CURRENTLY.
THAT WOULD TAKE A LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE WE COVERED THE OR WE ARE
ABLE TO FORCE THE REPAIR.
BUT NOT THE REQUIREMENT THAT.
FAVORITE PART IS OF A REPAIR.
.
GOT IT REPAIR PART IS YOU PUT A
TIME LIMIT IN THERE THAT'S WHAT
GETS REASONABLE SO THAT.
IT BE MAY BE.
EASY FOR YOU TO ADMINISTRATE AND
WHEN YOU GET CALLS.
YEAH BUT DON'T LOOK AT THIS.
THANK YOU OUR LIVE TO OVER TEN
YEARS ARE OVER FIFTEEN YEARS
OLD.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT.
.
YOU KNOW THERE SEEMS TO BE SOME
LIKE THAT MANUFACTURES A LOT OF
PLANNED OBSOLESCENCE WHERE THEY
DON'T MAKE THE REPAIR PARTS
ANYMORE AND. THAT'S BEEN EVEN A
PART OF THEIR STRATEGY SINCE WE
CAN'T GO BACK TO THE
MANUFACTURERS IT SEEMS PRETTY
TOUGH.
IT LEAVES FORWARD.
IT MAY BE A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME
OR SOME PERIOD OF TIME. IF YOU.
REQUIRE THEM TO REPLACE REPLACE
IT WITH SOMETHING EQUAL I GET
THAT IF IT'S LESS THAN TEN YEARS
IF IT'S MORE THAN TEN YEARS I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE GIVEN THAT.
ANY THOUGHT.
WE WOULDN'T WE'D BE HAPPY TO
EXPLORE THAT WITH THE SERVICE
CONTRACT INDUSTRY I MEAN I'M NOT
AWARE OF IT AND IT AND EGGS. A
TIMELINE THAT IS BEEN OFFERED AT
THIS TIME BUT.
I MEAN IT'S DEFINITELY SOMETHING
IS ONE OF THE I USED TO BE IN
THIS BUSINESS WERE YEAH WE DID
SERVICE CONTRACTS AND YOU KNOW
WE. WERE WE REPAIRED A LOT OF
MAKES IT A LOT OF MODELS AND HAD
SERVICE CONTRACTS AND MOST OF
THEM YOU CAN GET.
A RADIO REPAIR PARTS BIRD HE
JUST SEEM TO BE BUT. YOU HAVE
YET A REPAIR PART THAT'S WORTH
FORTY OR FIFTY BUCKS AND THAT.
THE APPLIANCE NOW IS OBSOLETE
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET THAT FORTY
OR FIFTY DOLLAR PART HE GOT
SERVICE CONTRACTOR HAVING TO BUY
A FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR ITEM. I
DON'T KNOW.
THAT'S SOME FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
THANK YOU.
YES THE DOCTOR CAN.
I JUST WANTED.
OKAY I JUST WANT THE FAULT ISSUE
NUMBER FOR STAFFING I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE. AT RISE AND AND A
VACANCIES SIGH NOTED THAT WAS
MENTIONED WAS IS THAT.
.
RETIREMENT SENIOR FIELD STAFF.
YES TERMS OF
WHAT MORE SHOULD WE DO TO HELP
ENSURE THAT. THIS.
DID YOU DO YOUR WORK YOU NEED TO
HAVE THE FIELD STAFF THERE RIGHT
AND I I DON'T KNOW THE TERMS OF.
EXAMPLES YOU'RE LOOKING OUT WHAT
PERCENTAGE YOUR CURRENT STAFF
ARE NEARING RETIREMENT AND WHAT
ARE YOUR TREATMENT NEEDS. YOU
HAVE SUFFICIENT ARE YOU A RE
COMPETITIVE IN TERMS OF FOR
RECRUITING IN TERMS OF SALARIES
FOR PEOPLE TO TO RECRUIT FOLKS.
I MEAN I'M.
WOULD.
ALWAYS DISTURBS ME WHEN I SEE
OUR ENFORCEMENT BOARDS.
TALKING ABOUT STAFFING ISSUES.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
WE HAVE HISTORICALLY HAD.
AN ISSUE AND WITH THE FIELD A
REPRESENTATIVE THERE HAS BEEN
SOME. YOU KNOW A FEW
RETIREMENTS.
SO SINCE I'VE BEEN THE BUREAU
CHIEF WE.
CHANGE THE CLASSIFICATION FOR
THE FIELD STAFF TO A RE CLASSES
TO SPECIALISTS TO GET HER. WHICH
IS A MUCH MORE COMPETITIVE.
.
CLASSIFICATION AND HAVE SINCE
WE'RE WE'RE FULLY STAFFED NOW IN
THE FIELD.
DURING THE LAST FOUR MONTHS SO
YOU FOLKS YOU'RE FULLY STAFFED
NOW WE ARE. EXCELLENT YEAH.
THANK YOU DOCTOR FAN OF THE
CHAIR LOW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
KINGDOM INFORMED ABOUT THE.
EVOLVING NATURE WITH RESPECT TO
ENFORCEMENT OF PRIVACY.
THE INTERNET OF THINGS AND THAT
OF HOME APPLIANCES THAT BAND
ADVENT OF TECHNOLOGY I'M GLAD TO
SEE ON. JUNE OF CYBER SECURITY
AND ASSEMBLY AND A MEMBER OF THE
PRIVACY COMMITTEE BUT.
MANY OF THE ISSUES WITH RESPECT
TO INTERNET OF THINGS AND
APPLIANCES.
AND THE INCREASE OF FOCUS ON
DATA AS I'VE BEEN AN ISSUE THAT
HAS BEEN ON YOUR RADAR.
TO MIND THAT IS NOT AN ISSUE
THAT HAS BEEN.
BROUGHT UP.
TO ME IT'S IT'S ON OUR RADAR
RIGHT NOW PER SE AS FAR AS THE
REPAIRS OF.
ELECTRONICS.
THIS CAN IS CONCERNED.
.
I MEAN I GUESS IT'S SOMETHING WE
CAN LOOK INTO IT.
ARE YOU REFERRING SPECIFICALLY
TO CELLPHONE.
THE BOMBS WERE TO JUST
APPLIANCES REFRIGERATORS.
ANYTHING SO YOU CAN TALK TO
MANY DEVICES AND THERE'S STATED
THAT IT'S BEEN TRACKED.
AND SO I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE AND
AND IS OBSERVING TO MR CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT MIGHT BE IN
PLACE. WITH RESPECT TO MANY
DIFFERENT APPLIANCES AND ITEMS
AS WELL THAT CERTAINLY THE
DIRECTION OF OF INDUSTRY. AS YOU
KNOW.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LOW OF. THE DISTRAUGHT
OVER YOU'RE FAIRLY NEW I KNOW AT
THE AT THE BUREAU. HOW'S IT
GOING.
IT'S GOING WELL.
FOR TOO. DID THE.
WHEN YOU STARTED WHAT RESOURCES
AND TRAINING DID DCA PROVIDE FOR
YOU.
THERE WAS AN EXTENSIVE ON
BOARDING A PROCESS WITH.
ALL OF THE DIVISIONS WITHIN THE
CIA.
WHERE YOU KNOW THE PRESENTED?
?
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY YOU KNOW LIKE
A.
YEAH I DID A PRESENTATION BUT
ALSO WITH MATERIALS.
AND.
DIFFERENCE SET YOU KNOW WERE
STAFFING NEEDS.
WHAT?
WHAT THEY ARE WHAT THEY CAN
OFFER BY THE BUREAU AS WELL I
MEAN SO? THAT WAS COMFORTABLE
THAT AT I HAVE A VERY
COMFORTABLE WITH IT.
NOVELS THAT PROCESS TOOK ON A
ROUGHLY A MONTH REALLY TO.
TO VISIT WITH ALL OF THE.
THE DIVISION WITHIN THE CIA.
GOOD THANK YOU ANY CHANGES IF IT
WORKED SUCCESSFULLY BECAUSE YOUR
PRESENTATION TODAY WAS A. WAS A.
WAS UP THERE AND IN TERMS OF OF
THAT. IS EFFORTS AS THE BUREAU
GIVEN ANY THOUGHT TO NOW THAT
YOU'RE ADDING YOU KNOW HOUSEHOLD
FURNITURE YOU KNOW HOUSE OF
MOVERS TO THE PROGRAM OF.
CHANGING THE NAME ARE YOU GOING
TO ADD THAT TO THE END OF THAT.
THE. WAY OF MAYBE STREAMLINING
THE LITTLE BIT THAT DOWN THE
ROAD WE COME UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT MAY WORK A LITTLE BETTER
ABSOLUTELY. WE WOULD.
YOU KNOW I LOVE THE. ISSUE OR
THE NEIGHBORHOOD DO YOU HAVE ANY
IDEAS NOW AND I I I'M NOT EVEN
GOING TO TRY.
I.
IT WOULD PROBABLY BE A LOT
LONGER IF I HAD HIT IT YOU KNOW
JUST BY. MY ABILITIES IN THAT
REALM.
IT ONE OF THE FINAL QUESTION
AND IT IS HERE HAS A PURE OPEN.
BEEN MADE AWARE OF ANY CONCERNS
WITH THE UPDATED FLAMMABILITY
STANDARDS THAT SAID TECHNICAL
BULLETIN ONE SEVENTEEN DASH
TWENTY THIRTEEN OR WITH THE
FLAME RETARDANT LABELING
REQUIREMENTS. THAT WOULD BE S.
B. TEN OF NINETEEN. OF.
BECAUSE WE TEN NINETEEN AND OF
THEIR ONE SEVENTEEN TWENTY
THIRTEEN STANDARDS SEEM TO BE
VERY SUCCESSFUL.
.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANY CONCERNS
NECESSARILY OF THOSE STANDARDS.
.
HOW?
IF THE OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW OPEN THIS TO PUBLIC
COMMENT TO. PLEASE COME FORWARD
IN.
WE WILL BE HERE TO THE TWO
MINUTE RULE TODAY YOUR DRINK.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN TOLD CHAIRMAN
LOW AND MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
KELLY JENSEN REPRESENTING THE
SERVICE CONTRACT INDUSTRY
COUNCIL.
WE HAVE APPRECIATED THE AXIS.
TO THE BUREAU CHIEF AND UP. THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
IN DCA STAFF WITH REGARD TO
ITEM TWELVE OR ISSUE TWELVE.
ARTICULATED IN THE BACKGROUND
SHEET WITH REGARD TO MODERNIZING
THE DEFINITION OF SECURITY CON.
SERVICE CONTRACTS.
AND LOOK FOR THE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THAT ISSUE TO MAKE SURE
THE CALIFORNIA IS IN LINE WITH
TWENTY TWO OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE A MOREGENERIC DEFINITION.
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY LOOK FORWARDTO
CONTINUING THIS CHARADE THANK
YOU MISTER JENSEN OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE PUBLIC OR ANY
PARTICULAR INTEREST GROUPS. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
TESTIMONY TODAY AND FOR FOR
BEING HERE THANK YOU. LOCAL.
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE REVIEW
OF THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
YOU'RE ALL SO IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE COME FORWARD AND. WE
WOULD APPRECIATE.
HOW ARE YOU WELCOME?
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS
HERE PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHERRY HILL CHAIR
LOW SENATORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND STAFF. MY NAME IS REBECCA
MAY AND A SERVICE BUREAU CHIEF
FOR THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
SPIRO THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME
HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE BUREAU
AND ARE PENDING SUNSET. I'M
JOINED BY TEAM GRAFFITI LOW
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
THE PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
SPIRITS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
LICENSURE AND REGULATION OF NON
FAMILY MEMBER PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY SEE INCLUDING.
CONSERVATORS GUARDIANS TRUSTEES
AND AGENTS UNDER DURABLE POWER
OF ATTORNEY FOR HEALTHCARE AND
FINANCES. AS DEFINED BY THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY ACT. THE
BUREAU AND THE ACT FIRST
ABOLITION TWO THOUSAND SIX FIVE
SP FIFTEEN FIFTY AUTHORED BY
SENATOR LIZ FIGUEROA.
PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC IS THE
PUREST HIGHEST PRIORITY
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY IS ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE OVERALL CARE
OF THEIR CLIENTS WHETHER
IMMEDIATE OR IN THE FUTURE. THEY
MANAGE PERSONAL FINANCES BASED
ON CLIENT NEEDS OFFERING
SERVICES RANGING FROM BASIC BILL
PAYING TO STATE AN INVESTMENT
MANAGEMENT.
OFFICIAL PRODUCERS ARE ALSO
CARE HOUSING AND MEDICAL NEEDS
OF SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THE BUREAU
BEGAN OPERATIONS JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN AND PROTECTS
CONSUMERS BY PROMOTING LEGAL AND
ETHICAL STANDARDS OF
PROFESSIONAL CONDUCT. ENFORCING
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS PRIOR TO
LICENSURE INVESTIGATING ALL
COMPLAINTS AND TAKING
DISCIPLINARY ACTION AGAINST
LICENSEES WHEN APPROPRIATE.
ALSO EDUCATE CONSUMERS ABOUT
THEIR RIGHTS INCLUDING THEIR
RIGHT TO QUALITY SERVICE THROUGH
ITS OUTREACH EFFORTS.
BUREAU ISSUES ONE LICENSE TYPE
THE PROFESSIONAL FISHERIES
LICENSE. THE BUREAU HAS ISSUED
ONE THOUSAND THIRTY NINE
LICENSES SINCE ITS INCEPTION. OF
WHO SEVEN HUNDRED THIRTY THREE
ARE CURRENTLY ACTIVE. THE BUREAU
TYPICALLY ISSUES AN AVERAGE OF
SEVENTY TWO NEW LICENSES EACH
YEAR AND RENEWS AN AVERAGE OF
FIVE UNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
LICENSES EACH YEAR.
SINCE OUR SUNSET REVIEW IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE BIR HAS
INCREASED THE PUREST THE BUREAU
CHIEF POSITION TO FULL TIME. AND
HIRED A FULL TIME ENFORCEMENT
ANALYSTS WE HAVE ALSO COMPLETED
A NEW STRATEGIC PLAN FOR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ARE UNDERGOING AN
OCCUPATIONAL ANALYSIS OF THE
LICENSING EXAMINATION.
THE BUREAU CONTINUES TO EXPLORE
WAYS TO INCREASE VISIBILITY AND
OUT REACH FOR THE FIDUCIARY
PROFESSION WHILE LICENSING
NUMBERS HAVE INCREASED FIFTEEN
PERCENT SINCE OUR LAST SUNSET
REVIEW. WE CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS AND CONSUMERS TO
INFORM THEM ABOUT THE BUREAU AND
THE PROFESSION.
WE'RE DEVELOPING AN OUT REACH
PLAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
PUBLIC AFFAIRS OFFICE THAT IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OUR STRATEGIC
PLAN SHOULD INCREASE AWARENESS
ABOUT BOTH THE FIDUCIARY
PROFESSION AND THE FEAR OF.
THE BEER ALSO HAS AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH EXAMINES THE
FUNCTIONS AND POLICIES OF THE
BUREAU AND MAKES
RECOMMENDATIONS.
IN PREPARING FOR SUNSET REVIEW
THE BUREAU HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO IDENTIFY AREAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT IN ITS FUNCTIONS.
WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO CAN
INCREASE CONSUMER PROTECTION.
AND ONE AREA OF CONCERN IS
LICENSEES BILLING THEIR CLIENTS
FOR RESPONDING TO CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS FILED WITH THE
BUREAU.
I'M UNAWARE OF ANY OTHER
PROFESSION THAT PERMITS THIS
PRACTICE. WE'RE EVALUATING THE
BEST WAY TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
ADDITIONALLY SOME OF THE
BUREAU'S REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
COULD USE UPDATING AND
CLARIFYING THE BUREAU IS KEY.
CONSIDERING STATUTORY CHANGES
THAT WOULD BETTER SPECIFY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER WHICH A
LICENSEE IS REQUIRED TO REPORT
TO THE BUREAU CASES. IN WHICH HE
OR SHE HAS RESIGNED OR BEEN
REMOVED AS A DIRECT RESULT OF A
COMPLAINT BEING FILED WITH THE
COURT. THESE CLARIFICATIONS
WOULD ASSIST THE BEER AND
COLLECTING THE INFORMATION IT
NEEDS WHILE MAKING IT EASIER FOR
LICENSEES TO COMPLY WITH
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. FINALLY
THE BUREAU IS EVALUATING WAYS
YOU COULD REDUCE BARRIERS TO
ENTRY INTO THE PROFESSION BY
INCLUDING AN EXPERIENCE ONLY
BASED PATHWAY. CURRENTLY ONLY
PERSONS WITH A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE AND THREE YEARS
OF EXPERIENCE OR FIVE YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE PRIOR TWENTY TWELVE
ARE QUALIFIED FOR LICENSURE.
PERMITTING APPLICANTS TO USE
RELEVANT EXPERIENCE AS A BASIS
FOR LICENSURE MAY BROADEN THE
LICENSEE POPULATION AND BRING
VALUABLE EXPERIENCE BASED
INSIGHT TO PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY. IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR WORK. NOW I'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THE ISSUES IDENTIFIED
BY THE COMMITTEES IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER. THE FIRST
ISSUE RELATES TO THE PUREST
POTENTIAL MOVE TO THE PRE
SYSTEM.
THE BEER WAS PART OF THE
ORIGINAL RELEASE THREE OF BREEZE
ND CONSISTENT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT'S BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN. IS CURRENTLY
EVALUATING WHETHER IT WILL BE
USING BREEZE IN THE FUTURE.
ALTHOUGH THE BUREAU IS NOT
EXPERIENCING ANY BACKLOGS IN
LICENSING OR ENFORCEMENT TO OUR
CURRENT IT SYSTEM. THE BEER IS
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
DETERMINE AN APPROPRIATE LONG
TERM SOLUTION.
HAS COMPLETED ITS BUSINESS
MAPPING. BUSINESS PROCESS
MAPPING AND WILL CONTINUE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA.
I'M SORRY AND WILL WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGIES
PROJECT APPROVAL LIFECYCLE TO
DETERMINE WHAT IT SYSTEM BEST
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE BUREAU.
THIS DETERMINATION SHOULD BE
MADE BY THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. UNTIL THE BUREAU AND
THE DEPARTMENT TO PLAY THE
PURISTS FUTURE SYSTEM THE BUREAU
WILL CONTINUE TO USE IT.
CURRENT DATABASE SYSTEMS TO MEET
ITS CORE BUSINESS NEEDS.
COMMITTEE STAFF OF ALSO ASK THE
BEER TO WEIGH IN ON SURVEYING
LICENSEES TO DETERMINE INTEREST
IN ESTABLISHING A BUSINESS.
ENTITY LICENSE BUREAU IS OPEN TO
CONDUCTING THE SURVEY AND
BELIEVES IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
APPROACH THIS ISSUE WITH A
CAREFUL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
UNIQUENESS OF THE FIDUCIARY
CLIENT RELATIONSHIP. BECAUSE THE
PHYSICAL AND FINANCIAL WELL
BEING OF THE CLIENT IS SO
DIRECTLY DEPENDENT ON THE
JUDGMENT AND ACTION OF A
FIDUCIARY THE BUREAU MUST
CAREFULLY CONSIDER THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ALLOWING
BUSINESS ENTITIES TO SERVE IN
THIS ROLE. THE PURE RECOGNIZES
THAT PROVIDING AN ENTITY LICENSE
MAY INCREASE CONTINUITY OF CARE
FOR CLIENTS IN THE EVENT A
FIDUCIARY IS NO LONGER ABLE TO
CARRY OUT HIS OR HER DUTIES. OR
WANTS TO RETIRE OR MOVE TO
ANOTHER PROFESSION.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE ROLE OF
FIDUCIARY PLACE IN THEIR CLIENTS
LIVES THERE ARE POTENTIAL RISKS
THAT SHOULD BE MITIGATED.
ANY POTENTIAL STATUTORY CHANGES
RELATED TO THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
AN ENTITY LICENSE SHOULD INCLUDE
SUFFICIENT ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY
SO THAT THE BUREAU CAN CONTINUE
TO UPHOLD ITS MANDATE TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS. REQUIRE LICENSEES TO
CARRY ADEQUATE INSURANCE
POLICIES AND ENSURE THAT THE
FEES ARE SET AND AN AMOUNT THAT
REFLECT THE TRUE COSTS OF
ADMINISTERING AND NEW LICENSE
TYPE.
FINALLY THE COMMITTEE RECOMMENDS
THAT THE REGULATION OF THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARY
PROFESSION AND THE OPERATIONS OF
THE BUREAU BE EXTENDED BY FOUR
YEARS. THE BUREAUCRACIES THAT
CONTINUED REGULATION OF THE
PROFESSION IS NEEDED TO ENSURE
CONSUMERS ARE PROTECTED. THE
BUREAU HAS SUCCESSFULLY UPHELD
ITS CONSUMER PROTECTION MANDATE
SINCE ITS INCEPTION AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO WITH A FOUR
YEAR SUNSET EXTENSION. I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR MANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YOUR HELP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ONE BRIEF QUESTION IS CAN YOU
BRIEFLY DESCRIBE OR DISCUSS ANY
PLANS THE BUREAU MAY HAVE TO
INCREASE OUR REACH. CONSUMES
CONSUMERS OR LICENSEES IS THERE
ANY EFFORT UNDER WAY TO TRY AND
DO THAT YES WE HAVE A TWO FOLD
PLAN FIRST IS OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
AND WERE OF. OUT REACH IS A BIG
PART OF THAT AND THAT'S ALMOST
FINISHED OMINOUS IN HIS THAT'S
WRAPPED UP WE'LL. GET TOGETHER
AND DO LIKE AN ACTION PLANS WILL
HAVE DELIVERABLES. ON AGAIN
OBJECTIVES FOR OUT REACH.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE PARTNERING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S PUBLIC
AFFAIRS OFFICE TO COME UP WITH A
PLAN FOR OUT REACH AS WELL. AND
IN THE MEANTIME I WE ATTEND A
LOT OF SENIOR.
SENIOR VANCE FRAUD EVENTS.
CERTAINLY IF THERE'S THINGS IN
YOUR DISTRICTS THAT YOU'D LIKE
US TO ATTEND A WORK AWFULLY OPEN
TO DOING THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RICHARD
CENTER DOT.
YOU HEARD.
.
HER RESPONSE TO YOU ABOUT THE
BRIEFS IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
BUREAU.
YOU KNOW I. I DON'T KNOW I HAVE
SOME TROUBLE MAY BE JUST FROM
THE FROM THE STANDPOINT OF
UNDERSTANDING YOU KNOW WHERE WE
ARE WITH THAT PROJECT OUT.
WHETHER WE INTEND TO IMPLEMENT
IT HERE OR NOT.
SEEMS TO BE WORDS THAT THAT
CAUSED ME SOME.
YOUR CONCERN ON THIS ONE AND
WHERE YOU ARE ON THIS SO
SPECIFICALLY HAS MISSED MAY
MENTIONED ARE SHE'S ABOUT TO
EMBARK UPON A PROGRAM IS ABOUT.
TO EMBARK ON A MUCH MORE
DELIVERY OF ROBUST PROCESS TO
DETERMINE. WHICH.
IT PLATFORM IN FACT IN FACT WILL
BE UTILIZED.
BY BY PROFESSIONAL FISHER'S
BUREAU YET TO BE DETERMINED
WHETHER OR NOT THAT IN FACT WILL
BE PRES.
SHE MENTIONED SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT RELEASED THREE PROGRAMS
ARE THAT WE'RE IN RELEASED
THREE.
THERE ARE APPROXIMATELY I
BELIEVE.
SIXTEEN PROGRAMS THAT. ARE
STILL GOING TO EMBARK UPON. I'M
THE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN
SO IT IS IT'S VERY POINT I
UNDERSTAND THAT.
RELEASE ONE AND RELEASED TO.
MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS DID IN
FACT SELECT BREEZE ARE ONE
PROGRAM. THAT YOU ALL MAY BE
AWARE OF SPECIFICALLY THE BEER
OF CANADA CANNABIS CONTROL OF IN
PART. BY LEARNING.
OR HEARD. VIA THE THE LESSONS
LEARNED AT HE DEPARTMENT
UNDERTOOK IN RELEASE ONE.
THE BUREAU OF CATS CAN CONTROL
DID NOT SELECT BREEZE AND SO
AGAIN MY POINT IS THAT.
RATHER THAN.
COMPELLING EACH REMAINING
PROGRAM AT LEAST THREE TO GO
THROUGH TO GO THROUGH ARE TO
SELECT BREEZE. THE PROCESS WILL
DETERMINE THAT MANY FACTORS WILL
BE CONSIDERED IN DETERMINING.
WHICH IT PLATFORM WILL IN FACT
BE SELECTED FOR THE REMAINING
RELEASED THREE PROGRAMS.
YET IT MAYBE THIS JUST DESERVES
THAT A MORE BROAD DISCUSSION
ABOUT BREEZY OUT IN IT IN IN
GENERAL AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND IF IF. IF IT DOESN'T
MEET THE NEEDS. OF THE BUREAUS.
.
YEAH YOU DON'T WANT TO FORCE A
SQUARE PEG IN A YOU KNOW IN A IN
A ROUND HOLE I GET THAT BUT I
ALSO GET THE FACT THERE'S ONE
HELL OF A LOT OF COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND.
I THINK WE JUST NEEDTO MAKE
DARN SURE THAT IT YET. IT.
BUT THERE IS SOME OVERSIGHT
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT IF IT IF
IT IS A POSSIBILITY OF IT BEING
USED EFFECTIVELY THAT WE GO THAT
ROUTE. I PLAYED EVERY SENATOR
AND BY DESIGN.
THAT IS THE APPROACH FOR THESE
RELEASED THREE. PROGRAMS AGAIN
VIA THE CURRENT BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION PLAN BUT
DEPARTMENT.
AND OTHERS HAVE DEVISED AT THIS
POINT THANK YOU ROCK.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY THAT.
SENTIMENT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JUST SUCH A
QUICK QUICK QUESTION THERE'S A
REFERENCE. TO THE SIZE OF YOUR
ESTIMATED YOUR LICENSEE
POPULATION AND IT'S MUCH SLOWER
THAN THE ESTIMATE. OR THE GROWTH
ESTIMATE GIVEN AND DIED BACK
INTO THE SERVICE ONLY TO THE
STATE SO BIG. AND THE WORLD IS
SO COMPLICATED WHAT WHAT
ACCOUNTS OTHER THAN THE EIGHTY
PERCENT OF COST OF A LICENSE TO
THE DEAD THAT DELTA BETWEEN. THE
HOURS OF WHAT WAS ESTIMATED A
FORECAST AND HOW SMALL IT DOES
SEEM. LIKE IN A PROFESSION FOR
TEACHERS TO PROVIDE A SERVICE
THAT IS NECESSARY SO IS IS
THERE.
A PROBLEM WITH UNLICENSED
ACTIVITY. AND IF SO WHAT SHOULD
WE DO ABOUT IT.
AND.
AT SO AS IN RESPONSE TO HAVING A
SMALLER ZERO AS I UNDERSTAND
WHEN THE BUREAU WAS FORMED THE
ESTIMATES FOR THE NUMBER OF
LICENSEES IS BASED OFF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAD A.
DISTRIBUTION AND THAT'S WERE
PRACTITIONERS AT THE TIME BEFORE
THEY WERE REQUIRED TO BE
LICENSED AND.
WORD THAT SITE AND BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S HOW THEY BEAT THE
ESTIMATES OF WHAT THOUGH
LICENSURE POPULATION WOULD BE.
RIGHT BUT IT'S GETS CLEARLY IT'S
NOT GROWING PROPORTION TO THE
NEW YEAR EVEN THE POPULATION SO
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THE
PROFESSION. I'M I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US TO BRING MORE
VISIBILITY TO THE PROFESSION AND
TO THE TO THE BUREAU THERE'S
BEEN A. GROWTH SINCE OUR LAST
SUNSET REVIEW ABOUT FIFTEEN
PERCENT AN ACTIVE LICENSES SO I
THINK THOSE. MEMBER SUGGESTS
THAT THERE IS.
I NEED FOR THE PROFESSION.
I GOT I THINK THAT'S CLEAR AGAIN
I KNOW I DON'T MEAN TO SOUND
LIKE I'M CRITICIZING I I THINK
IT'S IT'S IT'S MISSION QUESTION
THAT RELATES TO. MORE MARKET
FORCES REALLY THAN YOUR
OVERSIGHT SO. IT SEEMS SELF
EVIDENT TO ME THAT THAT PRESSURE
PRODUCERS TO PROVIDE A SERVICE
THAT STILL IT HAS TO BE TO THE
EXTENT THAT. I DID YOU THE THE
PUBLIC VERTICALLY THOSE IN NEED.
AREN'T BEING REFERRED TO WERE
CALLING UPON PROFESSIONALS.
CALLS OUT A PROBLEM BECAUSE THEN
CLEARLY YOU THERE FOR A REASON
YOU'RE PREVENTING PROBLEMS. WHAT
CERTAINLY OPEN TO INCREASING OUR
EFFORTS THERE AND MANY AND
ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENTIMENT
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMES
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CENA
OPEN THE PORTION OF THE HEARING
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM A
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME TO THE
MICROPHONE AND YOU ARE LIMITED
TO TWO MINUTES IN NAME AND
AFFILIATION IF YOU WISH TO DO SO
PLEASE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU ARMCHAIR LOW ENTER
HELL AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK.
I'M MEREDITH TAYLOR I AM A
CALIFORNIA LICENSE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY.
I'VE BEEN A FIDUCIARY FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
I'M VERY HAPPY TO BE LICENSED
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO.
NOT ONLY FOR MYSELF AND
FISHERIES BUT ALSO ON THE BEHALF
ON BEHALF OF THE FACT THAT
PROFESSIONAL FISHERIES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT THE
CONTINUATION OF THE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY SPIRO. ON WERE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR BEING LICENSED AND
FOR THE OVERSIGHT. AND
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE KNOWN ON NECESSARY AND
REQUIRED BY LAW FOR FIFTY
SHERRY'S. I'M I FEEL IT
LEGITIMIZES WHAT WE DO AND WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT.
WE ALSO JUST WANTED TO GIVE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THREE OF THE ISSUES.
UNDER THE CURRENT SUNSET REVIEW
ISSUES ARE MENTIONED. ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO UNLICENSED
REPRESENTATIVES AND ENROLLED
AGENTS.
WE CURRENTLY THE BUREAU DOES
NOT REQUIRE THE LICENSURE OF AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHO ACTS AS A
PERSONAL REPRESENTATIVE OF
DISSIDENTS THE STATES AND WE
FEEL THAT? THAT SHOULD BE
INCLUDED ON MOST FISHERIES DO DO
THIS KIND OF WORK. AND WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNLICENSED WHO ARE DOING THIS
KIND OF WORK.
THE BUREAU ALSO PROVIDES AN
EXEMPTION FOR FROM LICENSURE TO
ENROLLED AGENTS. AND RIGHT NOW
THEY ARE ABLE TO ACT WITHIN THE
SCOPE OF THEIR ON. THEIR.
JUST AS ENROLLED AGENTS BUT I
HAVE TO SAY THAT IF YOU ARE
DEEMED AS A FIDUCIARY.
DOING A LOT MORE WORK BESIDES
JUST ACTING AS A RULED AGENT AND
DOING TAX RETURNS. SO THAT'S
ANOTHER GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT WE
FEEL SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN OUR
ACT.
TO THIRD ISSUE IS THE.
WHICH WAS MENTIONED THE
REGISTRATION OF BUSINESS
ENTITIES.
WE WANTED TO PROVIDE OUR.
JUST INPUT IN SUPPORT OF THAT.
IT'S UP RIGHT NOW.
INDIVIDUALS ARE THE ONLY ONES
WHO REQUIRED AND ALLOWED TO GET
LICENSED TO AND WE WANTED TO
EXPAND THAT TO ALLOW ENTITIES.
TO POSSIBLY BE LICENSED AND. AS
WAS MENTIONED.
.
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS AN ISSUE
FOR THIS.
SECTION OF INSTITUTIONAL
KNOWLEDGE. AND I JUST WANT ALSO
MENTION THE SECURITY OF MULTI
GENERATIONAL ESTATE PLANNING
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
WERE ABLE TO STAY WITH THE SAME
FIDUCIARY FIRM. ON IT WOULD BE
VERY COST EFFECTIVE AND VERY
IMPORTANT TO OUR CLIENTS WHO ARE
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE. ON IT'S
WONDERFUL THAT THEY GET TO KNOW
ONE FIDUCIARY IN ONE FISHERY
AGENCY AND STAY WITH THEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
OF PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK. SEE
NONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS ME
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH DIRECTOR
GRAFFITO AS WELL THAT NOW
CONCLUDES THE REVIEW OF THE
PROFESSIONAL FISHERIES. ZERO.
AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO THE
REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
DIRECTOR COULD FILL.
WELCOME AGAIN.
YEAH.
PLEASE PROCEED.
MAKING SURE THAT REAL.
THE JAIL CHAIR LOW MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS INGA FEEL I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
BEFORE I GET MY FORMAL REMARKS I
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY SINCERE
GRATITUDE. TO ALL THE SENATORS
PRESENT HERE TODAY. VOTED IN
SUPPORT OF MY CONCOCT FORMATION
LAST WEEK MONDAY ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. INTO THE FAMILY MEMBERS
BY YOU COULDN'T VOTE FOR MY
CONFIRMATION MANY OF YOU
DIRECTLY SUPPORTED ME. THROUGH
THE WORK WE ACCOMPLISHED WHILE I
WAS EITHER IN OR NEAR THE
ASSEMBLY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FOUR.
WHEN I ARRIVED AT THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE.
THANK YOU.
I WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY.
TO DISCUSS THE DEPARTMENT AND
SOME ISSUES OF MUTUAL INTEREST.
BUT APARTMENT CONSUMER AFFAIRS
OVERSEAS THIRTY EIGHT UNIQUE
LICENSING PROGRAMS COMPRISE THE
BOARD'S COMMITTEES ROSE HAD A
COMMISSION.
BUT TO GET A LICENSE AND
REGULATE OVER THREE MILLION
LICENSEES AND MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED PROFESSIONAL AND ONE
HUNDRED BUSINESS CATEGORIES.
THE DEPARTMENT SERVES AND
SUPPORTS THESE THIRTY EIGHT
PROGRAMS IN THE AREAS OF
ENFORCEMENT. BUDGET.
PROCUREMENT. INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY.
LEGAL. COMMUNICATIONS HUMAN
RESOURCES STRATEGIC PLANNING AND
TRAINING AMONG MANY OTHER
SERVICES.
SINCE THE DEPARTMENT LAST
APPEARED BEFORE THESE COMMITTEES
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
WE HAVE MADE CHANGES TO
INCREASE.
TO INCREASE THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDES TO ALL
OF THE LICENSING ENTITIES.
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A PROUD A
WORKING GROUP WITH MEMBERS OF
THE PROGRAMS TO SEEK INPUT AND
FEEDBACK.
EXPANDED THE BOREDOM BUREAU
SERVICES OFFICE DISTRICT
PARTNERSHIP SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BUSINESS
PROCESSES AND COMMUNICATION OF
BEST PRACTICES ACROSS ALL BOARDS
IN YOUR HOUSE.
ESTABLISHED A FUTURE LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT THROUGH MEMBER
THROUGH MENTORSHIP TO ATTAIN
YOUNG TALENT AND TACKLE
SUCCESSION PLANNING.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WITH PLANS TO
RECONVENE THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
COORDINATION COMMITTEE. TO
REVIEW AND UPDATE THE UNIFORM
STANDARDS FOR SUBSIDY SUBSTANCE
ABUSE LICENSEES.
ESTABLISH LICENSING ENFORCEMENT
WORK GROUPS TO IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE BEST PRACTICES.
ESTABLISH STANDARDS AND IDENTIFY
TRENDS TO BENEFIT ALL THE LYSINE
ENTITIES UNDER THE DEPARTMENT.
DEVELOP AN INTERNAL ONLINE
REGULATIONS TRACKING SYSTEM TO
INCREASE TRANSPARENCY FOR THE
BOARDS ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALL
PARTIES INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS.
AND IMPLEMENT TRAINING TO HELP
PROGRAMS IMPROVE THE BUDGET
CHAIN PROPOSALS SUBMITTED FOR
REVIEW.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO ADDRESS THE THREE
ISSUES THE COMMITTEES HAVE ASKED
THE DEPARTMENT TO SPEAK ON.
FIRST ALL DRESS ISSUE NUMBER ONE
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENTS
PROVIDE A COST TO THE PROGRAMS.
BY OUR CALCULATION.
DISTRIBUTOR PROGRAM HAS GONE UP
BETWEEN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
ELEVEN TWELVE.
AND TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BY FIFTY THREE PERCENT.
IN COMPARISON STATE LEVEL PRO
RATA CHARGE TO DCA BY CONTROL
AGENCIES.
BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
INCREASED BY FIFTY NINE PERCENT
DURING THAT SAME TIME.
THE LARGEST CONTRIBUTOR TO
INCREASE IN PRO RATTA OVER THIS
TIME PERIOD. HAVE BEEN DUE TO
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION AND
RETIREMENT INCREASES.
THE DEPARTMENTS PROVIDE A MODEL
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE MODEL
USED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
FOR EXAMPLE AS I RECALL AND YOU
ALL WELL KNOW THE LEGISLATURE
WROTE RELIES UPON CENTRALIZED.
HUMAN RESOURCES AND FACILITIES
THROUGH THREE RULES COMMITTEE
AND LEGAL SERVICES THEIR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL.
IN ORDER TO GAIN EFFICIENCIES
AND CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE
VARIOUS LEGISLATIVE OFFICES.
THE DEPARTMENT IS STRUCTURED
MUCH THE SAME WAY.
THIS YEAR'S PROGRAMS ARE
PRIMARILY CHARGE PER RATHER.
BASED ON THEIR STAFFING LEVELS
SO ALL BOARDS AND AEROSPACE
DEPARTMENT THE SAME DOLLAR
AMOUNT TO PERFORM CENTRALIZED
SERVICE FOR ANY GIVEN POSITION.
THIS MODEL ASSUMES AVERAGES AND
ALLOWS THE PROGRAMS TO
PARTICIPATE IN DCA CENTRALIZED
SERVICES. MUCH LIKE AN INSURANCE
PROGRAM.
LIKE INSURANCE PROGRAMS MEET MAY
USE MORE OR LESS. GIVEN SERVICES
IN A PARTICULAR YEAR AND ON
AVERAGE THE SYSTEMS WORK TO
EVERYONE'S BENEFIT.
UNDER THIS MODEL COSTS ARE
STABILIZED PROVIDING A
PREDICTABLE BUDGET. ALLOWING THE
BOARDS AND BUREAUS TO USE AS
MUCH OF A SERVICE AS A NEED.
WITHOUT CONCERNS ABOUT GOING
OVER THEIR BUDGET.
THERE ARE POTENTIAL UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES.
PART OF ME THERE ARE POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
MOVING TO A USE MODEL.
PROGRAMS MAY NOT SEEK SERVICE
EVEN IF NEEDED.
FOR EXAMPLE THE PROGRAM A
PROGRAM YOU CHOOSE NOT TO PUSH A
REGULATION PACKAGE BECAUSE THEY
WOULD BE DIRECTLY CHARGE FOR
LEGAL SERVICES WHEN WE TRY TO
HANDLE SENSES SENSITIVE
PERSONNEL ACTIONS. WITHOUT HUMAN
RESOURCES EXPERTISE.
WITHOUT EXPERTISE TO ADVISE ON
THESE ISSUES PROGRAMS WOULD BE
EXPOSED TO POTENTIAL LIABILITY
LIABILITY. AND LARGER COSTS IN
THE LONG RUN.
AS MENTIONED IN THE
BACKGROUNDPAPER. THE DEPARTMENT
DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEM IN PLACE. TO TRACK
INDIVIDUAL STAFF TIME SPENT ON
SPECIFIC PROGRAMS.
IMPLEMENTING SUCH A PROGRAM
COULD BE EXTREMELY COSTLY. AND
IT WOULD BE A NEW IT SYSTEM AT
THE AME TIME WE'RE TRYING TO
ROLL OUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
BUSINESS MODERNIZATION PLAN.
I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT. AS I NOTED
EARLIER WE'VE STARTED A PRO RATA
WORKGROUP WITH REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE PROGRAMS TO DISCUSS
CONCERNS. RESOURCES AN
IMPROVEMENT TO SERVICES.
DOCUMENTING CERTAIN PROCESSES
AND EXPECTED TIME FRAMES MAY
ALSO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TRANSPARENCY.
I'M COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TO ENHANCE THE SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES. THE BEST
MEET THE NEEDS OF THE BOARDS AND
GROSS.
NEXT I WILL DRESS ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. OF THE BACKGROUND PAPER AND
DISCUSS THE LEGAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT PROVIDES TO OUR
PROGRAMS.
DO YOU SEE AS LONG SERVING
GENERAL COUNSEL. RECENTLY
RETIRED AFTER MORE THAN FIFTEEN
YEARS.
AND THE LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION
HAS A NEW DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR AND NEW MANAGEMENT
STRUCTURE TO BUILD UPON PREVIOUS
SUCCESSES.
THE DIVISION'S NEW MANAGEMENT IS
COMMITTED TO SEEKING OUT AN
INPUT IN IMPLEMENTING
IMPROVEMENTS WHERE NEEDED.
ONE AREA FOR IMPROVEMENT THAT
THE COMMITTEE IS IDENTIFIED WITH
THE TIMELINESS OF ADVICE ON
PERSONNEL MATTERS.
THE LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION
PROVIDES ADVICE REGARDING LABOR
AND EMPLOYMENT MATTERS TO DCA
CENTRALIZED SERVICES AND TO ITS
PROGRAMS.
ATTORNEYS DRAFT EMPLOYMENT
ACTIONS AND PROVIDE ADVICE ON
DISCIPLINE MATTERS.
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE HARASSMENT
AND DISCRIMINATION CLAIMS AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION.
TO ADDRESS TIMELINESS CONCERNS.
LEGAL DIVISION IS CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATING IN A LEAN SIX
SIGMA BUSINESS PROCESS REVIEW.
OFFERED IN CONNECTION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. TO
STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE THE
HANDLING OF ADVERSE PERSONNEL
ACTIONS.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL WOULD BE TO
APPLY THESE EFFICIENCIES TO ALL
PERSONNEL MATTERS.
WELL I UNDERSTAND OF THE
COMMITTEES ARE INTERESTED IN THE
ABILITY OF SOME BOARDS TO HIRE
THEIR OWN IN HOUSE ATTORNEY.
IT IS THE DEPARTMENT'S POSITION
THAT ALL OF ITS CLIENTS SPORTS
EMBRYOS ARE BEST SERVED.
USING THE TRADITIONAL MODEL OF
CENTRALIZED CENTRALIZED LEGAL
SERVICES.
ATTORNEYS EMPLOYED BY THE
DEPARTMENT'S LEGAL AFFAIRS
DIVISION ARE SIR ARE SIGNED TO
SERVE HAS IN HOUSE LEGAL COUNSEL
TO DEPARTMENTS BOARDS AND
BUREAUS. HAVE AN ATTORNEY CLIENT
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEIR BORDER.
BUT THEY ALSO WORK IN A
COLLABORATIVE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THEY CAN DRAWN LEGAL KNOWLEDGE
AND PRIOR EXPERIENCE OF OTHER
ATTORNEYS WITHIN DEPARTMENT.
ALLOWING FOR CONTINUITY
CONTINUITY WHEN THERE'S A
TURNOVER IN BASE KNOWLEDGE OF
ONGOING ISSUES LIKE THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE NORTH
CAROLINA. NORTH CAROLINA CASE.
ADDITIONALLY.
UNLIKE THE WORK OF A LOAN
PROGRAM ATTORNEY. THE WORK OF
LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION ATTORNEYS
IS SUPERVISED BY ASSISTANT CHIEF
COUNSELS AND OTHER SENIOR
ATTORNEYS. ENSURING ACCURACY
CONSISTENCY AND THE QUALITY OF
THE LEAGUE OF AND THE QUALITY OF
THE LEGAL ADVICE.
AND BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
MULTIPLE ATTORNEYS ON STAFF.
THE LEGAL AFFAIRS DIVISION CAN
PROBABLY PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
ATTORNEY RESOURCES WHEN NEEDED.
SUCH AS A SISTER ASSIGN MULTIPLE
ATTORNEYS TO ONE CLIENT.
PROVIDING MEETING COVERAGE IN
THE EVENT OF AN ENEMY UNEXPECTED
ATTORNEY ABSENCE.
FINALLY LIKE TO DISCUSS THE
THIRD ISSUE IN THE BACKGROUND
PAPER RELATED TO THE REGULATORY
REVIEW PROCESS. OF THE
DEPARTMENT.
AS A NEW DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT. THE FLOW AND QUALITY
OF REGULATIONS IS SOMETHING I
QUICKLY IDENTIFIED. AS A SUBJECT
OF IMPORTANT BOTH TO THE
PROGRAMS HAD TO THE HEAD TO
CONSUMERS AT LARGE.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO CONSULT WITH THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW. TO
IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES IN OUR
REVIEW PROCESS.
WE CURRENTLY PARTNER WITH THEM
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S
INTERNAL TRAININGS FOR PROGRAM
STAFF.
AND ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK AN IMPORTANT
INFORMATION WE RECEIVE.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT DOES
NOT HAVE PERFORMANCE MEASURES
FORTS REVIEW PROCESS BUT THIS IS
ONE OF OUR STRATEGIC PLAN GOALS.
AS PART OF PROCESS TO ESTABLISH
REASONABLE AND EFFECTIVE
PERFORMANCE MEASURES.
THE DEPARTMENT. IS SPEARHEADING
A NEW REGULATION TRACKING
SYSTEM.
THAT WILL INTEGRATE EACH OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S KEY REVIEW AREA IS
INTO ONE SYSTEM.
THIS WILL ENABLE THE DEPARTMENT
AND PROGRAMS TO QUICKLY
DETERMINE THE STATUS OF A
REGULATION. AND TO DEVELOP BENCH
MARKS FOR REVIEW DURING EACH
STAGE OF THE REVIEW PROCESS.
NOT ONLY WILL IT HOLD UP THE
DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR IT
FOR REVIEW TIME LINES.
BUT WILL PROVIDE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY TO THE BOARDS AND
GROWS AWAITING FEEDBACK FROM THE
APARTMENT DURING THIS PROCESS.
THE DEPARTMENT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
REPORT BACK ON THIS ITEM. NEXT.
ON THIS ITEM NEXT YEAR DURING
THE SUNSET PROCESS.
WELL I BELIEVE THAT. REASONABLE
TIMELINES AND PERFORMANCE
MEASURES SHOULD BE ESTABLISHED.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED WITH THE
QUALITY OF REGULATIONS.
THE DEPARTMENT'S PROGRAMS
HISTORICALLY HAVE AT A HIGH
PROPORTION OF REGULATION PACKAGE
PACKAGES REJECTED BY THE OFFICE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE LAW.
SO WHILE THE REVIEW TIME LINE
LEVELS OF REVIEW ARE NECESSARY
TO MEET THE STANDARD OF LAW.
I ALSO AGREE THAT ONGOING
TRAINING IS CRITICAL TO ANY
SUCCESSFUL BUSINESS PROCESS.
IN ADDITION TO TRAINING THAT. IN
ADDITION TO THE TRAIN AT
DEPARTMENT OF RIDES TO THE
PROGRAM STAFF ON THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. THE DEPARTMENT ALSO
ENCOURAGES AND PROMOTES THOSE
STAFF INVOLVED IN THE REVIEW IN
THE REVIEW PROCESS. TO ATTEND
THE OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
FLAWS THREE DAY TRAINING.
THIS IS SOMETHING WE WILL
CONTINUE TO D AS WE REFINE AND
IMPROVE OUR OWN STANDARDS AND
PROCESS HE'S.
IN CLOSING I BRIEFLY SHARE A FEW
OF THE WORDS I STATED DURING MY
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE HEARING
FOR CONFIRMATION A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO.
I THINK ALL OF US WOULD AGREE.
THAT CALIFORNIA IS THE GREATEST
STATE IN THE NATION IN PART
BECAUSE OF HOW BOLD YOU FOR
THINKING WE CRAFT OUR PUBLIC
POLICIES.
I LOOK FORWARD TO PORT
BARGAINING WITH ALL OF YOU AS WE
SHAPE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS. FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
FROM.
THANK YOU MISTER DIRECTOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THAT
SENATOR DODD. SENATOR PAY AND I
HAD TO LEAVE THE WANTED ME TO
ASK QUESTION THAT I'VE GOT
ANOTHER ONE MYSELF BUT THAT.
HE WAS FOCUSING ON.
STAFFING HE'D NOTICED THAT. IT
SEEMS LIKE WHEN WE COME HERE
THAT'S A COMMENT.
CONCERN WITH THE THE THE THE
BUREAU'S ON. THE STAFFING BUT
MAYBE NOT. AS HE'S ASKED
QUESTIONS.
WAS IS THEIR BUDGET REQUESTS
YET AND THE ANSWER IS NO ARE
YOU.
WORKING ON YOUR SOME SORT OF
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT.
THE STAFFING DOES GET.
ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS. SO.
YES AND NO YES IN THE SENSE THAT
WE'RE ALWAYS OPEN MINDED IN
TERMS OF HOW TO ADDRESS.
STAFFING NEEDS FOR ALL OUR
PROGRAMS. NO IN THE SENSE THAT.
NOT EVERY STAFF INITIALLY
REQUIRES A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL. SO I'M VERY OPEN
MINDED IN TERMS OF HOW TO
DIRECTLY AND EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
STOPPING CONCERNS I'M I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT WORKS VERY CLOSELY.
WITH OUR PROGRAMS WHEN IN FACT A
STAFFING ISSUE. DOES COME TO OUR
ATTENTION.
AND YES THANK YOU AND.
YOU ON ON THE ISSUE WITH THE.
.
THE.
THE B. ALREADY BECOMING AN
APARTMENT YOU KNOW THAT WAS A
BILL THAT I RAN LAST YEAR AND.
I KNOW THAT YOU'RE.
YOU KNOW YOU. YOU CAME IN AFTER
THE.
YOU KNOW ALL THIS STUFF WAS
HAPPY BUT I GUESS I'VE GOT IT.
RESPONDED. THERE'S A FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR DELTA
BETWEEN. WHAT YOU WERE CHARGING?
THE BUREAU AND NOW.
.
EVEN WITH THEM GONE THERE'S
THERE'S YOU'RE STILL GOT THAT
FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
BURIED SOMEWHERE. YET AND I ARE
ONE I DON'T MEAN TO SAY BERRY
BUT IS EVE GOT IT IN THE BUDGET.
THE BOARD IN.
IT I GUESS THAT'S CONCERNING TO
ME.
YOU'RE FOR FOR OBVIOUS REASONS
I WONDER IF YOU COULD JUST
COMMENT ON YOUR THOUGHT PROCESS
AND. IN MOVING DOWN THE ROAD IN
THIS REGARD.
ANY. PROGRAM THAT LEAVES THE
DEPARTMENT IS IT'S CONCERNING.
TO ME TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
ARE YOU LEAVING.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE MINIMAL
IMPACT ON EXISTING PROGRAMS ARM
IN THE SHORT TERM AND THE DELTA
THAT YOU MENTIONED. WHILE.
HAS YET TO BE YOU KNOW
COMPLETELY DECIDED HOW WE'RE
GOING TO ADDRESS.
I STATED. MY SORT OF MY POINT.
THE APPROXIMATE FIVE MILLION.
YOU KNOW HIT TO THE DEPARTMENT.
IS A ARGUABLY LARGE SIGNIFICANT
A FACTOR FOR ALL PROGRAMS AND
SO.
AGAIN.
TRYING TO DETERMINE SPECIFICALLY
HOW TO ADDRESS THAT.
NOT ONLY IN THE NEAR TERM BUT
MAY BE OVER.
YOU KNOW THE MID TERM.
ULTIMATELY I'M INTERESTED IN
TRYING TO ENSURE THAT THE
REMAINING PROGRAMS ARE.
OR NOT ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE DEPARTURE OF OF
THE ARMY.
BUSH.
THIS COULD BE WHAT WHAT WHAT
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I BEAT IT'S
IT'S IT'S SOME MORE IT IS
TROUBLING TO ME BECAUSE SOME
MORE IT SEEMS THAT THERE SEE
YELL A STRUCTURAL. ISSUE WITH
REGARD TO STAFFING.
YEAH WITHIN THE DCA.
I THINK THIS IS EVIDENCE. OF
THAT AND SO I GUESS.
IT IT IS PRETTY HARD IT.
HE OUT.
THEY HAVE YOU REACT YET TODAY
BUT THIS IS THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO COME
UP.
YOU KNOW EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT
WE HAVE A REVIEW ON IT OUT YOU
KNOW IN THIS AGENCY SO MY
SUGGESTION WOULD BE.
TO ME THIS IS TOO LARGE OF A
DELTA JUST TO GO UNNOTICED AND
NOT HAVE US. RESPOND TO.
TO ME IT'S A BIG DEAL AND I
DON'T SEE HOW OTHER DEPARTMENTS
ARE GOING TO BE. GIVEN THIS.
PROGRAM AT.
YEAH EXTRA SHARE GIVE IT TO THEM
AND WHEN THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS ARE SUCH THAT.
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
PAYING FOR ANYBODY ELSE'S.
SERVICES.
I I KNOW YOUR IN THE ALLEY.
SUGGESTED THAT.
.
THE YOU THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY THE LA O. SUGGESTED
TO YOU REVISIT PRO RATA CHARGES.
AND SO I I I. I I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO TELL YOU EXCEPT FOR THIS
IS GOOD EVERY TIME THIS COMES UP
I'VE GOT TO BE ASKING THESE
QUESTIONS.
NOT. NOT LOST ON SOME LOST ON ME
ARE WHAT TO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
TO TO TO ME. TODAY. SPECIFIC TO
AGAIN YOUR LEGISLATION.
IN MY REVIEW OF IT.
I THINK THE KIND OF A LONG TERM.
POTENTIAL OF THE IMPACT.
ON THE DEPARTMENT AND ITS
PROGRAMS.
COULD HAVE BEEN FURTHER I GUESS
CONSIDERED VETTED EXCEPT TRUCK.
WE ARE NOW OBVIOUSLY.
IN CHARGE OF IMPLEMENTING YOUR
LEGISLATION AND HOW OBVIOUSLY
ADAM IMPACTS. THE DEPARTMENT AND
OTHER PROGRAMS. COMPLETELY
COMPLETELY RECOGNIZE THAT.
THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM FOR
IMPROVEMENT SPECIFIC TO.
PRO RATA.
L. A. O.'S RECOMMENDATION.
I'M.
WHAT ARGUMENT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED?
BUT I THINK IT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED IN TOTALITY OF HOW HE
PER USAGE APPROACH.
COULD HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
NEGATIVE IMPACT IMPACT ON THE
SMALLER PROGRAMS AT DCA.
.
PART OF MY REFERENCE TO PREVIOUS
WORK THAT I HAVE DONEBEFORE. I
KNOW IT MAY SOUND KIND OF.
YOU KNOW ROMANTIC AN INJURY TO
ONE IS AN INJURY AT ALL HAS A
SMALLER PROGRAM.
CONSIDERATION SHOULD ALSO BE.
YOU DON'T.
CLEAN THOUGHTFULLY CONSIDERED
WHEN.
WE ARE DISCUSSING THE POTENTIAL
TO GOING TO A PER USE MODEL.
THEIR ARMS.
I'M NOT BE IN. THERE TOO OUR
ARGUMENT IS MR FEEL ABOUT IT I
DIDN'T ND I WOULD AGREE WITH
YOU ON THIS ON THE ON THE
SMALLER PROGRAMS.
BUT.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT ON THE
SMALLER PROGRAMS.
IF THEY'RE NOT PAYING THEIR FAIR
SHARE.
OR THEIR FAIR SHARE WOULD BE
SUCH A GREAT.
NEGATIVE IMPACT.
YOU KNOW ON ON THEIR SPECIFIC
PROGRAM PERHAPS WE SHOULD LOOK
AT THAT.
BUT UNDER A DIFFERENT LIGHT THEM
WERE LOOKING OUT. AT AT AT THESE
FEES YELLOW ARE A MORE IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT YOUR MACRO YELL
LEVEL.
AND CERTAINLY THE OF THE THE
DEPARTMENT REAL STUDENTS STAY
GOING.
THE STATE GOING BACK TO THE
BARBER REAL ESTATE WAS A DIRECT
FUNCTION OF YOUR PREDECESSORS
NOT YOU. THAT HAD JUST IGNORED
THIS PROCESS OVER TIME AND I
WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
VERY. IMPORTANT TO THIS
COMMITTEE THAT WE GET A HANDLE
ON.
COMPLETELY AGREE AND IN NO WAY
SHAPE OR FORM.
DIRECTED I EAT BY MY RESPONSES
TO SUGGEST ANY KIND OF.
ARGUMENT.
QUITE QUITE CHERRY.
ELEVEN MONTHS THAT I HAVE BEEN
AT THE DEPARTMENT.
PRO RATA IS ABSOLUTELY AN ISSUE
THAT HAS COME TO MY CONTENTION
COME TO MY ATTENTION OFTEN END
EARLY AND OFTEN AND AS I
MENTIONED IN MY COMMENTS. TRYING
TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS COMPLETE
TRANSPARENCIES A SPECIFIC TO PRO
RATA TO OUR PROGRAMS.
I'LL BE THE FIRST AND I THINK
OTHERS HAVE HEARD ME SAY THAT I
IN NO WAY SHAPE OR FORM HAVE A
MONOPOLY ON GOOD IDEAS.
AND I AND I WELCOME. DIRECT
COLLABORATION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE WITH YOU OTHERS TO.
ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
I THINK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OF.
WELL YOU KNOW.
.
MR DIRECTOR IN AND THANK YOU
SENATOR DOT FOR THOSE THOSE
QUESTIONS AND THE CONCERN
BECAUSE IT IS IT IS AN ISSUE
THAT.
.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE. THE
CHARGING AND THE FACT THAT.
IT'S GEORGE BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF AUTHORIZED BOARD PERSONNEL
RATHER THAN ON THE ACTUAL COST
OF THOSE BOARDS AND AND I I
FRANKLYI I DISAGREE WITH THE
ARGUMENT I THINK IT'S THE FACT
THAT.
THAT THERE IS A.
YOU KNOW CREATED A COMPUTER
SYSTEM OR A CHARGE SYSTEM THAT
WOULD ALLOCATE THOSE. THOSE
CHARGES TO THOSE PARTICULAR
BOARD SHAPIRO'S BASED ON THEIR
USAGE. IS A MUCH MORE EFFICIENT
WAY OF DOING IT IT REQUIRES
CERTAIN CERTAINLY.
HE THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO TO
CONSERVE FOR THE ABILITY TO FOR
THEM TO BECOME MORE EFFICIENT IN
THE PROCESS AND THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE TODAY.
FOR ANYONE TO NOT USE WHATEVER
SERVICES THEY WANTED IS CALLED
THE CA FOR WHATEVER BECAUSE
THERE'S GOING TO BE SOMEBODY
THERE TO HELP. THEM AND I THINK
THAT'S NOT THE WAY CERTAINLY IT
SHOULD BE A AND I FIND THAT IT'S
JUST THE FACT THAT YOU MAY NOT
HAVE A COMPUTER SYSTEM BUT NOW
YOU'RE WORKING ON A NEW IT
SYSTEM FOR. THE TRACK
REGULATIONS MAYBE WE SHOULD HAVE
A NEW IT SYSTEM TO WORK ON THE
PROKHOROVKA CHARGES AND AND
ALLOCATE THEM APPROPRIATELY TO
THESE.
THESE DIFFERENT BOARDS AND AND
BUREAUS IT'S THAT IT LACKS
EFFICIENCY AND AND AS I SAID
AND.
AND THE CONSISTENCY OF IT WHICH
IS. I THINK.
IMPORTANT END OF IT IN THE IDEA
OF OF.
OF REQUIRING THEM AND AND I
THINK SENATOR DODD'S CONCERNS
RELATED TO.
THE FEAR OF REAL ESTATE AND NOW
THE DEPARTMENT IS IS IS CRITICAL
TO THE HIGH COST AND THE AND
THAT LEADS ME INTO THE OTHER
WITH PART WHICH IS RELATED TO
THE LEGAL COUNSEL. YOU KNOW THIS
SOME OF THESE WERE THE BOARDS
HAVE REQUIRED AND ASK FOR.
OUTSIDE COUNSEL THE MEDICAL
BOARD HAS IT UTILIZES IT VERY
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
AND THEY'RE STILL PAYING THEIR
PARODIC CHARGES FOR FOR THAT USE
IN IN THEIR THEIR COSTS BUT THEY
NEEDED THOSE THAN THE GENERAL
BOARD I KNOW HAD THAT REQUEST.
IN WE'VE AUTHORIZED THAT ARE
ALLOWED THAT TO TO OCCUR IN DATE
IT'D BEEN DENIED BY DCA.
WE WANT TO SEE THE BOARDS IN
BUREAUS. ACTED AND WORK
RESPONSIBLY EFFICIENTLY. CAN
ALLOW THEM THE AUTONOMY IN SOME
CASES TO DO THAT AS THEY DESIRE.
IN THIS CASE IT WAS DENIED AND
CONTINUE TO BE DENIED I TALK
WITH THE. OTHER SIX SECRETARY
PROTEST ON THE ISSUE AND SHE
SAID WE'RE JUST GOING TO
DISAGREE DECEPTIVE.
IT IS A GREAT WELL I MEAN
THAT'S.
THAT SEEMS TO BE A.
.
ROACH THAT IS A. IS IS NOT THE
MOST CONSTRUCTIVE I THINK AND. I
THINK IF WE WANT TO SEE SOME
GOOD CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
APPROPRIATE END AND QUICK
RESPONSIVENESS. I MEAN THE
DELAYS NOW WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
IN TERMS OF INVESTIGATIONS AS
YOU KNOW WHAT THREE YEARS. TWO
YEARS THREE YEARS FOUR YEARS IN
SOME CASES.
I MEAN THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THAT
THE CONSUMER BUT THE A I BELIEVE
IT'S JUST AS MUCH BUSINESS AS
USUAL WITH THE DCA. AND WE'LL
JUST EXPECTED AND THAT'S JUST
THE WAY IT IS WELL THAT'S JUST
IN LIKE A BUREAUCRATIC ANSWER.
AND NOT AN EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT
GOOD GOVERNMENT ANSWER I THINK
WE HAVE THE SENSE THAT REVIEWS
EVERY FOUR YEARS AND END WITH
THE DC AID. IN THIS IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
GOVERNMENT DOES. IS WE REQUIRE
THAT ALL OF THE BOARD AND FEARS
THE FORTY ONE OR HOWEVER MANY OR
UNDER YOU AS CLOSE TO THAT.
THEY HAVE TO RESPOND AND BE
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC AND TO
JUSTIFY THEIR CONTINUED
EXISTENCE. AND IF WE CAN'T DO
THAT AND REQUIRE THE SPECIALLY
WHEN YOU HAVE AS SENATOR DOES
MENTION WITHIN THE. THE THE DCA
THE YOU KNOW THE L. A. O.
SUGGESTS THE LEGISLATURE COMPEL
BC TO REVISIT PRO RATA CHARGES.
ASKING COMPEL.
AND WE ARE WE IT JUST AS WE ASK
FOR THE ATTORNEYS IN THOSE OTHER
AREAS AND ENOUGH TO KNOW. I
DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S A GOOD
ACCEPTABLE RESPONSE THAT WE HAVE
TO.
.
OR DO WE HAVE TO ACCEPT IN A WAY
THAT THAT I THINK PUTS UNDUE
BURDEN ON SOME OF THOSE BOARDS
WITHIN DCA THAT WE ALL EXPECT.
AND REQUIRE THEM TO DO AND BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SO I HOPE YOU
WILL LOOK AT THAT. THAT ISSUE A
LITTLE MORE CLEARLY AND TO ME.
WHAT I LOOK AT THE FRANKLIN I
THIS IS AT THE THE PRO RATA
CHARGES HAVE BECOME A CASH COW
FOR DCA?
AND IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE THAT
WAY UNTIL SOMETHING IS DONE
ABOUT IT EITHER THE LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATURE HAS TO DO SOMETHING.
OR DCA TAKES IT UPON THEMSELVES
TO TO TO LOOK AT IT AND AND FIND
A BETTER WAY. TO ALLOCATE THOSE
FUNDS. LEADS THE PART OF THAT IN
THE OTHER.
SOME QUESTIONS I DID HAVE ONE IS
THE DEPARTMENT APPEARS.
TO REQUIRE A NUMBER OF MANDATORY
CONSULTATIONS OR REVIEW BY.
BY DEPARTMENT STAFF IS THERE
ANY.
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING AS TO. UNDER
WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES THESE
CONSULTATIONS OR. ARE A OUR
RECORD REVIEWS ARE NECESSARY
JOURNEY CRITERIA ESTABLISHED FOR
STANDARDS ARE THE WRITTEN
POLICIES OR PROCEDURES WHEN WHEN
THESE CONSULTATIONS ARE REVIEWS
ARE. ARE ARE NECESSARY.
AS IT IS TO.
HAPPEN THAT.
FOR CHANGE.
NOT CLEAR TO ME WHICH
CONSULTATION OR VIEWS REFERRING
TO.
GENTLY SPEAKING WE TRY TO
ENSURE THAT. YOU KNOW IF
PROGRAMS NEED ASSISTANCE WE TRY
TO MAKE IT AS PRODUCTIVE AS
POSSIBLE AND MAYBE THERE ARE
SOME AN UP FRONT.
AREA THAT.
WOULD BE NEEDED IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS A YOU KNOW
PRODUCTIVE HITTER OF OUR PROCESS
BUT.
I'M NOT AGAIN NOT LOSE THE
GENDERS IN THE AGENDAS IN THE
MEETINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED AND
OTHER THINGS THAT. HAVE TO GO
THROUGH DC EIGHT.
IN IN IN WE WE DID THAT LETTER
THAT THAT WE HAD SENT.
.
ON JANUARY SEVENTEENTH THAT WAS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS THAT IT
HASN'T HAVEN'T RECEIVED A
RESPONSE YET. TO THAT.
CORRECT AND.
HER INITIAL DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
HAD HAD WITH.
.
STAFF.
WE KNOW THAT.
WITH WHAT'S PROBABLY FIRST.
PROTECTED BY THE FIRST STEP IN
ORDER TO ENSURE A PRODUCTIVE IN
OUR PROCESS. THAT WE SIT DOWN
AND HAVE A HAVE A CONVERSATION
ABOUT KIND OF THE TOTALITY. OF
OF YOU KNOW EITHER IN THAT
SPECIFIC. MEMO OR PREVIOUS.
MMHM REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION.
FROM YOUR STAFF.
AND AGAIN. I WELCOME THAT.
.
IF YOUR PREFERENCE IS A. YOU
KNOW BACK AND FORTH IN WRITTEN
FORM.
PLEASE PLEASE LET US KNOW THAT
AS WELL. THE GOAL ULTIMATELY IS
TO ENSURE THAT. THERE IS A.
PRODUCTIVE COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS.
TOWARDS.
I'M GETTING TO WHAT I THINK ARE
IN FACT SHARED COMMON COMMON
GOALS AND SHARED A COMMON AREAS
OF INTEREST.
SENATOR YOU'RE MENTIONED
EARLIER ABOUT.
IMPROVEMENTS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
EXCEPT TRY AND.
.
YEAH MAYBE BECAUSE OF. MY ELEVEN
MONTHS BEING AT THE DEPARTMENT
I'M NOT ABLE TO.
I GUESS IDEALLY AS QUICKLY.
ACHIEVE.
IMPROVEMENTS AND GREATER
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AS YOU AS YOU AS AS YOU
MENTIONED BUT I CAN SAY IN THE
LAST MONTH SAID THAT I HAVE BEEN
YOU BENT HAVE BEEN THERE. THERE
HAVE BEEN SPECIFIC IMPROVEMENTS
RELATED TO TIME FOR A TIME
FRAMES OF FOUR FOUR FOR
REGULATIONS.
THERE HAS BEEN IMPROVEMENTS
SPECIFIC TO ADDRESS SEEN.
OBSESSED STAFFING ISSUES. FOR
FOREIGN FORCE MEANT AND SO.
.
WHILE.
WE HAVE YET TO BE. IDEAL IN
PERFECT PERFECT ON MANY FRONTS
I'M I'M CONFIDENT THAT.
WE PUT OUR I PUT MY BEST FOOT
PUT FORWARD TRY. TOWARD TRYING
TO ACHIEVE WHAT IS IDEAL THAT IS
DEMANDED FROM NOT ONLY YOURSELF
BUT TECH CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
IN WHICH DIRECTION THE OTHER
QUESTION JUST THE IN TERMS OF
WHAT I MENTION INTER. RELATED TO
CAN CONSULTATIONS AND REVIEWS
THE DCA HAVE CONSISTENT.
REFERRED DISAPPROVING STAFF
REQUESTS WHICH IS YOU KNOW ANY
ANY OF THE BCP'S THAT ARE. OUT
THERE IS SEARCH CERTAIN.
CRITERIA THAT YOU LOOK AT BEFORE
THEY ARE APPROVED OR DISAPPROVED
SPECIFIC TO THE CDD CBS.
SO AS I UNDERSTAND AND I'M
LEARNING.
YOU KNOW.
THE BCT PROCESS IS. ARGUABLY A.
YEAH I JUST CLOSED.
CONFIDENTIAL PROCESS IN TERMS OF
DID YOU KNOW DETERMINING THE
OUTCOME.
WHAT I AM AWARE IS THAT I
BELIEVE IT WAS TWENTY TWELVE
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
FIRST ISSUE CRITERIA SPECIFIC
TO?
YOU KNOW. BCP'S HAD I THINK
ANNUALLY THEY HAVE REITERATED
CRITERIA SPECIFIC TO VOTE FOR
SPECIFIC TO BCP'S THAT ARE
SUBMITTED BY EACH EACH EACH
DEPARTMENT. DO. YOU USE THOSE
CRITERIA OR DO HAVE THEIR OWN
CRITERIA BASED ON WHAT YOUR
NEEDS ARE WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
DEFINITELY FACTORED IN HAPPY TO
GET THAT. TO YOU A MAN AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THIS NOTION
OF.
I GUESS A HARD AND FAST CRITERIA
SPECIFIC TOO BCP'S AT THAT
APARTMENT UTILIZES.
DOESN'T NECESSARILY EXIST.
AS I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY.
NOT ALL CONCERNS PROBLEMS
ISSUES. REQUIRE REQUIRE THE CP
AND.
THAT'S THAT THAT THAT IS A
FACTOR THAT GOES INTO THE
DECISION IF IF ONE IF A BOARD
COMES TO YOU WITH THE BCP AND.
AND IT'S.
THEY THEY RAISE ISSUES THAT ARE
OF CONCERN AND SHOWING WHAT THEY
BELIEVE IS A NEED FOR THAT BCP
OF THE PERSONNEL CHANGES. HOW DO
YOU IF YOU DENY THAT OR PITCH
TONIGHT HOW DO YOU WORK WITH THE
BOARD? TOO ON WORKLOAD ISSUES
BACKLOGS AND INSTALLATION
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES. IF
THERE IS A DENIAL OF THOSE AND
IF THEY REALIZE THAT THERE'S A
PROBLEM.
I THINK.
IT INVOLVES.
GETTING TO THE BOTTOM OF HOW.
THE YOU KNOW THE PROGRAM IS
CURRENTLY.
.
TRYING TO ACHIEVE ITS ITS
DESIRED OUTCOMES ARM IF THERE
ARE SPECIFIC.
STAFFING LEVELS THAT NEED TO BE
TO BE ADDRESSED THEIR NUMBER
EXAMPLES IN MY ELEVEN MONTHS AT
DCA WHERE. WE'VE ASSISTED WHO
WITH FAT VIA ARMED DIVISION
INVESTIGATION STAFF BEING HOUSED
FOR LACK OF BETTER TERMS IN A
SPECIFIC PROGRAM TO IMPROVE.
THE ENFORCEMENT TIMELINES.
SO IT'S.
IT'S A CASE BY CASE BASIS AS YOU
COULD IMAGINE.
YOU KNOW. THE NEEDS OF ONE
PROGRAM COULDN'T BACK AND COULD
BE IN FACT DIFFERENT FROM
ANOTHER AND.
THE DEPARTMENT ALWAYS STRIVED
TO BE NUMBER ON THAT REGARD
TRYING TO ADDRESS OUR PROGRAM
NEEDS.
OKAY THEM. YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T IS
THEN THE SYSTEM. OF A FINAL MY
FINAL QUESTION. YOU CAN'T REALLY
COMMENT AND I DON'T EXPECT YOU
TO ON ANY PENDING INVESTIGATIONS
BUT WHAT CAN YOU.
TELL US.
HOW THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION PRIORITIZES CASES
THAT MAY HAVE? CRIMINAL END IN
ADMINISTRATIVE VIOLATIONS TO AND
WHAT I'M VERY CONCERNED WITH
RIGHT NOW IS THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER FRAUDULENT SCHOOLS.
CLAIMING THEY ARE PROVIDING
MASSAGE THERAPY OR COSMETOLOGY
YOUR MANA CURING TRAINING. THAT
ARE ACTUALLY JUST SELLING PROOF
OF PROGRAM COMPLETION DOCUMENTS
OR FALSIFYING DOCUMENTS FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEVER RECEIVED THAT
TRAINING IS THE. DEPARTMENT
FOCUSED ON THESE ACTORS AND ON
IN A TIMELY BASIS BECAUSE THOSE
FRAUDULENT SCHOOLS THAT THAT
LEAVES IT TO THEN THE. BUREAUS
IN THE DEPARTMENTS IN THE BOOK I
MEAN THE BOARDS TO. TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY THEM THEMSELVES RATHER
THAN HAVING INVESTIGATIONS
ONGOING. SURE OF ANY BACKUP OF
PER SE THAT.
HER DIVISION INVESTIGATION.
PER TWENTY TENDS. CONSUMER
PROTECTION ENFORCEMENT
INITIATIVE KINDA CATEGORIZES.
HOW THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE OF
HOW DIVISION HAVE A DIVISION
BECAUSE ABOUT ADDRESS SEEN?
POTENTIAL ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
VIA THE CP I ACCEPTED GUIDELINES
AGAIN THAT.
ENSURES THAT IF IN FACT A
PARTICULAR CASE REQUIRES.
IMMEDIATE THAT THAT THAT THAT
CASE GOES IMMEDIATELY TO THE
DIVISION OF EDUCATION VERSUS.
STAYING WITHIN.
ITS SPECIFIC PROGRAM SO KIND OF
ENFORCEMENT ACTION FROM
BP.
IN SO.
TRYING TO.
AT ME LEARNING THIS ISSUE TRYING
TO IDENTIFY WAYS THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY I GUESS.
GET AT THE ISSUE YOU KNOW
FURTHER UPSTREAM AS OPPOSED TO A
DOWNSTREAM.
TO HEAL HARM. ANY DEFINED HARM
IF SOMEONE TELLS YOU THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM OR THEY HAVE.
A. FRAUDULENT FALSIFIED DOCUMENT
THAT'S THE HARM YOU'RE LOOKING
FOR. YEAH. TO YOUR POINT HARM IS
GUESS IS IN THE EYE OF THE
BEHOLDER.
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH A
SPECIFIC DEFINITION OF HARM
THAT.
HE MAY HAVE.
AGAIN MY POINT IN MENTIONING
THAT IS THAT I'M A STUDENT WOULD
HAVE TO. GUESS AFFIRMATIVE
AFFIRMATIVELY APPROACH JOB YOU
KNOW PERHAPS BE BEAT BP. BEFORE
BE PP YOU CAN ACT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE TO.
THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS THAT
DOES CONCLUDE THAT DEPARTMENT
BUT.
I KNOW YOU'LL STILL BE AROUND
DIRECTOR FOR YOUR GOOD WORK WITH
RELATED TO THIS BOARD TO THANK
YOU FOR THAT.
MOVING TO THE FIELD. IT WE WILL
HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT WHEN WE
CONCLUDE WITH THE.
ALL OF THE.
HAS ADDRESSED BY THE DEPARTMENT
TO. DO NOW LIKE TO INVITE THE.
THOSE FROM THE BOARD PLEASE COME
FORWARD.
WORD OF OCCASIONAL NURSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS.
SO.
ONE.
YEAH.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO OPEN UP
THE STOCK.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING? RIGHT NOW.
SECOND OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
OKAY.
AND I THINK MISTER DIRECTOR
YOU'RE GOING TO OPEN THE
COMMENTS OF THANK YOU FOR THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY GOOD WORKING AND
DOING ON RELATED TO THE SPORT.
MY PLEASURE.
LONG TIME NO SEE SENATORS AND
SEMI MEMBERS. BEFORE I BEGIN I'D
LIKE TO GIVE THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
JOINED ME HERE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES.
ALL.
BOB BENJAMIN FRANKLY
ADMINISTRATIVE ENFORCEMENT
MONITOR.
FEELING HIM HERE TO THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
TAMMY AND ALSO THE RE ELECTED TO
A CURRENT BOARD PRESIDENT.
AND I GUESS I CAN SAY GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I'M BERNICE BESTED. AND I WAS
JUST RE ELECTED AS VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE BOARD.
THANK YOU ALL GIVEN THERE ARE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES.
REPRESENTED IN THIS PANEL.
I'LL PROVIDE A BETTER PICTURE OF
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HAS FOCUSED ITS SUPPORT
OF THE BOARD IN THE FORM OF
OVERSIGHT AND PARTNERSHIP.
BEGINNING JULY TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
DEPARTMENT ASSIGNED STAFF FROM
THE DIVISION INVESTIGATION. TO
INTO TWO MORE ROBUST ENFORCEMENT
PROCESSES AND START IMPLEMENTING
IMMEDIATE ACTION RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT BEN FRANK. THE BOARD'S
ENFORCEMENT MONITOR PUT FORWARD.
TO THE STAFF HAVE REMAINED AT
THE BOARD DEDICATING SEVERAL
HUNDREDS OF HOURS OF CENTRAL
SERVICE OFFICE HOURS OF CENTRAL
SERVICES STAFF TIME. TO HELP THE
BOARD CHIEF IMPROVE AND HELP THE
BOARD ACHIEVE IMPROVED PROCESS
HE'S.
THROUGH THE REMAINDER OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE WORK OF
MISTER FRANK. COORDINATING WITH
THE BOARD TO ENSURE THE
APPROPRIATE ACCESS TO DATA DATA
AND STAFF WAS PROVIDE.
THE GOVERNOR APPOINTED
MISCELLANY I'M A GUCCI WHO JOINS
ME HERE AS EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE THE NPT. AND SHE BEGAN HER
ROLE ON JANUARY TWENTY SECOND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
ONCE MISS YAMAGUCHI ASSUMED A
ROLE. THE DEPARTMENT PROVIDED A
ROBUST ON BOARDING PROCESS WHICH
INCLUDED. KEY STATE MANDATED
TRAINING. BRIEFINGS WITH
INDIVIDUAL DIVISIONS TO DISCUSS
SERVICES. INTERACTIONS TO KEY
STAFF THAT WOULD BE ASSIGNED TO
THE BOARD AND MORE.
THIS PROCESS IS BUILT IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER HANDS
APARTMENT LEADERS.
WORKING CLOSELY WITH BOARD
LEADERSHIP.
CAN WORK WITH POOR LEADERSHIP
BATTLING. THE DEPARTMENT FOCUSED
ITS INITIAL EFFORTS ON FIVE KEY
ADMINISTRATIVE AND ENFORCEMENT
AREAS OF THE BOARD.
FIRST.
I'M GOING VACANCY RATES STAFF WE
CAN SEE RATES HAVE ALREADY
DECLINED FROM NINETEEN PERCENT
IN LATE DECEMBER ONLY THIRTY
THIRTEEN PERCENT AS OF MARCH
FIRST.
BVB T. MANAGEMENT ARE MAKING
PROGRESS TOWARDS PHILLY
VACANCIES WITH A WELL QUALIFIED
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO MOVE THE BALL FORWARD.
TO PROVIDE A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE.
THE ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
POSITION AT BVB TI HAVE NOT BEEN
FILLED ON A PERMANENT BASIS FOR
NEARLY THREE YEARS.
MR YAMAGUCHI WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT'S OFFICE OF
THE MAYOR OF HUMAN RESOURCES.
CONDUCTED A BROAD SEARCH AND IS
APPOINTED MISS VICKI LYMAN
PREVIOUSLY. CHIEF FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
MISS LYMAN STARTED MARCH FIRST
BRINGS EXPERIENCE AND LICENSING
ENFORCEMENT. CHANGE MANAGEMENT
AND PROCESS IMPROVEMENT.
SECOND IN IMPORTANCE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH A FAMILY MEMBER
LOWS AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE.
THE DEPARTMENT'S FISCAL
OPERATIONS UNIT AND DIVISIONAL
INVESTIGATION MET WITH STAFF
FROM LEAVING A PETIT. TO DISCUSS
ITS CASHIERING AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES.
THESE MEETINGS HELP SET THE
FOUNDATION FOR ONGOING
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION.
THIRD.
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET AND
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES HAVE
PARTNERED WITH BOARD STAFF TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDED STATUTORY FEE
INCREASE ENSURE THEY HAVE IN FOR
INFORMATION AND TOOLS NEEDED. TO
PROCEED WITH WHAT IS WITH A
LEGISLATIVE CHANGE.
FOURTH.
DVB T. STAFF ARE WORKING CLOSELY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT ON INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND EFFICIENCY OF
LICENSING AT THE BOARD.
WE'RE WORKING TO IMPROVE THE
PUBLICATION OF LICENSEE
PERFORMANCE TIME LINES ON THE
BOARD TRIPS ON THE BOARD'S
WEBSITE.
WE ALL WORK WE ARE ALSO WORKING
TO APPLY THE METHOD PROVED
PROVEN SUCCESSFUL ELSEWHERE. IN
THE DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN A PILOT
PROGRAM WITH EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO ALLOW FOR THE
ELECTRONIC TRANSMISSION OF
SCHOOL TRANSCRIPT RECORDS TO
FURTHER IMPROVE VICENTINA.
PROCESSING TIME.
AND LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT DVB T. IN
ADDRESSING THE ENFORCEMENT
ISSUES THAT FACE.
STAFF FROM THE DEPARTMENT
INCLUDING TEAM MEMBERS FROM THE
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATION.
CONTINUE TO WORK ON SITE TO
ENSURE THAT THE BNP TEEN FORCED
INTO VISION MAKES PROGRESS IN
ADDRESSING THE MONITORS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
LOOKING AT TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
DEPARTMENT STAFF CAN BE THE NPT
LEADERSHIP WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON THE AREAS ALREADY
HIGHLIGHTED. CONSUMING AND SOON
BEGAN CONDUCTING A REVIEW OF THE
LICENSING DIVISION TO IDENTIFY
POSSIBLE AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT.
NOW LET'S TURN OVER OVER THE
MICROPHONE. OVER TO MR BEN
FRANK.
MISTER FRANK WAS SELECTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT IN EARLY SIXTEEN TO
SERVE AS THE ENFORCEMENT MONITOR
FOR THE BOARD TO IDENTIFY
ENFORCEMENT ISSUES AND SOLUTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES.
I DIDN'T. PREPARE ANY PREPARED
COMMENTS ARE I DID REVIEW THE UP
BACKGROUND PAPER PREPARED BY
STAFF. OB BOG COMMITTEE STAFF
AND I THINK IT DOES N
OUTSTANDING JOB OF SUCCINCTLY
SORT OF PRESENTING THE
CHRONOLOGY OF WHAT. OCCURRED
WITH THIS BOARD OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF PERCENT ONE
PARTICULAR.
THERE WERE.
A NUMBER OF VERY SERIOUS
PROBLEMS THAT SURFACED.
IN OFF FROM A LATE TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THROUGH MID TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. OF THOSE PROBLEMS
WERE IDENTIFIED. AND THE
INVOLVEMENT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
PARTICULARLY DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION. IN INTERVENING AT
THE BOARD. AT THAT TIME WAS
ABSOLUTELY INSTRUMENTAL IN
PREVENTING. AUG THOSE PROBLEMS
FROM WORSENING CONTAINING THOSE
PROBLEMS. AND UNTIL A MORE
SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT STRUCTURE
COULD BE PUT IN PLACE.
YOU KNOW THAT. ARE BASICALLY
JUST UNFORTUNATELY THERE WAS
ABOUT A YEAR TO A YEAR AND A
HALF OF TIME.
THAT WAS KIND OF LOST IN TERMS
OF. BEING ABLE TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVE. CONTINUE THE TURNAROUND
THAT HAD BEEN BEGUN PREVIOUSLY
AT THE BOARD AND AND FURTHER
IMPROVE THE BOARD AND INSTEAD.
THE EFFORTS WERE FOCUSED ON JUST
CONTAINING THE PROBLEMS AND
PREVENTING THEM FROM WORSENING.
AT THAT TIME AND THAT
INVOLVEMENT OF THE APARTMENT
CONSUMER AFFAIRS CONTINUED AT
REALLY AN UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL IN
MY EXPERIENCE. ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE END OF THE YEAR. AND
THEN REALLY STEPPED U TO A NEW
LEVEL AT THE BEGINNING OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWO MONTHS
AGO.
PENDING WITH THE APPOINTMENT OF
A.
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER. OF WHO
HAD BEEN THE ART DEPARTMENTS
CONTRACT OPERA A PROJECT MANAGER
FOR THE ENFORCEMENT PROJECT FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS.
AS THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE
OFFICER.
AND THEN.
THE APPOINTMENT THE BEGINNING
OF THE OCCUPYING MEANT STARTED
OF WORK WITH THE NEW EXECUTIVE
OFFICER ON JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND.
THE ACCELERATED HIRING. OF.
AS THE DIRECTOR MENTIONED ABOVE
I KNEW A LOT OF THE FIRST.
PERMANENT ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER IN THREE YEARS.
AND OTHER CHANGES IN THE
MANAGEMENT AND ORGANIZATION AND
REALLY.
ACCELERATE YOU KNOW ARE JUMPING
IN TO PICK UP AND.
BEGIN IMPLEMENTING ALL OF THE
NEEDED CHANGES OR IMPROVEMENTS
THAT WERE NEEDED.
WITH ORGANIZATION WITH STAFFING.
AND WHAT PROCESSES.
AUG CONCURRENTLY THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION. AGAIN WITH THE
SUPPORT OF DJS LEADERSHIP TEAM
AND IT'S FAIRLY BROAD BASED I
CAN TELL YOU UP. IN TERMS OF THE
BUDGET OFFICE LEDGE OFFERS US.
OFF. HUMAN RESOURCES OFFICE
OFFICE OF INFORMATION SERVICES
AND THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION IT'S IT'S KIND OF.
ACROSS THE BOARD AT DCA. TRYING
TO DO ALL OF THE THINGS THAT ARE
NEEDED TO BE NEED TO BE DONE AND
NEED TO BE DONE. AND CAN BE DONE
NOW.
TO ADDRESS THIS BOARD PROBLEMS.
AND.
THAT HAS CONTINUED.
AND IN A VERY INTENSIVE WAY FOR
THE PAST TWO MONTHS THE ARE
AGAIN THE.
THE ACTING EXECUTIVE OFFICER
KIND OF DROPPED IN MORE TO THE
CAPACITY OF A AN ACTING
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE OFFICER
PENDING THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
PERMANENT. ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER WHICH BEGAN I GUESS LAST
WEEK.
AND ARE THE. ARE THAT
INVOLVEMENT CONTINUES THE
DEPARTMENT THE DIVISION
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVEMENT
CONTINUES WITH THE VERY INTENSE
INVOLVEMENT OF SEVERAL STAFF
FROM THE DIVISION OF
INVESTIGATION. ON A ON A ON A
SUSTAINED BASIS.
IN ORDER FOR THE IMPORT WITH
pMANAGING AND TURNING AROUND
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. I'LL BE
MEETING AGAIN TOMORROW. OUGHT TO
HELP ON BOARD THE NEW ASSISTANT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER. AND SO THAT
PROCESS IS CONTINUING. AND I
HAVE. I THINK THERE IS GREAT
READ FROM FROM MY OBSERVATIONS
IN THE LAST TWO MONTHS I THINK
THERE'S GREAT CAUSE FOR
OPTIMISM.
AT THIS POINT THAT THAT YOU'LL
BE ABLE TO LOOK BACK ON THIS AND
SEE. THAT THE CHANGES THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED AS RESULT OF
ENACTMENT OF A B. TWELVE TWENTY
NINE. ARE ARE ARE ARE HAVING A
MEANINGFUL AND LASTING. UP
BENEFIT.
OFF THE HIGH IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THIS PROGRAM'S LONG
STANDING PROBLEMS.
THANK YOU MISTER FRANKEN AND
THAT WAS THE QUESTION I WAS
GOING TO SK YOU HAVE YOU OVER
ON THE RIGHT TRACK ARE WE GOING
TO.
ABLE TO TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT
THAT WE ALL FELT NECESSARY LAST
YEAR AND. IT SOUNDS LIKE WE ARE
I'VE I HOPE SO. GOODNIGHT FOR
THAT'S GOOD GOOD GOOD ENOUGH FOR
ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER
DIRECTOR DID YOU HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE THAT YOU WANTED TO. SOME
PROVISIONS STATEMENTS.
OKAY THEN WE WILL OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO ONE HAD ONE QUESTION JUST A.
.
IT I AND I GUESS THE KEY IS IS
THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO.
AS A LEGISLATURE TO MAKE
ESPECIALLY MICHELLE GOOD JUNIOR.
CONCERNS NOW IS. AS THE ACTING
DIRECTOR OF TRAINING THAT WE CAN
DO TO HELP YOU AND ASSIST YOU
I'VE IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE I
KNOW AND. AND A LOT OF THE BOARD
IS COME TOGETHER AND HELP TO
MAKE THAT CHANGE AND SO IF
THERE'S ANYTHING THAT YOU.
HAVE THAT YOU THINK WE CAN DO.
THANK YOU SIR.
I CAN I CAN GET TO THAT I I HAD
A FEW PHONE IS VERY GOOD THANK
YOU.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR MISTER
CHURCHILL TO YOUR LOVE. MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDE THE UPDATES.
ON THE STATUS OF BV IN PT I'M
LAYING OUT YOUR CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND.
I WANT TO SHARE SOME OF OUR
ADMINISTER PROGRESS REGARDING
HIRING A KEY POSITIONS BUILDING
A BETTER CULTURE. IMPROVING
COMMUNICATIONS AND STRENGTHENING
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WITH ME
OF COURSE IS OUR NEWLY REELECTED
PRESIDENT TENIENDO SO. WHO WILL
PROVIDE SOME INFORMATION ON HOW
WE'RE ADDRESSING THAT FORCED HIM
ON HIS RECOMMENDATION? AND ARE
ALSO NEWLY REELECTED VICE
PRESIDENT BRINGS BASTIDE
MARTINEZ WHOSE GREATEST SHARE
SOME MORE PROGRESS IN OUR
STRATEGIC PLANNING. BUT FIRST I
I HOPE YOU'LL INDULGE ME
BECAUSE.
I DO WISH TO EXPRESS MY GREAT
GRATITUDE TO MISTER BROPHY LOW
AND THE DEPARTMENT AND CLUED IN
THE. DIVISION OF INSTIGATION IS
FOR. UNSTINTING.
AND I USE THAT WORD ADVISEDLY
UNSTINTING SUPPORT. TO US IN
THIS TIME OF TRANSITION I'M
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL TO MISTER
BRIAN CLIFFORD OF DCA. MISS
STEPHANIE WHITLEY FROM DIVIDE.
WHO HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY FOR
MONTHS? TO LAY A FOUNDATION FOR
THE BOOK AT THE BOARD TO BUILD
FROM. ANTECHAMBER. VERY GOOD
COUNSEL VERY VERY SLOW.
ON POINT LET'S SAY INSIGHTS FREE
AS I AM ACCLIMATING AND I KNOW
THAT THEY WILL DO THE SAME FOR.
OUR NEW ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER.
AND ON THAT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT WHEN I WALKED INTO
THE OFFICE ON JANUARY TWENTY
SECOND. I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT I FOUND THERE.
WAS A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
LIKE WHAT THEY DO AND ARE PROUD
TO SERVE CALIFORNIA. AND WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY BUILD FROM THAT.
WHEN I BEGAN THERE WAS STILL
QUITE AN ALONG VACANCY REPORT.
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY. THERE
ARE MANY THERE ARE SO MANY MORE
FIELD DESKS AT THE BOARD NOW
PEOPLE LIKE COMING TO WORK.
WE HAVE HIGHER AS WE HAVE SAID
WE ORGANISE I NOR REORGANIZING
YET TO DO. BY DAY I BELIEVE THAT
WE ARE VERY FIRMLY ON THE RIGHT
PATH AND I THINK A LAWYER FOR.
ENDORSING THAT IDEA TO.
BUT I AM VERY VERY HAPPY TO
REPORT THAT WE'VE HIRED. I
SUPPOSE I THINK A SUPERBLY
QUALIFIED THIS IS AN EXECUTIVE
OFFICER. WITH LIMA START ON
MARCH FIRST THIS IS DAY THREE
SHE'S ALREADY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE.
SHE BRINGS AS MANY EXPERIENCES
IN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN LICENSING
PRETTY MUCH EVERY PHASE OF
LICENSING.
CHANGE MANAGEMENT AND SENIOR
MANAGEMENT.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MANY YEARS
WE HAVE A PERMANENT SENIOR
MANAGEMENT AT THE BOARD.
WE'RE BOTH EXTREMELY COMMITTED.
FIRMLY COMMITTED TO PROVIDING A
SUPPORTIVE SAFE AND PRODUCTIVE
WORK ENVIRONMENT.
BUT I THINK PERHAPS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CHANGE SO FAR IS IN
COMMUNICATIONS. THIS STUFF
ALREADY KNOWS AND FEELS
COMFORTABLE WITH THEIR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND THE RADIO.
I THINK THINGS AS SIMPLE AS
EMAILING THEM UPDATES ARE
CONTINUING TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
I'M IN THE PROCESS OF HAVING ONE
ON ONE MEETINGS WITH EVERY
SINGLE STAFF MEMBER.
VICKI'S FIRST WEEK HAS INCLUDED
ON IS INCLUDING. A MEANS OF
THESE TEAMS ARMED WITH A WHOLE
LOT OF COOKIES.
AND I KNOW THAT MANAGERS ARE
HAVING. TEAM MEETINGS REGULARLY
AND ONE ON ONES WITH THEIR
TEAMS.
NEXT UP WILL INCLUDE A REGULAR
UPDATES THROUGH SOMETHING THAT.
KIND OF RESEMBLES A NEWSLETTER.
WE'RE LOOKING TO HAVE MONTHLY
BROWN BAGS I THINK SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW THE OUR TEAM IS
DIVIDED.
IN THREE SEPARATE LOCATIONS ARE
BUILDING WHICH.
I THINK IS PROBLEMATIC FOR
COMMUNICATIONS AND MORALE. SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE THE
COMMUNICATIONS TO THEM WE'RE
GONNA GO IN AND SIT IN THEIR
OFFICES. JALAPENO WITH LUNCH
PEOPLE COULD COME AND. JUST CHAT
THEY CAN ASK QUESTIONS OR JUST
HANG OUT.
WILL BE LAUNCHING. AN EMPLOYEE
ENGAGEMENT SURVEY MOST LIKELY
THIS MONTH WHICH WILL REPEAT AT
LEAST ANNUALLY.
WITH SOME FINE TUNING BASED ON
WHAT WE FIND IS. KEY ISSUES THAT
THEY'RE IDENTIFIED BY THE
SURVEY.
AND I WANT TO SAY THE
COMMUNICATIONS OF THE BOARD IS
EVERY BIT AS IMPORTANT. OUR
BOARD MEMBERS REPRESENT THE
PROFESSIONALS WE SERVE. AND OF
COURSE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THEIR EXPERTISE IS ESSENTIAL
IN ACHIEVING OUR MISSION. MY
GOAL IS TO CONTINUE IMPROVING
THAT INCLUSION OF THAT EXPERTISE
AND INCREASING THE EFFICIENCY
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF OUR TIME THAT WE SPEND WITH
THEM. IN TERMS OF COMEDIAN BOARD
MEETINGS WE'RE GOING TO START BY
IMPROVING OUR PREPARATION. FOR
MEETINGS.
AND IF BY ENHANCING THE CALIBER
OF FREQUENCY. OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS AND INTERACTION
WITH THEM IN BETWEEN MEETINGS.
BLUNTLY.
I THINK THAT WE ATE HIS STANDARD
OURS AND SHARPEN THE MANNER IN
WHICH WE ANALYZE AND PRESENT
DATA.
IN ORDER TO BETTER PREPARE AND
SUPPORT THEIR OVERSIGHT IN
POLICY MAKING.
WE ARE ALSO LOOKING INTO WAYS TO
RESTRUCTURE OUR COMMITTEE
STRUCTURES. OF MORE ON THAT AS
WE PROCEED.
BUT ONE OF THE OTHER TOP
PRIORITIES IS OF COURSE
ADDRESSING OUR SOLVENCY. OUR
STAFF HAS BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DC BUDGET OFFICE.
TO ANALYZE OUR OUR OPERATING
EXPENSES AND ANALYZE OUR REVENUE
STREAMS.
OF THE NEXT STEPS WILL INVOLVE
WORKING WITH THE DC LEGISLATIVE
OFFICE AND OF COURSE WE ALREADY
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH. BOTH THE
SENATE SIMPLY STAFF OFFICES AS
WELL. THEY PROVIDED SOME VERY
VERY WELL APPRECIATE INFORMATION
AND AND A. COUNCIL AS WE DRAFT
OUR LEGISLATION TO UPDATE OUR
FEE STRUCTURE FOR BOARDS AND
REVIEW AND APPROVAL LATER. AND
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD BE THE NPT.
AND COMPLIED SETTING MR FEEL
ADMISSION AND COMPLIES WITH. AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE WE HAVE HAD
OUR INITIAL MEETING WITH THE OF
OUR LAST WEEK. TO DISCUSS THE
FUNCTION OPERATIONS. OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAMS. AND OUR
FIRST REPORT TO THE DIRECTOR
LEGISLATURE. HE SAID OUR
PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING THE
MOTORS RECOMMENDATIONS. IS DUE
ON APRIL FIRST.
SO IT CLEARLY YOU HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO AND IT'S GONNA TAKE
SOME TIME. BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT
IN MY MIND THAT ARE SUCH SERVE
YOU IN TWENTY TWENTY.
VERY DIFFERENT DISCUSSION IN THE
LAST YEAR.
IN CLOSING I WOULD BE VERY
NERVOUS I DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THANK OUR BOARD. EMPRESS
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION FOR
THEIR WELCOME AND SUPPORT. AND
BEFORE I HAND THE MIKE OVER TO.
TO TAMMY IT I WONDERED IF THERE
ANY QUESTIONS I MIGHT ANSWER FOR
YOU.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS AT THIS POINT
BUT THERE MAY BE SOME AFTER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LANE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHERRY HILL AND
LOW AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU
AN UPDATE ON THE PROGRESS THAT
WE'VE MADE SENSE THE LAST SUNSET
HEARING.
.
IT'S A WORK IN PROGRESS.
REGARDING RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THEM PERSONALLY MONITOR.
THE WE'VE IMPLEMENTED SIXTEEN OF
THE MONITORS RECOMMENDATIONS WE
HAVE TWENTY SIX RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT.
CURRENTLY ARE PARTIALLY
IMPLEMENTED.
AND WE DO HAVE SIXTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS LEFT TO
IMPLEMENT.
THE ENFORCEMENT STAFF STEPHANIE
WHITLEY FROM DFI AND BRIAN
CLIFFORD FROM DCA. THEY'VE BEEN
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY ARM.
TO ASSIST WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE REMAINING SIXTEEN. AND
COMPLETION OF THE TWENTY SIX
THAT ARE PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED.
AND I KNOW THAT.
.
ALL WERE.
ENFORCEMENT CHIEF BRIAN.
.
HAD WORKED WITH STEPHANIE AND
WHEN. MR BEN FRANKS HAD. BROUGHT
TO THE ATTENTION OF THE.
PROBLEMS THAT AROSE FROM CASES
BEING CLOSE INADVERTENTLY BRIAN
DID LOOK AT POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES AND WITH THE
ASSISTANCE OF DEAL BY. HAS
PLACED.
THE REVAMPED THE POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES TO CORRECT THOSE
ERRORS SO THAT. THEY WILL NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN.
.
SO. THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT FOR
THAT IN AND THEN IN LIGHT OF RE
STARTING.
OF COMMITTEE WORKING LATE TWENTY
SIXTEEN BECAUSE PRIOR TO THAT.
OUR COMMITTEES FOR THE BOARD OF
WORD NOT FUNCTIONING OR WERE
SEIZED.
AT THAT TIME. THE EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE WITH THE EO WILL BE
RECHARGING THE COMMITTEES TO
ENSURE THEIR WORK IS ALIGNED
WITH RELEVANT STRATEGIC GOALS.
.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE LOOK AT
REVAMPING AND RECHARGING OUR
COMMITTEES TO.
GO ALONG WITH OUR. STRATEGIC
GOALS INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YES I AM DECKS OF CARDS SO THANK
YOU MISS BASS IN MY TEENS.
YES I WANT TO TALKWITH YOU AND
THANK YOU BY THE WAY FOR GIVING
US ALL AN OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
BEFORE YOU. AND I THANK YOU FOR
THE HARD WORK YOU DO TO MAKE
SURE WE WORK WELL IN SUPPORT OF
THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A BRIEF
UPDATE ON THE BOARDS PROGRESS IN
STRATEGIC PLANNING.
AND SO WE CAN TELL ME AND I CAME
ON AS THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE. A
WE RECEIVED AT THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
STRATEGIC. PLAN GOALS AND WE
READ VIEW THOSE AS AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE AND IDENTIFY WHICH OF
THOSE GOALS WOULD BE BEST
ADDRESSED BY BOAT RELATED
COMMITTEES AND OF COURSE
STAFFING THAT'S ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE GOALS.
THOSE GOALS WERE THEN FORWARDED.
TO BOARD COMMITTEES ALONG WITH
AS SAMPLES OF BENCHMARKS AND
METRICS ANOTHER WHICH DELIVER
BULL EXPECTATIONS.
AND THE COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH ENSURING THAT THOSE
DELIVERABLES ARE REALISTIC. AS
WELL AS REASONABLE.
AND I JUST WANNAREMIND EVERYONE
THAT COMMITTEES THESE
RECONSTITUTED COMMITTEES.
ARE COMPOSED OF BOARD MEMBERS.
AND INCLUDE STAFF.
WERE RELATED TO THE EACH
COMMITTEE.
THEREFORE IT'S STAFF AND BOARD
MEMBERS TALKING ABOUT FROM A
WORK PERSPECTIVE WHAT IS
REALISTIC AND WHAT CAN BE DONE.
AND THEN OF COURSE BOARD.
BRUCE ARE ENGAGING STAFF AND
BETTER WILL BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW WORK IS DONE.
ADDITIONALLY TO ENSURE THAT THE
THE STRATEGIC PLANNING REMAINS
AN ACTIVE PART OF OUR WORK IS A
BOARD.
WE AS EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WILL
BE PROPOSING THAT THERE BE A
REGULAR.
AND SYSTEMIC STRATEGIC PLANNING
REVIEW AND UPDATE.
SO THAT ONE CAN LOOK FORWARD TO
WHAT I CALL LIVING. STRATEGIC
GOALS.
SO THERE WOULD BE A TWENTY
TWENTY.
A TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND FOR
WHAT.
YOU WANT TO REACH A BENCH MARK
YOU SHOULDN'T STOP THERE. YOU
NEED TO WORK ON WHAT'S NEXT AND
HOW CAN WE GET BETTER.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND I THINK WE'RE ALL READY FOR
YOUR QUESTIONS.
BUT I THINK YOU'VE ANSWERED MANY
OF THEM AND CERTAINLY YOU DID
REMIND OTHER OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM.
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENIOR HEARING NONE THAT TO.
THAT'S A THAT'S A GOOD SIGN AND
THE I HAVE ONE QUESTION I DO
HAVE ONE QUESTION JIM QUESTION.
WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL THE BOXES
OF?
OF CP WEREN'T THEY CERTIFICATES
THAT CAME IN THAT WE SAW LAST
YEAR THAT WERE OF.
WHAT HAPPENED TO ALL OF THOSE?
I'M AFRAID THEY'RE STILL THERE
ARE THEY STILL THERE OKAY WE'RE
WAITING ON COUNCIL TELL ME
WHETHER IT'S RIGHT OR NOT
SHOWCASE VERY GOOD THANK YOU BUT
TO.
I KNOW THAT WAS ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT REALLY BROUGHT US
TO.
AND TO THE POINT WHERE WE
NEEDED TO TAKE SOME ACTION AND
SO THANK YOU FOR FOR ALL THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT WORK I
I'VE. AT LEAST FROM. MY
OBSERVATION OVER THE LAST YEAR.
YOU CAME TOGETHER I THINK THE
BOARD LEARNED A LOT.
AND.
IS CERTAINLY WORKING WITH MR
FRANK. AND THE THE NEW DIRECTION
WITH SOME LEADERSHIP I'VE
BROUGHT IT ALL TOGETHER AND
THANK THANK YOU.
BETTER TO FEEL FOR YOUR YOUR
YOUR HARD WORK IN THE IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S HARD WORKING IN
DOING THIS SO. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW WE KNOW THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE THAT
WILL CONCLUDE THIS PORTION OF IT
AND THANK YOU TO THE IS. THE
BUREAU AND A FIRM FOR THE BOARD
IN I'M SORRY OF OF. LOCATION OR
SHEEN AND A PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT AND FINAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH YOU VERY MUCH.
THE FINAL ITEM WHICH IS THE. OF
THOSE ISSUES ADDRESSED BY THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SO WE HAVE SOMEONE.
REPRESENTATIVE FR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO DISCUSS THE
RECENT REPORT ON CASE TIME LINES
GOOD AFTERNOON.
PLEASE AND AFTERNOON.
CHAIRMAN HELD HER MELLOW AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
BEHALF OF ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE
YOUR BEST SERRA. THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
SERRANO OUT TO PET AND I AM
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'M HERE TODAY WITH GLORIA
CASTRO WHO'S TO MY LEFT.
SHE'S SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF DOJ'S HEALTH QUALITY
ENFORCEMENT SECTION AND TO MY
RIGHT IS LINDA SCHNEIDER WHO IS
SENIOR ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF DOJ'S LICENSING
SECTION.
WE'RE PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
TO DISCUSS THE DOJ'S ROLE IN THE
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS FOR
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
CLIENT AGENCIES. AND. HOW WE ARE
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
FIRST REPORT?
REQUIRED UNDER BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION THREE
ONE TWO POINT TWO.
I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
GLORIA AND LINDA TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF HOW WE FIT INTO DC
IS CONSUMER PROTECTION
ENFORCEMENT INITIATIVE TIMELINE.
AND PROVIDE CONTEXT FOR THE
REPORT WHICH IS BASED ON OUR
HANDLING OF LITIGATION CASES.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND THE
LICENSING SECTION AND THE HEALTH
QUALITY ENFORCEMENT SECTION IN
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
ARE AT THE TWO SECTIONS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROSECUTING.
DISCIPLINARY ACTIONS AGAINST
PROFESSIONAL AND VOCATIONAL
LICENSEES.
BETWEEN THE TWO WE REPRESENT
THIRTY EIGHT DC EIGHT CLIENTS.
WE TAILOR OUR SERVICES TO EACH
OF OUR CLIENTS SPECIFIC NEEDS
AND RESOURCES. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE HIGHEST QUALITY
LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
OUR ROLE IN THE DC ENFORCEMENT
TIMELINE IS TO ADJUDICATE
DISCIPLINARY CASES FOR OUR
CLIENTS.
ENFORCEMENT BEGINS WITH THE DC A
CLIENT AGENCY RECEIVING A
CONSUMER COMPLAINT. AND ENDS
WITH A FINAL DECISION REACHED BY
THE AGENCY.
DOJ'S PART IN THIS PROCESS FALLS
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE.
BEGINNING WITH THE RECEIPT OF
THE REFERRAL FROM OUR CLIENTS.
ENDING WITH THE EDUCATIONOF THE
CASE. AT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
THE DEFINITION OF ADJUDICATION
OF OUR WORK AT THE OFFICE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL MEANS THAT OUR
WORK IS COMPLETED. AND THE
MATTER IS THEN BROUGHT BACK
BEFORE THE CLIENT AGENCY FOR
THEIR FINAL DECISION.
ADJUDICATION OCCURS OF ONE OF
FOUR WAYS. NUMBER ONE SUBTLE MAN
NUMBER TWO DEFAULTS NUMBER THREE
SUBMISSION OF THE MATTER TO THE
OFFICE OF THE ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS. AND FOURTH WITHDRAWAL
OF THE ACCUSATION.
THERE CAN BE MORE THAN ONE
ADJUDICATIVE EVENT AND EACH CASE
SUCH AS WHEN MORE THAN ONE
LICENSEE IS NAMED IN A SINGLE
ACCUSATION OR WHEN THE AGENCY
DOES NOT A STOP EXCEPT. A
PROPOSED SETTLEMENT. OR WHEN THE
CLIENT AGENCY NANA TOPSY
PROPOSED DECISION BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE.
FOR EACH CLIENT THE TOURNEY
GENERAL'S REPORT LISTS THE
VOLUME. OF ANNUAL ACCUSATION
REFERRALS RECEIVED REJECTED OR
RETURNED FOR MORE INVESTIGATION.
THE REPORT ALSO PROVIDES
AVERAGES FOR THE COMPLETION AT
EACH STAGE OF THE PROCESS FOR
THE CASE IS ADJUDICATED DURING
THE REPORTING YEAR.
THE PROSECUTION OF A CASE IS AN
INTERACTIVE PROCESS BETWEEN THE
ASSIGNED DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND OTHER PARTICIPANTS WHICH
TYPICALLY INCLUDE. CLIENTS
LICENSEES AND THEIR COUNSEL
WITNESSES AND THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS. THE
FIRST STEP IN PROSECUTION IS
WHEN A DCA CLIENT REFERS I
COMPLETED INVESTIGATION TO THE
OFFICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
REVIEWS THE CASE TO DETERMINE
WHETHER DISCIPLINARY ACTION IS
APPROPRIATE.
AS DISCUSSED IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REPORT.
WHILE THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATIVE METHODS
USED BY DIFFERENT DCA CLIENT
AGENCIES TO COLLECT EVIDENCE.
EVERY ACCUSATION MATTER REFERRED
TO OUR OFFICE IS REVIEWED BY. A
DEPUTY TO DETERMINE SUFFICIENCY
OF EVIDENCE.
SPECIFICALLY A DEPUTY CAREFULLY
ANALYZES THE EVIDENCE TO
DETERMINE WHERE THE WEATHER IT
IS SUFFICIENT TO MEET THE
STANDARD OF PROOF TO SUSTAIN
DISCIPLINARY CHARGES.THIS
ANALYSIS CAN INCLUDE REVIEW
OF EXPERT AND LAZY WITNESS
STATEMENTS OR TESTIMONY AND
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE SUCH AS
MEDICAL RECORDS.
BECAUSE A LICENSEE A LICENSE AS
A PROPERTY RIGHT A LICENSEE HAS
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS. WHICH REQUIRES THAT WE
MEET A HIGHER BURDEN OF PROOF
BEFORE THE LICENSE IS TAKEN
AWAY.
MOST OFTEN IT IS CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE TO A
REASONABLE CERTAINTY STANDARD.
THAT'S A HIGH STANDARD TO MEET.
IF THE DEPUTY DETERMINES THE
EVIDENCE IS SUFFICIENT TO MEET
THIS BURDEN.
AND THAT ANY STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS DOES NOT BAR
PROSECUTION. THEY WILL DRAFT
ACCUSATIONS SETTING FORTH THE
CLIENT'S JURISDICTION ALLEGES
CHARGES AND RELEVANT STATUTES.
AFTER SUPERVISORY REVIEW THE
DRAFT ACCUSATION IS THEN
PRESENTED TO THE DCA CLIENT
AGENCY FOR ITS REVIEW AND
FILING.
IF THE EVIDENCE. IS NOT
SUFFICIENT.
THE DEPUTY REQUEST FURTHER
INVESTIGATION FROM THE CLIENT.
AS REPORTED FOR EACH AGENCY IF
THIS IS REQUIRED THE COP THAT
TIME TO CONDUCT THE SUPPLEMENTAL
INVESTIGATION IS INCLUDED IN THE
AVERAGE NUMBER OF DAYS.
FROM RESITA REFERRAL INTO THE
ACCUSATION IS PREPARED BY THE
ASSIGNED DEPUTY.
WE IN TRUCKLOADS THING WITH OUR
CLIENTS DURING THIS INITIAL
PHASE TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
CASE SHOULD MOVE FORWARD IN A
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS.
IF THE FILING BURDEN IS NOT AN
ACCUSATION IS DRAFTED. THIS IS
SIGNED TO THE DCA KLEIN AGENCY.
THE CLIENT'S OWN STAFF REVIEWS
THE DRAFT ACCUSATION AND THEN
PRESENTED TO THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OR ANY OTHER AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVE WHO CAN SIGN AS
THE COMPLAINANT IN THE CASE.
THE ACCUSATION IS FILED WHEN IT
IS SIGNED BY THE COMPLAINANT THE
COMPLAINANT BEING IN THE CLIENT
AGENCY.
THE ACCUSATION MAY LATER BE
AMENDED TO ADD AN EXTRA CHARGES.
THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF DAYS FROM
THE RECEIPT OF THE REFERRAL.
UNTIL THE ACCUSATION IS FILED IS
REPORTED FOR EACH AGENCY IN OUR
REPORT.
THIS PERIOD INCLUDES THE TIME TO
REVIEW AND ANALYZE THE EVIDENCE.
LEGAL RESEARCH TO DEPART
DETERMINE APPROPRIATE CHARGES
THE DRAFTING OF THE ACCUSATION.
AND REVIEW BY THE CLIENT AND
AGENCIES FILING OF ACCUSATION.
CASE IS ADJUDICATED BY
SETTLEMENT FOLLOWING
NEGOTIATIONS BETWEEN THE PARTIES
ARE ALSO INCLUDED IN THE REPORT
AS WELL AS DEFAULTS.
THE PROCESS OF SETTING A HEARING
BEFORE THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS. AND THE
TIME IT TAKES TO COMMENCE A
HEARING AS REPORTED FOR EACH
AGENCY IS A VERY INTERACTIVE
PROCESS.
FOR EXAMPLE THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL MUST ENSURE PROPER
VENUE.
THE DEPUTY MUST ENSURE TO BE
ABLE TO COORDINATE POTENTIAL
HEARING DATES WITH OPPOSING
COUNSEL ALL WITNESSES INCLUDING
EXPERT WITNESSES. AS WELL AS THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS ON CARING CALENDAR.
COMPLEX CASES AND THOSE THAT
INVOLVE DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
GENERALLY TAKE LONGER. BECAUSE
IT TAKES MORE TIME TO GET THE
HEARING SCHEDULED.
AND THERE IS A LONGER PERIOD OF
TIME BETWEEN WHEN A HEARING IS
SET TO WIN A HEARING COMMENCES.
IN THE SIMPLEST CASES THAT DO
NOT REQUIRE LIVE TESTIMONY
HEARING MAY COMMENCE WITHIN
NINETY DAYS OR LESS. ON THE
OTHER HAND COMPLEX CASES CAN
REQUIRE SEVERAL WEEKS OF
HEARING.
THE SETTING OF THOSE HEARING
DATES ARE DEPENDENT LIKE WE SAID
ON MANY SCHEDULES.
AND DURING THE TIME BEFORE THE
HEARING DISCOVERIES EXCHANGE AND
REVIEWED SUBPOENAS WERE SERVED.
AND THE FILING OF MOTIONS TO
COMPEL EVIDENCE. INTO EXCLUDED
ARE CONSIDERED. ALL STEPS IN
THIS PROCESS ARE GOVERNED BY THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
WELL NOW GO FOR A FEW HIGHLIGHTS
FROM THE REPORT BUT AS A BRIEF
ASIDE WE WANT TO NOTE THAT
BECAUSE THE LIFE OF A CASE MAY
SPAN MORE THAN ONE FISCAL YEAR.
THE REPORT INCLUDES DATA FROM
CASES THAT MAY HAVE BEEN
REFERRED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE BEFORE THE START OF THE
FIRST DATA COLLECTION PERIOD
WHICH WAS JULY FIRST TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
NOW TO THE MAJOR HIGHLIGHTS.
GENERALLY ABOUT TWELVE PERCENT
OF ACCUSATION MATTERS ARE
RESOLVED AFTER HEARING ON THE
MERITS AT THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS.
DEFAULTS ARE TAKEN AGAINST
LICENSEES IN ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THE CASES.
FINALLY ABOUT SIXTY PERCENT OF
ACCUSATIONS ARE SETTLED EITHER
THROUGH PROBATION TERMS AIMED TO
REHABILITATE THE LICENSEE AS
DICTATED BY THE CLIENT.
DISCIPLINARY GUIDELINES.
OR BY WAY OF REVOCATION OR
SURRENDER OF THE LICENSE. IF
PROBATION IS INCONSISTENT WITH
PUBLIC PROTECTION.
AS EVERYONE ON THIS COMMITTEE
KNOWS THE DISCIPLINE OF
LICENSEES SERVES TWO PURPOSES.
PUBLIC PROTECTION AND
REHABILITATION WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THE PROCESS OF BALANCING BOTH
THE INTERESTS AND THE
REQUIREMENTS OF DUE PROCESS
TAKES TIME.
A TOURNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE IS
AWARE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS CONSUMER
PROTECTION ENFORCEMENT
INITIATIVE OF TWENTY TIMES.
WHICH SET A GOAL OF THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE TO FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY DAYS OR TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
FROM CONSUMER COMPLAINT THROUGH
INVESTIGATION AND PROSECUTION TO
FINAL AGENCY DECISION OR OTHER
OUTCOME.
WHILE WE WERE NOT INVOLVED IN
THE SETTING OF THOSE PERFORMANCE
METRICS WE HAVE ALWAYS BALANCE
EFFECTIVENESS. AND EFFICIENCY AT
EVERY JUNCTURE OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS. THIS
INSURERS EACH LICENSEE THEIR DAY
IN COURT.
AS THEIR CASE IS JUDGED
INDEPENDENTLY ON ITS OWN MERITS.
WE CONSIDER OURSELVES.
OUR CLIENTS PARTNERS
INEFFECTIVELY MOVING THESE CASES
THROUGH THE DISCIPLINARY
PROCESS.
WE HOPE THAT THE PUBLICATION OF
THIS REPORT WILL HELP FACILITATE
AND THAT CONTINUED DIALOGUE TO
FIND EFFICIENCIES ARE POSSIBLE
AND ASSIGN RESOURCES WERE
NEEDED.
IT'S BEEN AN HONOR TO BE
INVOLVED IN THE PROTECTION OF
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS. ARE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH QUESTIONS.
THE COUPLE AND HE IS THE ONE IS
IT IS DIFFICULT FROM THE REPORT.
TO DETERMINE EXACTLY HOW LONG
THE INVESTIGATION WILL TAKE THE.
IN ON AVERAGE SHIP FOR THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO BASICALLY
HANDLE A CASE FROM THE TIME IT
IS REFERRED. TO THE FILING OF AN
ACCUSATION UNTIL A HEARING DATE
IS SET IN THE FINAL DECISION
ISSUED ITS KIND OF THE NUMBERS
ARE LISTED BUT THEY'RE NOT.
THERE'S NO REAL TOTAL OR A WAY
TO LOOK AT EXACTLY HELP LONGER
OR AN ORDER SETTLEMENT. CAN YOU
GIVE US AN IDEA OF HOW LONG THE
CASE CAN TAKE.
FROM THE TIME YOU RECEIVE IT
UNTIL PROPOSED DECISION IS
ISSUED BY L. A. L. J. OR IF IT'S
SETTLED.
I KNOW EACH AGENCY IS DIFFERENT
BUT THE. JUST AN AVERAGE OF HOW
LONG IT MIGHT TAKE WOULD BE
HELPFUL.
IT DEPENDS.
YEAH WE WE HANDLE CASES FOR LOTS
OF DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
SUBJECT MATTERS AND A LOT OF
DIFFERENT FACTORS THAT GO INTO
EACH CLIENT'S WORK.
SO WHEN I SAY IT DEPENDS I DON'T
MEAN TO BE CAVALIER. BUT FOR
EXAMPLE WITH THE FAST TRACK
PROGRAM THAT THE LICENSING
STARTED WITH THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND BE. PART
OF A CASE ON DRESSING AND
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS A COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO. WE TOOK A CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF THEIR CASES THOSE
BEING THE ONES THAT ARE THE.
CASES THAT DON'T REQUIRE
WITNESSES AND WE PUT THEM SORT
OF ON A FAST TRACK TO MOVE THEM
FORWARD QUICKLY.
UNDER THE THEORY THAT WE DON'T
WANT THOSE SIMPLER CASE IS TO
SIMPLY GET IN LINE BEHIND ALL
THE OTHER CASES THAT MAY BE MORE
COMPLICATED.
SO IN THAT BATCH OF WORK WE WERE
ABLE TO MOVE THOSE CASES FORWARD
VERY QUICKLY. AND THE
INVESTIGATIVE PIECE THAT YOU
MENTIONED ISN'T PRESENT BECAUSE
THE CASES ARE CASTIGATED ON THE
FRONT END BY THE CLIENT AGENCIES
AND THEN SENT TO US. AND ONE OF
OUR REQUIREMENTS FOR TO GO INTO
OUR FAST TRACK PROGRAM IS THAT
EVERYTHING IS GONNA BE THERE.
SO THOSE CASES WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO MOVE FORWARD VERY QUICKLY AND
NOW MAY BE AND AND THE OTHER
PART OF IT IS. THAT IF CASES.
SETTLE. THEIR GOING TO RESOLVE
MUCH MORE QUICKLY THAN A CASES
GO TO HEARING. SO IN THAT BATCH
OF CASES THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THEM ARE SETTLED. AND SO WITH
ALL OF THOSE THINGS IN MIND THEY
CAN BE DONE AND REALLY VERY
QUICKLY ON MAYBE AN AVERAGE OF.
YEAH NINETY TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DAYS.
BUT HEN ON THE OTHER HAND YOU
TAKE SOMETHING LIKE.
A DENTAL BOARD CASE. WHERE YOU
MAY HAVE A VARIETY OF CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS AGAINST A DENNIS SAID
OF EACH HAD TO BEEN INVESTIGATED
AND ALL INVOLVED? PATIENT
RECORDS AND THAT SORT OF THING
AND THAT'S GOING TO MOST LIKELY
HAVE OPPOSING COUNSEL THE CASES
ARE GOING TO BE MUCH MORE HARD
FOUGHT.
AND THOSE CAN TAKE MUCH MUCH
LONGER. SO NO ONE MESSAGE WE'D
LIKE TO BRING BACK IS THAT IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
FOR HANDLING OUR CASES NOR WOULD
I THINK IT BE HELPFUL TO HAVE
JUST A. SINGULAR CONCEPT UP HOW
LONG CASES SHOULD TAKE.
THEN IN THAT A HIKE I CAN SEE
WHERE THAT WOULD WOULD PLAY OUT
OF.
AND AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
IDENTIFIER DEFINED WITHIN ONE
PARTICULAR CASE IN IT YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO ONE SIZE FITS ALL
OBVIOUSLY IN THOSE BUT.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN A CONCERN OF
OURS IN ONE ISSUE THAT I KNOW IS
BEEN RAISED HIS.
UNDER THEIR WHEN THEY WERE
INSTANCES WHERE BOARDS MAY
PROVIDE.
DENTAL EVIDENCE OF VIOLATIONS.
OF THE LAW IT DIRECTLY TO YOUR
STAFF WHICH DOES NOT GO THROUGH
A. A IS TO DIVIDE INVESTIGATOR
SHOW WHICH IS CLEARLY HERE'S THE
VIOLATION.
I KNOW THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD HAS ITS OWN
INVESTIGATORS AND THEY SOMETIMES
WILL DO THAT.
BORDER FOR FOR THAT OR FOR
FINDINGS DIRECTLY TO YOU. OF
WHEN THEY BELIEVE INSPECTORS ARE
THERE ON SWORN INVESTOR STAFF OF
UNCOVERED MAJOR ISSUES. ARE
THERE CERTAIN CASES THAT ALWAYS
NEED. A DEPARTMENT OF UPPER
DIVISION OF INVESTIGATIONS.
INVESTIGATOR.
INVESTIGATION.
OR CAN YOU ACT ON JUST FACTS
THAT ARE BROUGHT TO YOU
VIOLATIONS OF OF OF LONG.
THAT'S A THAT'S A VERY GOOD
QUESTION SENATOR HELL. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS REPORT WILL BE
ABLE TO SHOW OUR CLIENTS
SPECIFICALLY WITH THEIR OWN
CASELOADS. HOW FREQUENTLY THEIR
CASES REQUIRE FURTHER
INVESTIGATION BEFORE AN
ACCUSATION CAN BE FILED? IN THE
ANSWER TO THE SECOND PART YOUR
QUESTION AS.
EVEN THOUGH WE CAN USE DEPUTIES
TO ASSIST OUR CLIENTS.
FROM TIME TO TIME IT DOES
REQUIRE SWORN FOR NON SWORN
INVESTIGATOR BECAUSE THEY WILL
BE THE WITNESSES IN THE CASE.
WE BELIEVE OUR REPORT.
WILL ALLOW OUR CLIENTS TO
COMPARE THEIR FREQUENCY OF CASES
THAT WE HAVE TO SEND BACK FOR
MORE INVESTIGATION.
MISSION LIGHTER AND I BELIEVE
THAT BOTH SECTIONS TOGETHER OR
OVERALL AVERAGE IS TEN PERCENT
SO CLIENTS CAN COMPARE HOW THEY
FALL. WITHOUT AVERAGE.
AND WE TRY TO AVOID HAVING TO
SEND CASES BACK FOR MORE
INVESTIGATION OBVIOUSLY AND. OUR
SHOP IN LINDA'S LEAD TO A LOT OF
TRAINING OF INVESTIGATIONS
INVESTIGATORS AT.
WE ALSO PROVIDE LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE RECENTLY.
LINDA SHOP PROVIDED A BEER AND
INVESTIGATORS AND BOTH NORTH AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TRAINING. AS
WELL AS PRIVACY PROTECTION
TRAINING. AND JUST LAST WEEK OUR
OFFICES WERE PROVIDING TRAINING
WAS SOLID. AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS FOR THEIR
ENFORCEMENT ACADEMY SO IT IS A
MUTUAL GOAL THAT THESE
INVESTIGATIONS BE DONE TO THE
BEST QUALITY POSSIBLE AND WE
CONSIDER SOULS PARTNERS AND
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN THEY SEND
US CASES. THEY'RE READY TO GO.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IN WASTING TIME
EITHER.
IT WHEN YOU MENTION NON SWORN WE
WERE TALKING RIVERS BEGIN NON
SWORN. WITHIN THE DEVICE OR NON
SWORN WITHIN THE BOARD.
AND THERE'S NOT SWORN INDIA BY A
AND H. COULD YOU.
BUT IT.
AS WE MENTIONED IN OUR REPORT
THERE'S. MANY MANY INVESTIGATIVE
METHODS THERE'S NON SWORN. AT
EITHER WITH THE CLIENT. OR AT
DFI. I'M SOME CLIENTS HAVE
INSPECTORS FOR EXAMPLE BOARD OF
PHARMACY EMPLOYEES INSPECTORS
WHO HAPPENED TO BE PHARMACISTS.
ON MANY OF OUR CLIENTS AND H.
CUTIE. ACTUALLY HELP DESK
INVESTIGATION SO OUR LIAISONS
TRAIN.
DESK INVESTIGATORS ARE NOT
SWORN THEY'RE NOT NON SWORN
THEIR STAFF MEMBERS AND WE HELP
THEM WITH THEIR CASES. AND.
OF COURSE YOU'VE ALL HEARD OF
pTHERE'S ALSO A A LIGHTER METHOD
WHERE IT'S A LIGHTER TOUCH THE
LIAISON MAY BE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY ON AN ENTRANCES MENTION
ORDER WITH DFI INVESTIGATORS AND
LINDA'S.
SHOP. THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS
IS TO COMMUNICATE IF PROCESS
IT'S A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE ALL WANT TO ACHIEVE
PUBLIC PROTECTION. AND
REHABILITATE THE LICENSEES THAT
SHOULD BE REHABILITATED THEY'RE
GOOD THANK YOU FOR MUCH OF ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE QUESTION JEAN
NONE WILL NOW OPEN THIS TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IS THERE ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO. CONTRIBUTE OR
ASK THE MAKE SOME PUBLIC COMMENT
RELATED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS.
BUT TO PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND WE WERE LIMITED TO MINUTES.
GET.
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU TO THE GERMAN HELEN
GERMAN LOW IN NUMBERS. MY NAME
IS CONNIE VALENTINE AND FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECTIVE PARENTS
ASSOCIATION.
I AM BRINGING AN ISSUE OF GREAT
CONCERN ABOUT TWO OF THE.
MEMBER AGENCIES. AT THE BOARD
OF PSYCHOLOGY IN THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES.
THE BACKGROUND IS CHILD CUSTODY
DISPUTES. WHEN THEY OCCUR FAMILY
COURTS MAY APPOINT PRIVATE
EVALUATORS.
THEY'RE LICENSED UNDER THESE TWO
BOARDS.
WHEN THE ALLEGATIONS OF CHILD
SEX ABUSE. THESE EVALUATORS ARE
SUPPOSED TO FOLLOW CERTAIN
PROTOCOLS IN FAMILY CODE THIRTY
ONE EIGHTEEN.
HOWEVER THEY'RE OFTEN APPOINTED
UNDER EVIDENCE CODE SEVEN THIRTY
EXPERT WITNESS CODE.
AND SEEM NOT TO FOLLOW THESE
PROTOCOLS.
THESE PROFESSIONALS ARE NOT
REGULATED. AND THEY CHARGE
WHATEVER THE MARKET WILL BEAR UP
TO SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
SINGLE EVALUATION.
THE LITIGANTS ARE FORCED TO PAY
THESE FEES. THE COURTS DO NOT
PAY THEM.
.
THAT PLUS THE PROFESSIONALS HAVE
IMMUNITY BECAUSE THEIR COURT
APPOINTED.
THESE ARE CONSIDERED PREDATORY
PRACTICES BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
REGULAR REGULATION.
VERY OFTEN THEY'RE PAID BY THE
ACCUSED PERSON IN THE CASE. AND
THEY RECOMMENDED CUSTODY TO THE
ACCUSED.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT SEVENTY
THREE PERCENT OF THE PARENTS WHO
ARE TRYING TO PROTECT THEIR
CHILDREN. LOST CUSTODY BECAUSE
THE COURT FOLLOWED THESE
PROFESSIONALS RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE PROBLEM IS IS THE OVERSIGHT
AGENCIES THE BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY
IN THE BOARD OF ABOVE OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES. SAY THE
COURT HAS OVERSIGHT OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS BECAUSE THEY'RE
QUITE A POINT COURT APPOINTED.
HOWEVER THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
SAYS THAT THE PROFESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES HAVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THEM BECAUSE
THEY'RE LICENSED.
THIS HOT POTATO HAS BEEN IN PLAY
FOR ABOUT A DECADE.
SO WE'RE NOW TURNING TO YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
TO HELP US SORT THIS OUT. WE'RE
NOT SURE WHERE TO GO FROM HERE.
I WOULD LIKE ANY KIND OF
FEEDBACK YOU'D LIKE TO GIVE US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE COMMENT NEXT TO.
YEAH GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR HELL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S KATHLEEN RUSSELL WITH THE
CENTER FOR JUDICIAL EXCELLENCE
BASED SIMMERING COUNTY
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE ALSO HERE
WITH CONCERNS ABOUT THE BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND THE
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY.
.
TO BE CLEAR COUNTLESS INNOCENT
CHILDREN ARE BEING FORCED INTO
LIFETIMES OF SEXUAL SLAVERY OR
ONGOING PHYSICAL ABUSE BY A
PARENT AS A DIRECT RESULT OF.
LICENSEES OF THE BOP IN BBS WHO
ARE UTILIZING JUNK SCIENCE.
WHICH HAS BEEN.
DEBUNKED BY EVERY CREDIBLE
MEDICAL LEGAL AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATION AT
LEAST FIFTY THREE CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN MURDERED. BY
A DIVORCING ARE SEPARATING
PARENT IN THE LAST DECADE. FIFTY
THREE MURDER CHILDREN IS LIKE
THREE OF THE MASS SHOOTINGS THAT
JUST OCCURRED AT MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL.
THESE ARE SERIOUS CASES.
THESE BOARDS HAVE A DUTY TO
PROTECTTHE PUBLIC FROM
MISCONDUCT BUT THEY'RE FAILING
MISERABLY WITH DISCIPLINE RATES
THAT MIRROR THOSE THAT
WARRANTED.
A J. LACK AUDIT OF THE
COMMISSION ON JUDICIAL
PERFORMANCE.
JUST O REQUESTS OF THE DCA
REGARDING THESE BOARDS. I KNOW
THAT LAST YEAR AS PART OF THE
BACKGROUND PAPER FOR THE SUNSET
REVIEW HEARING. THERE WERE
PRIORITIZATION GUIDELINES ISSUED
BY THE DC EIGHT TO ITS MEMBER
BOARD SENDEROS. WE'VE BEEN TO
FOUR OUT OF THE LAST FIVE BOARD
OF PSYCHOLOGY MEETINGS OVER THE
LAST YEAR. AND IT APPEARS TO US
THAT THESE GUIDELINES ARE NOT
BEING UTILIZED ALL OF THE
COMPLAINTS THAT WE DEAL WITH IN
HERE ON A DAILY BASIS ARE.
URGENT.
COMPLAINTS AND THEY CONTINUE TO
GO AND PERSIST FOR.
UPWARDS OF THREE OR FOUR YEARS.
THERE'S A WASHINGTON POST
MAGAZINE ARTICLE WHICH I'VE SENT
TO YOUR STAFF FOR THIS HEARING.
WAS EIGHT EIGHT PAGE ARTICLE OF
COVER FEATURE STORY LAST MAY
THAT CALLS OUT A BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY FOR NOT INVOLVE
GETTING INVOLVED IN. WHAT IS
ALSO A PROBLEM IS MULTIPLE
LICENSEES HAVE MULTIPLE
COMPLAINTS THOUGH SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED SO? WE STRONGLY URGE
THE DCA TO UPDATE OR REVISE ITS
PRIORITIZATION GUIDELINES FOR
ALL BOARDS AND BUREAUS. TO
ENSURE THAT INVESTIGATIONS OF
LICENSEES WITH MULTIPLE URGENT
COMPLAINTS BE PRIVATE BE
PRIORITIZED ABOVE ALL OTHERS.
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY PLEASE
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HOLD THE
BOARDS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THESE GUIDELINES.
WE HEARD AT THE BERKELEY MEETING
LAST FALL AT THE BOARD OF
PSYCHOLOGY. THE TWENTY ONE
LICENSEES HAVE TWO TO FIVE
COMPLAINTS PENDING. AGAINST EACH
AND.
TOTAL ABOUT TOTALS FIFTY
COMPLAINTS ONE LICENSEE HAS FOUR
COMPLAINTS AND ANOTHER HAS FIVE.
AND WE'RE FAIRLY CERTAIN THE
WASHINGTON POST MAGAZINE FEATURE
WAS DEALING WITH ONE OF THOSE
THAT HAD FOUR OR FIVE
COMPLAINTS.
AGAINST HIM FINALLY.
AND WE WOULD ALSO URGE THE DCA
TO INSIST THAT THE BOARD OF
PSYCH IN THE BBS ADOPTIVE
VERTICAL ENFORCEMENT AND
PROSECUTION MODEL FOR ALL URGENT
CASES INVOLVING CHILDREN.
SIMILAR TO THE ONE THAT'S USED
BY THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA THESE OUR CHILDREN'S
LIVES AND THEY'RE OFTEN BEING
FORCED INTO. DANGEROUS HOMES OR
THEY'RE BEING BEATEN RAPED
MOLESTED AND SOMETIMES KILLED SO
WAITING THREE TO FOUR YEARS IS
DESTROYING CALIFORNIA CHILDREN
THANK YOU SPECIAL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL LOOK INTO THAT I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT AFTERNOON
CHERRY HILL THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US MY NAME IS KATHERINE CAMPBELL
LINE FROM YOUR DISTRICT. AND I'M
HERE FOR THE SAME ISSUE I'M HERE
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT CHILDREN.
ARE BEING ABUSED.
THEY'RE BEING. PHYSICALLY HURT.
AND THEY'RE BEING.
THEY'RE BEING RAPED. BY A PARENT
BECAUSE AN EVALUATOR WHO HAS A
LICENSE WITH THE BOARD.
IS WORKING WITH HIM.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT CULTURE
THEY'RE WORKING WITHIN.
AND THEY'RE WORKING WITHIN A
CULTURE THAT THIS IS ACCEPTABLE
THAT CHILDREN ARE. ALLOWED TO BE
WITH AN ABUSIVE PARENT. IN
CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE AN EIGHTY
FIVE PERCENT CHANCE OF LOSING
CUSTODY IF YOU REPORT ABUSE.
DURING A DIVORCE AND THIS
HAPPENS I'M IF YOUR CHILD IS NOT
BEING PROTECTED.
BYE CPS OR WHATEVER IT'S CALLED
IN YOUR COUNTY.
YOU END UP IN COURT TO PROTECT
YOUR CHILD AND THEN YOU WERE
LOOKED UPON AS A PERSON WHO.
IS OUT FOR REVENGE IS DELUSIONAL
IS.
TELLING THE CHILD THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T LIKE THE OTHER PARENT.
WE END UP. HAVING THESE PARENTS
GO TO THESE EVALUATORS WITH
THESE.
BOARD OF PSYCHOLOGY AND BOARD OF
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES LICENSE IS.
AND THESE ARE PEOPLE ARE
DISMISSING ABUSE AND WHEN
REPORTS ARE FILED AGAINST SOME
COMPLAINTS.
FIRST OFF.
THOSE CHILDREN REMAIN WITH THEIR
ABUSER.
AND THEN YOU'RE HAVING OTHER
FAMILY SEE THE SAME EVALUATOR.
WE NEED TO PUT INTO PLACE AT AN
EVALUATOR. A LICENSEE CAN. CAN
BE PUT ON SUSPENSION WHILE THIS
IS BEING REVIEWED THREE TO FOUR
YEARS.
THERE IS NO REASON WHY OTHER
PEOPLE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO BE
HURT.
SO WE WANT TO ME POLICIES WE
WANT OVERSIGHT FOR THESE BOARDS
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU I HAVE
SEEN MANY COMPLAINTS ARE VALID
AND HAVE BEEN DISMISSED.
AND THERE'S NO REASON FOR THAT
SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS. AND YOUR.
AND WE HOPE THAT WE'RE BUILDING
AWARENESS TO BRING POSITIVE
CHANGE. INCLUDED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE TESTIMONY YOU ARE
BUILDING AWARENESS RIGHT NOW SO
THANK YOU WE WILL BE LOOKING
INTO. THOSE ISSUES AND THANK YOU
FOR COMING FORWARD TODAY. TO LET
US KNOW WHICH IS THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT SO THANK
YOU AND I WILL SAY I KNOW THIS
IS YOUR MEETING BUT I'M A LITTLE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE DIRECTOR
HAS LEFT BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU AND WE DID TALK WITH
HIM AND AND.
WEEKLY LET HIM KNOW THAT HE WAS
THAT HE COULD LEAVE BUT WE.
INSENSITIVITY THE PUBLIC COMMENT
BUT WE WILL TALK WITH HIM ABOUT
THIS SO PRESSURED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT AND. NO OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
WE WILL CONCLUDE THE HEARING AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND RESPONDED TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
THE HONDA THIS WILL CONCLUDE OUR
OVERSIGHT HEARING AND OUR SUNSET
REVIEW HEARINGS FOR THIS YEAR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT. AND I
WANTED TO SPEAK FOR A
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW WHO HAD TO GO
THROUGH SECTION OR HE WOULD BE
HERE AND THANK YOU AS WELL SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. APPRECIATED
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED